GONNA GET GOING HERE THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE THAT TODAY. IS
A DAY WILL TALK ABOUT ARCADE
TWELVE SCHOOLS TO DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AT PRIMARILY FOCUSING
ON THE LC FF
A FUNDING FORMULA.
AND TALK ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET.
THIS WAS ISSUE TOO WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR A FEW ELSE IF THAT
PROPOSAL'S FRIEND.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MEMBERS THE
LEGISLATURE AND DOWN.
AND THAT THE PUBLIC AS WELL.
AS AS WELL ISSUE NUMBER THREE
WE'RE GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT
OUR STATE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM.
SO SO WITH THAT WOULD START WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET.
WE HAVE DEPARTMENT HAVE.
ABOUT FINANCE ELIO THE CURRENT
EDUCATION OUR FIRST PANEL AND
OUR SECOND PANEL WE HAVE AYE
PRACTITIONERS FROM. DISTRICTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT.
WHAT ELSE THE FF LOOKS LIKE ON
THE GROUNDS? SIX YEARS LATER.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL ON THAT
BEGIN WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
NARRATIVE US DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
GONNA PRESENT YOU JUST WITH A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR.
ELSE IF F. PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THAT SOME
CONTACTS AS WELL OF THAT THE.
FUNDING FORMULA.
AND THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PROPOSAL INCLUDES
AN INCREASE OF ABOUT TWO POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
LOCAL TROLL FUNDING FORMULA.
THAT GETS US TO FULL
IMPLEMENTATION.
TWO YEARS AHEAD OF THE ORIGINAL
SCHEDULE AND PUTS TOLD US IF A
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET YEAR JUST
ABOVE SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS.
AND IT BRINGS A TOTAL OF NEW
ONGOING FUNDING THAT SCHOOLS
RECEIVE A SENSE TWENTY THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN.
THE TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS.
AS PART OF ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORT PROPOSAL TO FULLY FUND
THE LC FF IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THE MINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
APPROPRIATE THE REMAINING GAP
FUNDING AS A PERCENTAGE INSTEAD
OF A FIXED DOLLAR AMOUNT. USING
A PERCENTAGE TO CLOSE THE
REMAINING GAP PROVIDES THE
FOLLOWING BENEFITS.
WANTED ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO CALCULATE A PORTION
IS PRECISELY AT A HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE TARGET LEVELS FOR
EACH ELIA.
.
WHICH PREVENTS OVER OR UNDER
FUNDING OF THE LC FF NUMBER TWO
IT PROVIDES ELEAZAR AT THAT
LEVEL OF CERTAINTY WHEN
PROVIDING THEY'RE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGETS THIS COMING
SUMMER. BECAUSE THEY WILL KNOW
THE EXACT AMOUNT THAT THEY CAN
EXPECT TO RECEIVE AN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN RATHER THAN THEIR
PROPORTIONATE SHARE OF SOME
FIXED DOLLAR AMOUNT OF THE
STATEMENT.
AND THREE IT REDUCES WORKLOAD
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
BY ELIMINATING MUCH OF THE
ITERATIVE PROCESS THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED IN ORDER TO APPROPRIATE
A FIXED DOLLAR AMOUNT LIKE I
MENTIONED.
THIS PROPOSAL HOWEVER DOES NOT
AFFECT ANY ABILITY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
TO AUGMENT THE LC FF IN EXCESS
OF THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION
AMOUNT THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
CURRENTLY.
UNDER THE LCF HALF OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH STUDENT
POPULATIONS OF HIGH NEED AS
DETERMINED BY PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS QUALIFYING FOR FREE
INTRODUCED PRICED LUNCH FOSTER
YOUTH.
OR ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
A BIRTHDAY RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN THE FORM OF
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
GRANTS IN ADDITION TO THEIR PER
EIGHTY A SPACECRAFT AMOUNTS.
PRE LCF.
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH ALLOCATED BASED ON
HISTORICALLY SET REVENUE LIMITS
IN PARTICIPATION IN CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS.
WITH LIMITED FLEXIBILITY HOW
FUNDS WERE ACTUALLY SPENT IN
MOST DISTRICTS OPERATE WITH A
HEAVILY COMPLIANCE ORIENTED
MINDSET.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF LC FF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ALL THEIR REVENUE
LIMIT FUNDING AND THE MAJORITY
OF THEIR CATEGORICAL FUNDING
ROLLED INTO THEIR OUT OF
ENTITLEMENT AS A FLOOR.
WITH THE STATE APPROPRIATING GOT
FUNDING OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
TAB EVERYONE REACH THEIR TARGET
LEVEL OF FUNDING UNDER THEY'LL
CFF SIMILARLY WITH THE PASSAGE
OF ELSE IF OF. COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION ALSO RECEIVED AN OUNCE
IF A FORMULA THAT OPERATE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND CHARTER
SCHOOL FORMULA. WITH ADDITIONAL
WEIGHT GIVEN TO STUDENTS OF HIGH
NEED.
ADDITIONALLY COUNTY OFFICES
RECEIVE FUNDING BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITHIN THEIR COUNTY AND THE
OVERALL COUNTY WHITE ATA IN
RECOGNITION OF THEIR COUNTY WIDE
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE OVERSIGHT
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION HAVE
BEEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED ONTO
THEIR ELSE IF OF TARGET AMOUNT
SINCE THE FOURTEENTH FIFTEEN
YEAR. AND THEIR ANNUAL KINDA
MINUTES APPROXIMATELY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS.
NOW THAT SCHOOL THIS RECEIVE
ALMOST ALL THEIR FUNDING THROUGH
THE LC FF THEY HAVE
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF
DISCRETION TO BEST ADDRESS THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY NEEDS ALONG WITH
REQUIREMENTS PROMOTE LOCAL
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT. AND
INVOLVEMENT WITH IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS AS PART OF THAT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS ARE EL
CAPS.
IN AN EFFORT TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENT SEE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND COMMUNITY.
ENGAGEMENT.
IN ORDER TO MAKE IT MORE
MEANINGFUL AND EFFECTIVE
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
REQUIRING ELEAZAR. THROUGH A
BUDGET CROSSWALK DOCUMENT TO
SHOW HOW THEIR BUDGET
EXPENDITURES ALIGNED WITH THE
STRATEGIES DETAILED IN THEIR EL
CAPS FOR SERVING STUDENTS
GENERATING SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION GRANTS.
THE BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES THAT
THE CITY MAKE AVAILABLE ON A
SINGLE WEBSITE.
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF SUPPLEMENTAL
AND CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDING
PROVIDED TO EACH ELLIOTT UNDER
THE ELSE HERE TOUGH.
THIS PROPOSAL IS NOT INTENDED TO
IMPROVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY EFFORTS ALONE IN
ISOLATION RATHER IT IS VIEWED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION AS PART OF
THE LARGER EFFORT TO IMPROVE.
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN SCHOOL
DISTRICT DECISION MAKING IT AND
CAPACITY BUILDING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THROUGH THE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM SUPPORT IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE OUTCOMES
STUDENTS.
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE LAST PANEL
TODAY
YOU CAN JUST ABOUT THE STATEWIDE
SPAT.
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT WILL BE ABLE
DISCUSS THAT STRUCTURE IN OUR
INTENT AS WELL IN GREATER
DETAIL.
I WITHOUT OUR CONCLUDE MY
PRESENTATION I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU ELIA.
GOOD MORNING RUN ANDERSON WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WILL BE SPEAKING THIS MORNING
FROM A HANDOUT THAT WAS JUST
PASSED OUT TO YOU. BUT SO WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S FOR FISCAL PROPOSALS
REGARDING LCF OF BUT WE DO THINK
THAT THIS.
MELISSA MOMENT OF.
POTENTIALLY ACHIEVING FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LC A FIVE.
OFFERS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE TO ENGAGE IN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT. WHAT WAS
THIS POLICY CHANGE THAT WE MADE
IN THIRTEEN FOURTEEN ONE FAX HAS
IT HAD ON SCHOOL FINANCE? AND
WHAT CHANGES CAN WE MAKE GOING
FORWARD. ON THE FIRST PAGE OF
THIS HANDOUT WE TALK ABOUT THE
MOST BASIC ELEMENTS OF LC FF
WHICH IS THE.
A BASED GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDING
THAT'S OFFERED TO EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT ACCORDING TO THESE FOUR
DIFFERENT GRADE SPEND
CATEGORIES.
AND THE CENTRAL QUESTION HERE
IS.
NOW THAT WE'RE REACHING FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OR REACHING THE
STATUTORY.
BASEBAND RATES.
WHAT ARE THESE RATES HOW WHERE
THEY SAID?
BUT THERE WERE A COUPLE STEPS
THAT WERE TAKEN AT THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN FIRST WE STARTED WITH
WHAT WERE. OF THE AVERAGE
GENERAL PURPOSE FUNDING AMOUNTS
PROVIDED FOR EACH OF THESE
GRADES SPANS.
THEY AND THE PRE RECESSION ERA
SO WE RESTORED THE CUTS THAT
WERE MADE DURING THE RECESSION
WE ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION. THAT
WAS OUR STARTING POINT.
I TO WE ADJUSTED EACH OF THOSE
UPWARDS BY ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
ESTO BROWN NUMBER.
AND THEN THREE WE MADE
ADDITIONAL UPWARD ADJUSTMENTS TO
TO AT THE BASE RATES TO THE K.
THREE BASE RATE AND TO THE HIGH
SCHOOL BATES RATE THOSE VERSES
FOR SPECIFIC POLICY PURPOSES.
IT WAS TO SUPPORT CLASS SIZE
REDUCTION IN THE EARLIER GRADES
INTO SUPPORT CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION IN HIGH SCHOOL.
NOW THIS IS ALL THE SAY THAT.
.
WHEN ASKING THE QUESTION WHAT
ARE THESE BASE RATES HOW WERE
THEY SAID. THAT IT WAS A VERY AD
HOC PROCESS IT WAS NOT INTENDED
TO REPRESENT THE STATE'S FINAL
ANSWER ON THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING LEVEL. FOR
K. TWELVE SCHOOLS THESE WERE
MODERATELY AMBITIOUS TARGETS AND
NOW THAT WE'VE REACHED THEM WE
HAVE TO REVISIT THE QUESTION OF.
OF WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
FUNDING LA AMOUNT TO WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE VERSUS TARGETED FUNDING.
DOWN THE TARGETED FUNDING
QUESTION WE WE CAN DEAL WITH
THAT ON THE SECOND PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT.
AND THAT'S THE SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION GRANTS IN MANY
WAYS THESE WERE LCF APPS
PROPOSED SUCCESSOR TO THE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING THAT WAS
PROVIDED. UNDER THE PREVIOUS
FINANCE SYSTEM BUT THEY DIFFER
FROM THAT CATEGORICAL FUNDING IN
TWO IMPORTANT WAYS.
BUT THE FIRST IS THAT IT'S
NOTABLY LARGER THAN THE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING THAT WAS
ROLLED AND IF IF YOU TAKE ALL OF
A CAN CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THAT
WERE ROLLED INTEL CFF. YOU JUST
THAT FUNDING FOR INFLATION.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A LITTLE
LESS THAN SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS ROLLED IN. A THE ACTUAL
VALUE OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION GRANTS IS A LITTLE
OVER NINE BILLION DOLLARS.
AT A SECOND WAVE DIFFERENCES
IT'S MUCH MORE TARGETED A
SCHOOLS COULD RECEIVE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING FOR A
NUMBER.
OF REASONS UNDER THE PREVIOUS.
SCHOOL FINANCE SYSTEM BUT UNDER
LC FF THEY CAN ONLY RECEIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
GRANT FUNDING.
FOR THE SPECIFIC STERN
POPULATIONS THAT THEY SERVE SO
ONLY SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
SERVING.
OF LOW INCOME OR ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS. RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING IN ONLY AT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT SERVE AN AWFUL
LOT OF THOSE CHILDREN ARE
RECEIVING CONCENTRATION GRANT
FUNDING.
NO THIS IS NOT TO SAY THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT DON'T
SERVE THOSE STUDENTS WERE
COMPLETELY LEFT IN THE COLD
UNDER LC FF. AS WE DESCRIBED ON
PAGE THREE OF THE HANDOUT LC FF
DID INCLUDE A NUMBER OF. ADD ON
PROGRAMS THAT THE DIRECT SOME
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WERE
RECEIVING MORE FUNDING UNDER THE
PREVIOUS FINANCE SYSTEM THAN
THEY WOULD. UNDER THE BASIC
BASED SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
FORMULA UNDER LC FF.
BUT IT IS TO SAY THAT GENERALLY
SPEAKING LCF EFFORTS MUCH MORE
TARGETED TOWARDS DISTRICTS THAT
SERVE LOW INCOME ENGLISH HONORS
STUDENTS.
NOW CONSEQUENTLY AS WE SHOWN ON
PAGE FOUR.
SPENDING DIFFERENCE FOR THOSE
HIGH POVERTY DIFFERENT THAT
DISTRICTS IS NOTABLY LARGER NOW
THAN IT WAS UNDER THE OLD
FINANCE SYSTEM. NOW EVEN UNDER
THE OLD FINANCE SYSTEM.
HIGH POVERTY DISTRICTS IN IN
HERE WE'RE DESCRIBING HIGH
POVERTY DISTRICTS AS THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT SERVE MORE THAN
EIGHTY PERCENT ENGLISH SIREN LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. AND THEY SPEND
ABOUT FOURTEEN PERCENT MORE THAN
NO POVERTY DISTRICTS.
WELL THAT'S GROWN UP
SIGNIFICANTLY TO ABOVE TWENTY
THREE PERCENT AT THAT STARTING
PLACE REFLECTS THE FACT THAT WAS
SOME TARGETING UNDER THE
PREVIOUS FINANCE SYSTEM BUT.
THEY'RE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
TARGETING NOW.
THAT DESPITE THE FACT THAT. HIGH
POVERTY DISTRICTS SPEND A LOT
MORE THAN THE POVERTY DISTRICTS
WE DO FIND EH AS WE.
POINT ON ON PAGE FIVE THAT
THEIR BASE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO BE SOMEWHAT POORER
THAN THOSE THAT ARE OFFERED BY
LOW POVERTY DISTRICTS. IN
PARTICULAR IF YOU LOOK AT CLASS
SIZES THOSE TEND TO BE LARGER.
IN YOUR HIGH POVERTY DISTRICTS
IF YOU LOOK AT TEACHER PAY
ATTENTION BE LOWER IN YEAR HIGH
POVERTY DISTRICTS.
NOW THAT THIS MIGHT BE A LITTLE
COUNTERINTUITIVE MOST OF WHAT
SCHOOL SPENDING THEIR GENERAL
PURPOSE FUNDING ON IT IS
TEACHERS SALARIES CITY. YES A
QUESTION IF A DISTRICT IS
RECEIVING.
TWENTY PERCENT MORE THAN ANOTHER
DISTRICT BUT THEY'RE PAYING
THEIR TEACHERS LESSEN THEIR
HIRING FEWER TEACHERS HOW IS
THAT POSSIBLE WHEN THE ANSWER IS
THAT. THESE HIGH POVERTY
DISTRICTS ARE SPENDING AN AWFUL
LOT OF THEIR BUDGETS AND
SERVICES THAT LOW POVERTY
DISTRICTS EITHER DO NOT OFFER OR
DO NOT OFFER TO THE SAME EXTENT.
LASER A TRUANCY PREVENTION
PROGRAMS.
AT SCHOOL SECURITY SCHOOL
HEALTH AT THESE PROGRAMS.
TAKE A SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH CHUNK
OUT OF THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BUDGETS THAT THEY HAVE LAST.
LEFT OVER FOR THEIR BASE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
NOW THIS IS ALL IMPORTANT
CONTEXT FOR ONE OF THE BIG
POLICY QUESTIONS WITH US IF IF
THAT'S WHAT WE ADDRESS IN. THE
SIXTH AND FINAL PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT.
A THE LC FIVE WAS INTENDED IN
PART TO ADDRESS A VERY SPECIFIC
LONG STANDING UP AT ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN OTHER STATES
WHICH IS THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
BETWEEN LOW INCOME AND NON LOW
INCOME STUDENTS.
WELL UNFORTUNATELY THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AS MEASURED BY
STATE A.
STATEWIDE STANDARD ASSESSMENTS
AS NOT BUDGE NOTABLY UNDER LC FF
WOULD WE HAVE A FEW YEARS NOW
INTO THE STATE'S NEW STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENTS.
IT WHILE WE'VE SEEN SOME
OVERALL IMPROVEMENTS ON A
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT ON THOSE
TESTS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
LOW INCOME AND NON LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. IS NOT CHANGE NOTABLY
OVER THOSE YEARS IN ADDITION
THE.
.
FEDERAL.
NAPES RESULTS AS WELL AS WE CALL
THEM. WHICH ARE AYE AYES SAMPLE
OF ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE GIVEN.
EVERY COUPLE YEARS THEY THEY
INDICATE THAT. IT OVER THE SPAN.
.
STARTING FROM JUST BEFORE EL CFF
TO A FEW YEARS INTO ELSEY FF'S
IMPLEMENTATION WILL AGAIN
CALIFORNIA'S NOT NOTABLY CLOSE
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
THIS RAISES THE QUESTION AS TO.
.
WHAT CHANGES COULD BE MADE TO
SCHOOL FINANCE
TO FURTHER ADDRESS?
AND IN ADDITION.
.
THERE OUR LONGSTANDING ISSUES
ABOUT THE.
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT'S PROVIDED ALL DISTRICTS TO
COVER RAISING COSTS SUCH AS
SCHOOL PENSIONS.
THOSE ARE ALL QUESTIONS THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH AND THIS IN COMING
YEARS OF BEFORE I I PASS ON I.
DO WANNA.
DISCUSS THE OTHER ASPECT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ALSO ABOUT
PROPOSAL WITCHES
THE TRANSPARENCY THEY. AS
FINANCE INDICATED HAVE A GRIP
PROPOSED.
ADDING AN ADDENDUM TO DISTRICT
BUDGETS THAT WOULD OFFER SOME
CROSSWALK BETWEEN.
THE INFORMATION THAT'S IN THOSE
BUDGETS AND THE INFORMATION
THAT'S IN THE HELL CAPS WERE
WE'RE RECOMMENDING REJECTING
THAT PROPOSAL. WE UNDERSTAND
TRANSPARENCY IS A CONCERN. A
WITH THE EXPENDITURE OF
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
GRANT FUNDS THOUGH WE DON'T
THINK THAT THIS.
PARTICULAR PROPOSALS WELL
TARGETED TOWARDS THOSE CONCERNS
GOOD MOSTLY DUPLICATE
INFORMATION THAT'S ALREADY
AVAILABLE ON ALL CAPS.
IT WOULD PUT IT IN A THE BUDGET
BUT THE BUDGET IS NOT REALLY A
DOCUMENT THAT'S DESIGNED FOR
PUBLIC CONSUMPTION IT'S ALREADY
A LONG AND COMPLICATED.
A PROCESS WHICH WE THINK TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
TRANSPARENCY CONCERNS WOULD WE
WOULD RECOMMEND.
A FOCUSING ON IMPROVING THE EL
CAP AND SIMPLIFYING BE EL CAP.
BUT THAT'LL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS
THANK.
THANK YOU BEFORE YOU DO THAT WE
DO OUR OUR ROLE REAL QUICK.
IT'S MCCARTY HERE.
CHAVEZ HERE AMONG.
MEDINA HERE MESSAGING THERE
O'DONNELL. VOEPEL.
THANK YOU BERMAN IF EDUCATION.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH VENABLE
HAVE THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION I JUST MAKE A
FEW ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND
BUILDING UPON WHAT'S ALREADY
BEEN SAID AROUND AT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF LC FF AND AND
JUST TO KNOW THAT THAT.
SUPERINTENDENT IS PLEASED TO SEE
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MAINTAINING
THE COMMITMENT TO FULLY FUNDING
LCF OFTEN THAT WHERE AT DOING%
THAT EARLY NAY NO WILL TALK
ABOUT IT LATER.
IN THAT IN THE NEXT.
ISSUE AROUND THE NEED TO AYE
BUT WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S A STRONG NEED TO PUT
MORE FUNDING TOWARDS. US SCHOOLS
AND LCF MATHIS WE THINK ABOUT
WHAT ELSE IT WHAT FULL FUNDING
MEANS WHICH MEANS THAT WE'VE
RESTORED.
ARE FUNDING LEVELS BACK TO
SIXTY THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHT
FUNDING LEVELS ADJUSTED FOR COST
OF LIVING SO SO AM AS MISTER
ANDERSON SAID IT YOU KNOW. WHAT
WE REALLY NEED TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE MAKE I'M MORE INVESTMENTS
IN OUR SCHOOLS IS THAT WAS NOT?
SORT OF THAT THAT THE GOAL IS
TO WHAT WE WANT TO SEE FUNDING
FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND. AND AND
IT'S WHAT HE'S IT MISTER
ANDERSON ALSO TALKED ABOUT SORT
OF THAT WITH THAT WERE STILL
CONTINUING TO SEE.
AT THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND SOME
AND AND THERE'D THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE ELSE IF THAT'S AND THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED TO MAINTAIN THE COURSE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO SEE. A
GROWTH IN THAT AND I THINK THE
ONLY THING I WOULD JUST ADD
WHAT.
AROUND THE AB PROPOSAL TO AND I
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT POSTED THE
AS SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
GRANTS WITHIN THREE DAYS OF THEM
BEING AVAILABLE WHICH IS JUST TO
SAY THAT WE SAID WE SUPPORT THAT
PROPOSAL. AND THAT WRITTEN THAT
IT IS AYE CODIFYING IN EXISTING
PRACTICE THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
TO TO MAINE TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION ON THAT ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE SO WE WE
SUPPORT THAT.
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY THINKING.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
THIS.
PANEL BEFORE HERE FROM OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS
CUSTOMERS WHO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE YOU ON.
WE LIKE TO START WITH THE THE
ALEJO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
I.
NOT ONLY.
APPRECIATE IN THE HANDOUT THAT
YOU. PROVIDED TODAY BUT ALSO
YEAR PROP NINETY EIGHT EDUCATION
ANNOUNCES.
AND.
.
I KNOW TO.
THAT.
.
ON PAGE TWENTY SIX OF YOUR. PROP
NINETY EIGHT ANALYSIS.
YOU TALK ABOUT.
THE OPTIONS FOR LESS THAT
CONSIDERATION THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE DISCUSSING TODAY. NOW IN
TERMS OF.
K. THROUGH TWELVE.
.
FINDING AND.
FIRST IN YOUR ANALYSIS YOU'D
DISCUSS THE.
PROPOSAL FOR THE INCREASE BASE
RATES.
THAT WOULD HELP ALL DISTRICTS ON
MULTIPLE FRONTS.
COULD YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT TO.
THE EARS SO THEY IN MANY WAYS
THIS WOULD BE THE SIMPLEST
OPTION WHICH WOULD BE TO
MAINTAIN THE STRUCTURE OF THE
LCF A FORMULA WHICH IS TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT IS PROVIDED THROUGH THAT
FORMULA.
SO GENERALLY SPEAKING THIS IN
THIS MEANS YOU WOULD INCREASE
THE BASE RATES.
I'D AS YOU INCREASE THE BASE
RATES YOU WOULD INCREASE FUNDING
FOR SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION GRANTS MRS BECAUSE
THOSE. FUNDING AMOUNTS OUR ARE
SIMPLY A PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
BASE RATES ARE THE GENERAL RULE
OF THUMB THAT WE PRESENT THERE
IS THAT FOR. EACH A ONE PERCENT
INCREASE IN THE BASE RATES EAT
YOU WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT A
STATEWIDE COST OF ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH
A LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
WOULD GO TOWARDS THAT TARGETED
FUNDING FOR LOW INCOME AND
ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS.
OKAY YEAH THANK YOU AYE.
THE CHAIR JUST POINTED OUT TO
ME THAT THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE.
FOCUSING SPECIFICALLY ON THE
SUBJECT INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM.
YOURSELF AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND SO I
RESERVE. MY QUESTIONS FOR THE
NEXT PANEL OKAY THANK YOU WITH
THAT.
LET'S I BRING. OUR REPRESENTS
FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE HAVE.
OUR NEW SUPERINTENDENT FROM THE
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT EXCITED TO WELCOME MAT
THAT SUPERINTENDENT HORRY I YOU
ARE FIRST TIME TO.
SUBCOMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT FROM THE
TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
DOCTOR TENSED UP.
START WITH YOU.
I CAN'T FIGURE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS JORGE YOU LIED AS.
THE CHAIRMAN CHEN DIE AND.
TEN MONTHS INTO MY TENURE AS
SECOND IN A CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT AND VERY
EXCITED TO BE HERE.
I WANNA AND TAKE A FEW MINUTES
TO DISCUSS THE QUESTION OF.
WHETHER AT THE LC FF BASED GRANT
A SUFFICIENTLY COVERS ALL OF THE
INCREASED COSTS THAT DISTRICTS
SUCH AS MINE ARE FACING. A
INCLUDING PENSION COSTS.
AND CERTAINLY WHILE OUR
DISTRICT VERY MUCH APPRECIATES
THE INCREASES IN FUNDING FROM LC
FF INCLUDING THE ADVANCE
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE ELSE IF
IF BASS GRANT WILL NOT
ADEQUATELY COVER THE INCREASED
COSTS THAT WE ARE FACING.
ACCORDING TO OUR CBO'S
CALCULATIONS AFTER PERSON STIRS
COST ARE DEDUCTED FROM LC FF.
A WE WILL BE LEFT WITH EIGHTY
EIGHT CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR WE
RECEIVE FROM AL CFF.
AND THIS IS A DOWNWARD TREND OF
FOR US IN SUCCEEDING ARE ARE CAL
STIRS PENSION CONTRIBUTION RATES
WILL MORE THAN DOUBLE IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS WE ARE GOING FROM
EIGHT POINT TWO FIVE PERCENT TO
NINETEEN POINT NINE PERCENT.
THE TOTAL OF OUR PER STIRS
CONTRIBUTIONS WENT FROM THIRTEEN
MILLION. I JUST OVER THIRTEEN
MILLION IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN.
TO OVER THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
AND ALTHOUGH WE HAVE RECEIVED
MORE LCF IF FUNDING EVERY YEAR
THE AMOUNT WE ARE RECEIVING FROM
L. CFF IS NOT KEEPING PACE WITH
THE INCREASES IN OUR PENSION
CONTRIBUTION.
I YES WE ARE RECEIVING MORE
MONEY FROM THE STATE OUR BUT
AFTER WE MAKE OUR PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS WE HAVE LESS TO
WORK WITH.
A AND THE TREND IS THAT EVERY
YEAR WE HAVE LESS AND LESS TO
WORK WITH.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN FISCAL
YEAR WE HAD ABOUT NINETY THREE
PERCENT NINETY THREE PERCENT OF
OUR LCF IF FUNDS LEFT TO SPEND.
AFTER SUBTRACTING ARE PENSION
CONTRIBUTIONS BUT IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
FISCAL YEAR THAT AMOUNT WAS
REDUCED TO ABOUT EIGHTY EIGHT
PERCENT OF OUR BUDGET LEFT TO
SPEND AFTER SEPT TO IDENTIFY THE
AREAS OF
GREATEST NEED WHERE WE NEED TO
DEDICATE RESOURCES AND IS
NECESSARY.
INSECTS CITY WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO ADDRESS
I'D THESE SHORTAGES BY LOOKING
MORE CLOSELY AT HOW WE BUDGET.
OUR IN OUR DISTRICT ARE THROUGH
THE USE OF WHAT WE'RE CALLING
EQUITY INDICES.
I WE'VE BEGUN TO TEST A THESE
EQUITY INDICES AND I WANT TO
GIVE YOU ARE AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT
WE'RE. SEEKING TO ACCOMPLISH
I IN THE AREA OF STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES.
OBVIOUSLY IN MANY URBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE OURS AND SEXY
THAT WERE IN GREAT NEED OF
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES.
ID SUPPORTS INCLUDE COUNSELORS
NURSES SOCIAL WORKERS SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST.
BUT WHAT WE FOUND IN OUR
DISTRICT IS THAT DESPITE
INCREASED LCF IF FUNDING WE
STILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT NEED
FOREIGN INVESTMENT IN THE
STUDENT SUPPORT SERVICES.
FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE ALLOCATED FIVE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN OUR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET FOR
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS.
HOWEVER THAT INVESTMENT IS STILL
APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLAR SHORT OF WHAT WE
WOULD NEED TO MEET THE STAFFING
RATIOS RECOMMENDED BY THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
OF SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS.
WE ALSO HAVE ABOUT FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT
SHORTAGE TO MEET THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL NURSES
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR NURSING TO
STUDENTS STAFFING RATIOS.
AND A TWENTY POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLAR SHORTFALL TO MEET THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTITIONERS.
TO STUDENTS STAFFING RATIOS.
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE IMMENSELY
ALSEA FF AND THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IT HAS PROVIDED AND
HOPE THAT I'LL SEE IF IF WILL
CONTINUE TO YIELD MORE RESOURCES
SO THAT WE CAN. BE ABLE TO MEET
OUR OBLIGATIONS AND BE ABLE TO
INVEST MORE IN CRITICAL SUPPORT
PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE ESSENTIAL IN HELPING
OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED TO LEARN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. A.
CHAIR MCCARTY.
VICE CHAIR CHAVEZ AND MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY. A SUB COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF TOWARDS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
NOT JUST AS A.
AS THE DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
AND FORMER CHIEF ACADEMIC
OFFICER BUT ALSO A PARENT NOT
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR FULLY FUNDING OF
THE LC FF IN THE PROPOSED
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET. I
THINK THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
.
YOU KNOW THAT THE FORMULA.
BUT THE PRINCIPLES ON WHICH THE
FORMULA ARE BASED ARE SOLID. ARE
HOWEVER I BELIEVE THAT THAT
THERE'S A FLAW THAT DOESN'T.
INCLUDE ENOUGH SPACE FUNDING TO
ADDRESS BASIC NEEDS
OF OUR SCHOOLS PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE OF THE RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE INCREASE
SUBSTANTIALLY JUST ONE YEAR
AFTER THE L. CFF WAS ADOPTED.
I AM GLAD TO SEE THE COMMITTEE
DOES GOING TO DISCUSS THAT HERE
OUT TODAY IN THE FOLLOWING
SECTION.
THE TORCH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SERVES OVER TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS IN OUR
THIRTY SCHOOLS EACH AND
EVERYDAY.
WE OPERATE A SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL AN ADULT TRANSITION
PROGRAM AND THREE ADULT
EDUCATION CAMPUSES THAT ARE SELF
SUSTAINING.
WE ARE DIVERSE COMMUNITY IN MANY
WAYS
OUR STUDENTS SPEAK SEVENTY SIX
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
AND WE HAVE AN UNDUE PICKET A
POPULATION OF A THIRTY SIX
PERCENT.
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LCF OFF.
OUR LEADERSHIP TEAM HAS GONE
THROUGH A TRANSPARENT PROCESS
INVOLVING ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN.
THE PROCESS HAS BEEN
COLLABORATIVE.
AND IS MAXIMIZING THE USE OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT FUNDING THAT
WE RECEIVE TO IMPROVE AND
INCREASE SERVICES FOR THESE
TARGETED STUDENTS.
WE'RE FOLLOWING THE INTENT OF
THE LAW AND RESISTING PRESSURES
FROM SOME GROUPS IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT ARE REQUESTING TO
USE A SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR
BASS GRANT EXPENDITURES.
FOR EXAMPLE ACROSS THE BOARD
SALARY ENHANCEMENTS.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THE INTENT OF THE LCF OFF
NOR DO WE BELIEVE THAT IT
DIRECTS THE RESOURCES TO THE
STUDENTS THAT GENERATE THOSE
THOSE FUNDS.
IN ADDITION TO OUR USE.
OUR BELIEF ON THE USE OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT FUNDS.
WE ARE PROUD OF THE WAY IN WHICH
WE'VE UTILIZED THE ONE TIME
FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO US
EACH OF THE PAST FOUR YEARS.
ONE SUCH HIGHLIGHT OCCURRED THIS
PAST DECEMBER. WHEN ED SOURCE
FEATURED TORRENT UNIFIED'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEXT
GENERATION SCIENCE STANDARDS.
THIS COMPREHENSIVE TEACHER
TRAINING PROGRAM WAS PRIMARILY
FUNDED FROM ONE TIME DOLLARS AND
ASSISTED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
TEACHERS AND THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS IN LEARNING AND WORKING
WITH THESE NEW STANDARDS.
UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER. WE WE
HAVE RECENTLY HAD TO USE ONE
TIME FUNDS FOR ONGOING EXPENSES
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF THE
DOLLARS IN THE BASE GRANT.
STEPPED SUPPORT AND STUFF
STAN.
BOB PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE BUILT
AS OTHER OBLIGATIONS HAVE BEEN
PUT UPON US.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT A
BUDGETING BEST PRACTICE.
TO USE ONE TIME FUNDS FOR ON
GOING NEEDS BUT WE HAVE LITTLE
CHOICE.
FOR EXAMPLE IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
PROPOSED BUDGET.
FULL FUNDING OF THE LC FF
WE WILL HAVE VERY FEW IF ANY NEW
DOLLARS LEFT AFTER ADDRESSING
STIRS AND PURRS.
STEPPING COLUMN INCREASES
AND INCREASING COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH EDUCATING STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS.
OF THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
STARTING WITH SIX POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
WHICH WE WILL ACHED AT SEA AND
INCREASE UNDER THE.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION WILL BE
USED TO COVER STIRRED SPURS.
AND STEPPING CALL.
THAT LEAVES ONLY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS
LESS THAN ONE PER ONE HALF OF
ONE PERCENT OF OUR BUDGET. TO
ADDRESS THE OTHER ITEMS SUCH AS
SPECIAL EDUCATION UTILITIES AND
UPGRADING TECHNOLOGY.
THE PICTURE FOR NINETEEN TWENTY
IS MORE BLEAK.
UNDER THE ALL CFF WE ARE ONLY
EXPECTED TO RECEIVE A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT OF TWO POINT
FOUR ONE PERCENT.
OR THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
IF THAT IS THE CASE WE WILL NEED
NEARLY TWO MILLION ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS JUST TO TREAD WATER.
AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR ONLY STIRS
AND PURRS AND STEPPING CALL.
IN A DISTRICT WHERE ALMOST
NINETY ONE PERCENT OF OUR BUDGET
GOES TO PERSONNEL. THE ONLY WAY
TO MAKE UP FOR THESE KINDS OF
DEFICITS IS TO CUT PEOPLE.
AND HAVING BEEN PART OF THE TEAM
TO MAKE WRITTEN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION I CAN TELL YOU THAT
PEOPLE STILL REMEMBER THAT
TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE ON THE VERGE
OF HAVING TO MAKE THOSE TOUGH
DECISIONS AGAIN.
WE NEED THE STABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO PLAN OUR BUDGETS INTO THE
FUTURE.
AT THE CURRENT TIME.
WITH NO PLANNED INCREASE THE
FUNDING BEYOND COLA.
STRUGGLING IT WITH ISSUES
SUCH AS IF WE HAVE ENOUGH FUNDS
TO DEDICATE TO MAKING OUR
SCHOOLS SAFER. NOT PROVIDING
EMPLOYEES RAISES.
OR AND MAKING SURE THAT OUR
TEACHERS HAVE THE BEST TOOLS FOR
FOR EDUCATING STUDENTS.
SO I AGAIN AYE I WANT TO THANK
THE.
THAT THE COMMITTEE FOR
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION THAT THAT
WILL HAPPEN TODAY.
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AT ANY TIME FROM THE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE.
OKAY THANK YOU START CITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FIRST
MISTER AGUILAR A THANK YOU VERY
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. LACAN YOU
START OFF BY TELLING US WHAT THE
OTHER PEOPLE CAN COUNTIES INSECT
MONEY INFO.
ABOUT SEVENTY TWO PERCENT
SEVENTY TWO CHRIS
SO.
HIGH BUT TO JUST UNDER THE LA
OWES.
CHARACTERIZATION OF A HIGH
POVERTY DISTRICT BUT
NONETHELESS.
LARGE.
POPULATION OF ARIBA TITLE ONE.
NO ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
AND FOSTER KIDS.
.
AND.
IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT YOUR
NUMBER ONE CHALLENGE.
ARE THE.
THAT DRAMATIC RAMPING UP OF THE
PENSION COSTS THAT'S CORRECT.
AND AND YOU INDICATED THAT IN
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS YOU'RE
STIRS COSTS ITSELF WILL DOUBLE.
CORRECT HIM.
.
SO.
YEAH V..
AND WHY WHILE THE GOVERNOR.
IS IS.
NOW.
A PROUD TO TALK ABOUT I BELIEVE
THE SIXTY SIX PERCENT AND. OUR
OVERALL EDUCATION FUNDING
INCREASE.
SINCE
THE RECESSION.
NONETHELESS YOU YOU ARE FACING
THESE CHALLENGES.
.
DESPITE.
I I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
YOU'RE RECEIVING A LOT MORE
CONCENTRATION SUPPLEMENTAL
DOLLARS AND SAVE TORRANCE
UNIFIED
CORRECT.
SO.
IT IS IS IT IS IT FAIR TO SAY
I'M A HEARING.
FROM A LARGE URBAN DISTRICTS
LIKE LIKE SACRAMENTO UNIFIED.
AND SUBURBAN DISTRICTS LIKE
TORRANCE UNIFIED.
YOU'RE IN AGREEMENT THAT.
THE PACE GRANT IS INADEQUATE AND
THEIR BEST WAY TO.
ADDRESS YOUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE
ARE IS TO INCREASE THE BASE
GRANT THAT'S OUR POSITION.
THANK YOU I I OF APPROVAL FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS ON THAT SAME ISSUE
AS WELL SO CLEARLY THE THE ISSUE
WE HEARD FROM YOU.
.
THEY PRETEND THAT YOU ARE AND.
DEBBIE SUPERINTENDENTS DOUGH. IS
THAT COMPENSATION COSTS
ESPECIALLY THAT THE PENSION
COSTS.
ARE OUR BIG CHALLENGE
NOT ONLY IN THE FUTURE BUT AS
YOU SAID FROM THIRTEEN.
FOURTEEN TO SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
SAID WE OFTEN THIRTEEN MILLION
TO THIRTY THREE NINE SO YOU
ALREADY DOUBLED.
AND YEAH.
KNOWING THAT THEY WERE BEING THE
THAT DESIRES TO HAVE MORE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF IT IF IT IF
IT CAME AND I'M. MORE RESOURCES
THROUGH LCF AFTER OR. IF WE YOU
KNOW MADE A CONTRIBUTION TO
CASTERS THE ONE TIME MONEY LIKE
WE KINDA DID WITH WITH.
.
PARIS IN THE PRIOR YEARS.
YEAH DOESN'T REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
TT ALL HOW THAT WOULD PUT COME
FORWARD.
JERRY I SUPPOSE.
YOU KNOW THAT OUR COMMITMENT
WOULD BE TO ADVANCE THE SPIRIT
OF LC FF AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT WAS AROUND PENSION COSTS SO
I'M AS LONG AS WE COULD COVER
THOSE EXPENSES.
HE'D RATHER HAVE IT NOT HAVE
INCREASED ELSE FF BUT HAVE A
LOWER.
CONTRIBUTION REQUIREMENT FROM
ESSENTIALLY CASTERS LA I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR NEEDIEST STUDENTS OF ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS BUT CERTAINLY OF
THOSE THAT ARE. IN GREATEST NEED
IN OUR DISTRICT IS A DISTRICT
FORTY THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS
AND.
TEN MONTHS INTO MY POSITION I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE OUR
ENGLISH LEARNER STAND WHERE OUR
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT OF OUR
FOSTER YOUTH.
AS WELL AS OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND SEVERAL OTHER
GROUPS AS WELL.
AND I OR I WOULD SAY.
.
YOU KNOW IT AS WE THINK ABOUT.
THE THE PLANNED FOR STABILITY
AND AND LOOKING INTO THE FUTURE.
.
I THINK SUCH TYING SOMETHING TO
THE LC FF.
A AN ASPIRATIONAL TARGET WOULD
HELP US GET TO THAT WOULD WOULD
HELP US PLAN AND HELP US GET TO
THAT WHERE. WHERE WE WANT OUR TO
BE FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS?
AND YOU KNOW GETTING FUNDING.
IN
NOW IN NINETEEN IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO WHAT IT WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION STILL PUTS US.
YOU KNOW IN IN THE LOWER HALF
OF OF THE COUNTRY AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S THAT'S OUR CORE BELIEF IN
AND.
HOPE IS THAT WE CAN HAVE SET
THAT ASPIRATIONAL TARGET.
THAT CAN ABSORB THE THE ONGOING
COSTS.
WHILE WHILE KEEPING THOSE ARE
DECISIONS TO BE MADE LOCALLY ON
HOW WE BEST ADDRESS.
THE. THE THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS WITH IN OUR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES AND HAVE HOW WOULD
YOU ADDRESS THE EQUITY ISSUE AS
FAR AS.
A THAT THE PURSE COSTS ARE THE
SAME THING IN IN IN OTHER WORDS
WE DID THIS CHANGE FIVE YEARS
AGO I THAT WE MADE THE RIGHT
CALL THAT. WOULD FOCUS ON EQUITY
THAT YOU KNOW SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT KIND DUPLICATING COUNTER
DIFFERENT THAN.
THIRTY THIRTY THREE PERCENT THAT
THAT THE NEEDS TO BRING THAT
STUDENT SUCCESS ARE DIFFERENT
AND I THINK.
RESEARCH SHOWS COMMONSENSE KIND
OF SHOWS THAT BUT THAT STIRS
COSTS ARE THE SAME FOR YOU FOR
YOUR DISTRICT SO HOW HOW DO WE
RECONCILE THE FACT THAT.
THAT THE FUNDING STRUCTURE
DOESN'T ALWAYS.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
SO.
I'M I'M NOT QUITE SURE I'M I'M
I'M NOT THE THIS STATE FINANCE
EXPERTS.
AND BUT YOU KNOW FROM FROM THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
IF IF THAT OBLIGATION WAS TAKEN
AWAY FROM US.
THEN THEN AND AND WE COULD PLAN
FOR THAT. OF THAT WOULD BE GREAT
IF IT WAS A ONE TIME PAYMENT TO
STARS RIPPERS TOOK TO ALLEVIATE
THE BURDEN FOR THE SHORT TIME.
IS IS NOT MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
THE BRITISH A ONE TIME FUNDS.
AND SO.
SO IF THERE'S
IF THERE'S AN ONGOING PLAN TO
HELP US ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
THOSE NEEDS.
IN THE LONG TERM THEN THEN WE
CAN ADEQUATELY ADEQUATELY PLAN
AT AND.
.
AND AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE ARE SOLID AND
AND THAT WE.
.
THAT THAT WERE NOT.
YEAR TO YEAR.
ASK YOU KNOW.
TRYING TO TRYING TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO OUR COMMUNITY ABOUT.
THAT THE FUNDS THAT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A IT IT'S BEEN IT'S
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT. WHEN THE
STATE ECONOMY IS.
GOING CRAZY AND THE STOCK
MARKET'S UP AND YET WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT POTENTIAL CUTS AND
I KNOW PEOPLE IN DISTRICTS THAT
BUT THERE DID DID LAYOFFS THIS
YEAR FOR NEXT YEAR.
AND SO.
YOU OF THAT IT AND IT'S BECAUSE
OF OF THE LACK OF ABILITY TO
PLAN AND THAT.
IT'S CONFUSING THAT THE.
THE COMMUNITY AND AND TORRANCE
FOR SURE.
OKAY.
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FOR THIS
PANEL ISSUE ONE MISTER JARVIS.
OR TO THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING
TOUGH FOR THE. THIS DISCUSSION
THEY'LL CFM HAVING BETTER.
FOR SIX YEARS NOW WATCHING IT
COME THROUGH.
I THINK WHEN THE PRINCIPAL WE
STARTED WITH WAS THAT.
WE WANTED TO ADD SOME STABILITY
TO THIS WHOLE SYSTEM THAT'S WHY
DEVELOP THOSE YOU HAVE FOR THAT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COULD PLAN WHEN
I KNOW ON HOUSING ISSUES ACT OUT
IT WAS ODD THAT.
START SPENDING MONEY BEFORE WE
EVEN GOT OUR BUDGETS WE HAD THE.
MAKE GUESSES DEFERRED ROBERT
WE'RE TRYING TO GO.
AND SO WHAT THIS AN ATTEMPT TO
DO THIS.
I'D DO QUESTION TO A DOCTOR
STOKES JUDGING YOUR FUTURE FEW
TIMES.
THE.
FULLY FUNDED THE LC FF.
WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THE GROUND WHERE
SHOULD WE GO NEXT.
SHOULD WE JUST SAY.
FULLY FUNDED NEXT YEAR SO WE SAY
THAT WAS A GOOD BENCHMARK BUT WE
SHOULD ACTUALLY HAVE.
SOME OTHER MEASUREMENT IN SOME
OTHER RESULTS FROM THAT.
WOULD YOU THINK.
BUT I THINK AN ASPIRATIONAL
TARGET IS IMPORTANT.
A YOU KNOW AS AS CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE DO WE WANT OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM TO BE.
.
AND HAVING BEEN BORN AND RAISED
IN A GUN TO SCHOOL HERE AND AND
NOW.
WORKING IN THE SAME COMMUNITY
THAT
THAT AYE I WENT TO SCHOOL AND.
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS NOW.
YOU KNOW IT.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THAT ARE
OURS IS ANY DIFFERENT THAN THAN
ANY COMMUNITY ACROSS THE STATE
WHERE.
PEOPLE WANT WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR KIDS AND THEY WANT BEST
FOR THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND.
.
I I JUST LE.
COMPLETED THE THE THICK MAT
BOTTOM CBO MENTOR PROGRAM HERE
IN SACRAMENTO I WAS COMING UP
ONCE A MONTH FOR THE PAST YEAR.
AND AND WORKING WITH CBO'S AND
AND FUTURE CBO'S FROM ACROSS THE
STATE.
AND.
AND AND THE MESSAGE WAS WAS.
COMMENT.
RIGHT AND.
AND YOU DON'T WORK WERE LOOKING
AT HOW DO WE.
MAYBE MAKE MAKE CUTS AND REDUCE.
STIPENDS IN ATHLETICS OR OF
TRANSPORTATION AND OR YOU KNOW
IT WERE KIND OF NICKEL AND
DIMING AND SO.
YET PEOPLE GET TIRED OF THAT
RIGHT AND AND UNDERSTANDABLE
WHAT WOULD YOU THINK.
WE'RE ON A PERSONAL CFF WHERE
SHOULD WE GO NEXT YEAR.
THEN I WOULD SAY THAT THAT THAT
ASPIRATIONAL TARGET BECAUSE
YEAH THIS IS WHAT YOU MEAN
NUMBER GIMME THOUGHT. WELL KIND
OF WHAT YOU KNOW SET SETTING
SETTING A NEW BAR.
TO GET TO AND TWENTY TWENTY SIX
AND MR CHVEZ BURKE WE'RE GONNA
GET THERE IN JUST A SECOND LET
ME CAN I GOT THAT'S IS REASON
I'M DOING THIS.
THE JOB WHICH GOES TO MY NEXT
THING ON THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
WHEN WE STARTED LC FF FIVE YEARS
AGO.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP NOW WE'VE BEEN
GOING IN THE PROGRAM I'M
WONDERING.
WHEN YOU START FUELING THE
ENGINE.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE TO START
SOON?
THE RESULTS.
IN THE CHURCH AND THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR THE KIDS.
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW IF A CHILD
COMES IN IN A SAFE.
.
BECAUSE WE DEEP WE GET FUNDED
FULLY.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OR EIGHT
NOW THEY'RE. AND HIGH SCHOOL.
IS PROBABLY AN IMPACT UPON THEIR
ACADEMIC SKILLS A MINUTE DATA
PROBLEM MATH READING BECAUSE WE
START WE WANT FUNDING EVERYTHING
WE CAN AND WE HAD A PROBLEM.
ESPECIALLY THE CHILDREN OF
COLOR.
NOW WE'RE FULLY FUNDING IT WHEN
DO WE THINK WE'RE GOING TO START
SEEING THE RESULTS FROM THAT IS
I DON'T THINK IT STARTS THE NEXT
YEAR OR THAT WEEK I MEAN. I
THINK IT STARTS.
IN THE FUTURE SOMETIME BUT I'M
NOT A PROFESSIONAL LIKE YOU ARE.
WHEN YOU THINK THE CHEAP WHEN WE
GIVE MONEY WHEN WE SEE THE
RESULTS FROM OUR MONEY.
TWO YEARS THREE YEARS FIVE YEARS
HOW FAR DOWN THE LINE.
YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA VERY.
I KNOW THAT THAT WE'VE SEEN
WITH WITH THE USE OF
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING WE'VE SEEN
SOME VERY TARGETED.
SERVICES AND AND AND ACTIONS.
BE PUT INTO PLACE I THINK THE
ALL CAP IS A GOOD DOCUMENT.
I I THINK THAT PROCESS IS IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO INVOLVE
STAKEHOLDERS.
ALL ALONG THE WAY. AND THEN I
WOULD CONTINUE THAT THE THE.
NEW ACCOUNTABILITY MODEL TO TRY
TO NOT GET SCHOOLS TO TO REALLY.
HONE IN ON ON CERTAIN SUBGROUPS
AND AND SCHOOLS AND EH YOU KNOW
WITH REGARD TO THE EIGHT STATE
CONTENT ARE EIGHT SIT PRIORITY
AREAS. AND THAT'S THAT'S A A
GREAT MODEL THAT.
THAT WE'RE STILL WORKING
THROUGH IN SOME WAYS BUT. IN
TRYING TO FIND DATA FIRST FOR
SOME OF THE THINGS THE MEASURE
IS DIFFICULT STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
FOR EXAMPLE.
BUT BUT THOSE IF IF SCHOOLS CAN
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND AND IDENTIFY
USING DATA. HOW STUDENTS ARE
ACHIEVING?
AYE AYE I HEARD.
OF SUPERDELEGATE BOUT
COUNSELING AND NURSES AND AND
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE THINGS AS
WELL.
DEBTS THAT ARE HARDER TO
MEASURE WHEN WHEN STUDENTS ARE
MORE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL ANYA
ATTENDS ART I UNDERSTAND THE
HARDER TO MEASURE IT VARIES
BETWEEN EVERYBODY
I'M TRACK WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
YOU
THE FIRST QUESTION I WAS.
WHY I WANTED TO CONTINUE THIS
LINE OF THOUGHT IS THAT WE'RE
FULLY FUNDING THE LC FF?
AND IF IMPACT A FULL OF FUN AND
YOU'LL SEE IF F. IS GOING TO BE
THIS YEAR GOING TO BE. DOWN
YEARS AND THE WHOLE REASON WE'RE
JOINED IS DRILL IS TO BRING OUR
ACADEMIC STANDARD HIGHER FOR OUR
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY ARE.
PREPARED TO GO OFF IN COLLEGE
INTO ONE OF THE THINGS.
AND THEIR LIVES SO IF WE'RE
FULLY FUNDING THE LC FF NOW.
THE IMPACT OF THAT WILL BE.
TEN YEARS FROM NOW TWO YEARS
FROM NOW WHEN WILL THIS THING
BE.
IN WHICH TIED TO MY EARLIER
QUESTION ABOUT. WHAT IS THE
OBJECTIVE OF THE LC FF'S IS
SHOULD BE HIGHER BECAUSE?
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO AND I
FIRST GOT ELECTED YEAR WAS?
TO MOVE THE ACADEMICS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM BE IN. FORTY
EIGHTH IN THE NATION TO ISIDRO
CROWD KARADZIC CAN WE GET TO
THIRTY NINE.
CAN WE GET A THIRTIES SEX I
DON'T KNOW GIVE ME A NUMBER AND
WHAT WOULD BE THE PROCESS WE
WOULD GET THERE AND I THINK.
RESOURCES MATTER LIKE VLC AFFAIR
FOR THE RESULTS THAT WOULD COME
FOR THAT SHOULD BE. DOWNLINE AND
SO I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE LIKE
ELEVATE THE DISCUSSION.
A LITTLE BIT MORE ON THIS.
TAKE KILLER ISSUES AS WELL UNDER
BRING IT UP. DESCEND QUICKLY SO
YOU CAN GO ON.
THE YEAH WE LIVE. REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS SOME OF THE MEMBERS AGAIN
BE PUTTING. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOL SUPPLEMENTAL SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROGRAM.
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT AND. KNOCKED
AT MISTER AGUILAR YOU MENTIONED
THAT WAS A.
.
IN ISSUES OF THAT WILL BE COMING
FORWARD OUT OF THE BE SUPPORTED
BY ANYBODY BUT.
YOU WANT TO SIGN ON WOULD
APPRECIATE IT.
THINK.
DEPRESSED ENDORSEMENT THAT YEAH
RIGHT.
YES MISTER MARTZ ITCHY THE THANK
YOU AYE.
WOULD LIKE TO.
.
GO BACK TO THE ISSUE OF.
THE TREATMENT GAP.
THOUGHT THE LA O. STARTED OFF
THIS MORNING TALKING ABOUT HOW.
THE HIGH PARTY DISTRICTS ARE
RECEIVING TWENTY THREE PERCENT
MORE THAN LOW POPPY DISTRICTS.
.
AND DESPITE THAT.
THE HIGH POVERTY DISTRICTS.
.
OR.
IT THE CALIFORNIA'S ACHIEVEMENT
GAP.
ACCORDING TO THE LA O. AS
MEASURED BY THE NATIONAL
ASSESSMENT OF EDUCATIONAL
PROGRESS
HAS NOT NARROWED.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
SUPERINTEND ACT OF OUR.
.
HOW DO YOU SEE THE ADDITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
DOLLARS MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
SACRAMENTO AND FOR?
THANK YOU MEMBER FOR THE
QUESTION I MEAN YOU KNOW.
INTERESTINGLY TODAY.
WE ARE OFFERING THE SAT TO
OLIVER JUNIORS USING SOME OF
THOSE RESOURCES.
ARE IN SEXY UNIFIED.
AND AS I MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING I'VE ONLY BEEN
SUPERINTENDENT FOR TEN MONTHS A
LOT OF MY EXPERIENCES FROM MY
LAST POST AND PRESIDENT UNIFIED
WHERE I WAS THERE FOR. EIGHT
PLUS YEARS.
AND.
WE DID.
.
TAKE A VERY DISCIPLINED APPROACH
TO CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT AND
PART OF THAT. APPROACH IS THAT.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT A CHIEF
MEANT AYE AND DATA AS SOMETHING
THAT INFORMS US BUT NOT TO PROVE
BUT RATHER A TO IMPROVE.
AND OVER THE. COURSE OF THOSE
EIGHT YEARS WE SAW.
A VERY BIG INCREASES AND.
IMPORTANT MILESTONE MARKERS
SUCH AS GRADUATION AT ATG
COMPLETION.
COLLEGE GOING ON MATTERS AND
AND THIS WAS A RIGHT NOT JUST
FOR ALL STUDENTS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY FOR GROUPS OF
STUDENTS THAT PRIOR TO. ARE
THOSE AND INITIATIVES.
WERE UNDER OR OVER REPRESENTED.
.
AND THAT IS SOME OF THOSE SAME
EXPERIENCES WE'VE BROUGHT A SAX
CITY UNIFIED AND ARE. LOOKING
VERY CLOSELY AT.
ACHIEVEMENT OF ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND AS I EXPRESSED
EARLIER I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT.
SOME OF THE VERY POPULATIONS OF
STUDENTS THAT ELSIE FF WAS
INTENDED TO SERVE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPENED I THINK THERE WILL
BE. A SIGNIFICANT ACTION.
WITH THE MAY REVISE AND WOOD
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE IN A FEW
MONTHS BUT HOLD IT HOLD IT OPEN
FOR NOW.
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GOOD
ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
HEALTH THIS IS THAT KIND OF
ATTACK ON HERE OF COURSE LCS
PATH THAT BUDGET PROPOSALS AND
WE HAVE THREE.
PROPOSALS THAT WE WANT TO
CONSIDER DURING THE DELIBERATION
PROCESS OF THAT SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS AND WE WANT
IT.
GIVEN OVERVIEW OF THIS MORNING
OF OF THESE SO THERE ARE WE'RE
DOING THIS A BIT DIFFERENTLY. SO
THEY'RE THREE PROPOSALS OUTLINED
HERE AND NOT TO SAY THERE ARE
OTHER PROPOSALS THAT WE WANT
CONSIDER THIS YEAR BUT THESE ARE
THE THREE THAT ARE KIND ARE
RISING TO THE TOP SO FAR. AND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE LA HAUTE
FROM TO FINANCE TO PROVOCATION
GIVE THAT.
AN OVERVIEW OF WHAT.
AND TO YOUR KNOWLEDGE IS THE
PROPOSAL AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
OPEN IT'S A PUBLIC COMMENTS.
FOR EACH OF THAT PROPOSAL SO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. IS THE.
.
INCREASE
AND IF THE LC FF BASE IN ITS IS.
A KIND OF A FOLLOW UP FROM WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING.
THROUGHOUT THE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING BRIAN ANDERSON OF
THE LEGISLATIE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
IT'S AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO BE.
DISCUSSING A SERIES OF THREE
PROPOSALS THE FIRST OF WHICH IS
A AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER. AN
INCREASE THEY'LL SEE IF ATHLETES
RATES AND THE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL
WOULD INCREASE THE SPACE RACE.
BY ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT.
WELL IT'S AN IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT.
THIS CHANGE WOULD NOT IN ITSELF.
IMMEDIATELY.
I'D COMMIT THE STATE OF
SPENDING ANY ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
ON EDUCATION AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN.
I AND WITH US NOT.
IMMEDIATELY RESULT AND A
SCHOOLS RECEIVING MORE FUNDING
AND INSTEAD WHAT THIS WOULD DO
WOULD. MEAN WE'D BE MOVING OUT
THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION DATE BY
AN UNKNOWN NUMBER OF YEARS. DOES
SO AS WAS DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY
THIS WOULD BE MORE ABOUT
SENDING.
.
AN AMBITIOUS TARGET.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
TWO MEMBERS ETERNITY OF IT
AGAIN.
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS PROPOSAL AT
THIS TIME I THINK WE JUST KNOW
THAT WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
BUT
HAPPY TO DISCUSS FURTHER ITS
WELL THEIR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. DEBORAH
BAND OF THE OFFICE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TOPICS AND AND
AS WE'VE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THROUGHOUT THIS A YEAR THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT STRONGLY SUPPORTS
INCREASING THAT THE BASE FUNDING
AND SO WE ARE SUPPOSE SUPPORTING
THIS UP. PROPOSAL AND THINK IT'S
A IT'S A GOOD WAY FOR US TO TO
BE ON A TRAJECTORY TO INCLUDE
MORE FUNDING FOR LCF.
OKAY THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW FOR EACH OF
THESE PROPOSAL SO WE CAN LINE UP
IN THE MIDDLE AND WHILE WORKING
LINE THAT THEY BEGIN ASK
QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HERE.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE NOT
COMMENTING ON THIS PROPOSAL.
BUT WHETHER IT'S THIS YEAR THE
NEXT YEAR IF THERE WAS
ADDITIONAL PROP NINETY EIGHT.
DOLLARS AVAILABLE TO SPEND FOR
EDUCATION WOULD YOU SEE IT AS A
YEAR TO YEAR ANALYSIS OR DO YOU
THINK IT'S IT'S WISE AS AS WE
OUTLINED HERE. TO ON TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL MARKER.
BASICALLY LC FF TWO POINT NOW.
RIGHT STREET I THINK.
OUR PERSPECTIVE WOULD BE.
THAT MUCH LIKE
SUPERINTENDENTS NOTED IN I THINK
THEY DID A GREAT JOB PAINTING A
PICTURE FOR US OF.
THE CHALLENGES THAT LOCALS ARE
DEALING WITH BECAUSE THEY ARE
REAL CHALLENGES AND WE AND WE
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO. MINIMIZE THAT BUT
JUST LIKE THEY ARE GOING THROUGH
THEIR CHALLENGES A BUDGETING
DIFFICULT DECISIONS.
INFINITE NEEDYOU COULD ARGUE
WITH FINITE RESOURCES WE ARE
GOING THROUGH MUCH THE SAME
PROCESS ON A YEAR TO YEAR BASIS.
AND SO.
WE CONTINUE TO FEEL THAT
CONTINUING TO HAVE A CUSHION OF
SOME ONE TIME A MONIES DEDICATED
TO DISCRETION WHEN I'M PURPOSES
WITHIN THE NINETYGUARANTEE. ARM
IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE APPROACH
AT THIS POINT AND I THINK I
WOULD KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE.
I'M YOU KNOW COMMIT OURSELVES TO
I'M HAVING TO COMMIT.
.
FURTHER RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY
LC FF WITHIN PROP NINETY IN
FUTURE YEARS WHILE CERTAINLY A
NOBLE GOAL TO DO THAT ON ITS
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF AN
ALREADY IN A LARGELY COMMITTED
GUARANTEED. AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FOR EXAMPLE K. TWELVE
FUNDING RECEIVES ABOUT SIXTY
NINE BILLION OF THE TOTAL OF THE
SEVENTY EIGHT.
JUST OVER SEVENTY EIGHT BILLION
IN THE GUARANTEE AND THEN ABOUT
EIGHT AND A HALF BILLION GOES TO
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND THEN
BEYOND THAT IT'S THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE BUDGET SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE BEGIN TO START
COMMITTING OURSELVES TO THESE.
ARM.
INCREASES THE CIVIC EVEN I'LL
SEE IF IT STARTS BUT PRESSURE
AND THEN WE OF THE STATE RIGHT
HAVE TO MAKE THE DECISION. OKAY
ARE WE GOING TO REDUCE ANOTHER
PROGRAM WITHIN NINETY EIGHT EVER
GONNA ELIMINATE THEM SO WE'RE
DEALING WITH IN A MUCH THE SAME
KINDS OF DECISIONS AND AT THIS
POINT WE CONTINUE TO FEEL THAT.
BECAUSE OF THAT NEW WANTS ITS
THE MOST APPROPRIATE THING TO
CONTINUE ON A ON A YEAR TO YEAR.
.
HOW APPROACH FUND ELSE IF IF AS
IT WAS ORIGINALLY ENACTED?
BUT IT CERTAINLY THE
PREROGATIVE OF THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE OTHER PROPOSALS AND YOU
KNOW THAT'S WHAT WHAT THE
COMMITTEE PROCESSES FOR.
SO.
THAT'S HELPFUL OKAY THANK YOU.
SORRY PUBLIC COMMENT TURN
MEMBERS BRED STRONG AND YOU
HEARD THE OLEO TALK ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE TO THE HIGH
POVERTY DISTRICTS. BUT WE STILL
DON'T KNOW IF HIGH POVERTY
SCHOOLS ARE ACTUALLY GETTING
MORE OF THAT ADDITIONAL MONEY.
I'M ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW WE
DO SUPPORT THE EFFORTS TO
INCREASE THE BASE.
I'M AND SPLIT A CONSISTENT WITH
THE EXISTING FORMULA A BUT ONLY
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE AND
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY THE FULL AND
FUNDING OF THE THEATER
TRANSPARENCY THAT KICKS IN AT
FULLER FULL FUNDING.
IS THAT THAT IS MAINTAINED
ADDITIONALLY WE DO RECOMMEND
SEVERAL REASONABLE BUT CRITICAL
I CHANGES THAT CONSERVE.
TEN CHRIS TRANSPARENCY WILL
WELL AND PROVIDING COMMUNITIES
WITH CENTRALIZED ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES TO AND MEANINGFUL READ
AND I'M. MATERIALS TO ENGAGE IN
EL CAP PLANNING AND AND
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT PROCESS.
I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE LANGUAGE ON
THAT AND I'M WE DO NOT THINK
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE
SENATE PROPOSAL PROVIDES AND
SUFFICIENT TRANSPARENCY AT THE
CURRENT TIME THINK. THANK YOU
AND I DIDN'T I REMIND FOLKS THAT
YOU CAN TRY TO KEEP IT TO ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU.
SARAH MUCH AS THE CAST BUT WE
COMMEND THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT LCF OFF.
WITHOUT WE DO URGE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ASPIRE TO GOAL THE
FULLY FUNDS OUR NEEDS FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND BECAUSE OF THAT.
KASBAH SUPPORTS AB TWENTY EIGHT
OH EIGHT THINK YOU THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MITCHELL MCKAY
UNDERWOOD FROM SCHOOL SERVICES
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
SEVERAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING OAKLAND UNIFIED AND
FRESNO UNIFIED ON VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS CONVERSATION
AND SETTING ASPIRATIONAL
TARGETS.
ON THESE DISTRICTS ARE CONCERNED
IN THE CURRENT ELSE FF
ENVIRONMENT THAT A COLA ONLY
WILL NOT COVER THEIR INCREASED
UP COSTS AND THAT FUTURE YEARS
SO. I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND UP ISSUE THE
CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU.
MORNING AGAIN TIM SO TOWARDS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT JUST
WANT TO GO ON RECORD SAYING THAT
TORRANCE SUPPORTS INCREASING
THE.
BASED GRANT FUNDING THANK YOU.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL HOLE
SIZE ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
SCHOOLS AND OR FORTY SEVEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SERVE ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE COUNTY.
ARMED ON ON THIS ISSUE.
IN THE TOPIC NUMBER ONE WE JUST
WANT TO BE VERY EMPHATIC THAT
ARE DISTRICTS UNANIMOUSLY
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR SELL CFF.
AND THEY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
WE ARE SYMPATHETIC TO AND
ENCOURAGED BY THE PROPOSAL
COMING FROM THE LEGISLATURE WE
BELIEVE IT SHOULD PROPOSAL
NUMBER ONE. THAT TO DEGREE THERE
ARE AVAILABLE ON GOING FUNDS IN
THE CURRENT YEAR WE WOULD
CERTAINLY. US SUPPORT TARGETING
THOSE FUNDS TO INCREASING THE LC
FF.
SECONDLY IN ANSWER TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAVEZ'S QUESTION WE
THINK THERE ALREADY IS
COMPELLING EVIDENCE IN SUPPORT
OF THE LC FF INTRONS OF ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT IF YOU'VE NOT DONE
SO. WE WOULD REFER YOU TO THE
RECENT RESEARCH BY JOHNSON AND
TEN AROUND IF YOU SEE BERKELEY
WHICH SHOWS VERY CLEARLY.
IF THE INVESTMENTS OF LCF A
FUNDS IN SUPPLEMENTAL THE
CONCENTRATION DOLLARS
I'VE HAD A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP FOR
THE TARGETED POPULATIONS
STUDENTS. OUR OWN EXPERIENCE OF
OUR OWN DISTRICTS IN KERN
REINFORCES THAT I'LL GIVE YOU
ONE EXAMPLE THE KERN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE LARGEST HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. PRIOR TO THE ALL CFF
HAD SIGNIFICANT A CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM LOWER GRADUATION
RATES.
AND HIGHER SUSPENSION RATES THAN
AVERAGE DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
AND COMPARABLE DISTRICTS.
NOW AFTER FIVE YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTING MLC FF AND GIVEN
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED THEM. THEY'VE MADE THAT
A PRIORITY AND THEY NOW HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER GRADUATION
RATES THAN THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE.
THEIR SUSPENSION RATES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW PARTICULARLY
FOR THE TARGETED POPULATIONS.
DOES THAT DOES THAT DATA IS
ECHOED BY MANY OF OUR OTHER
DISTRICTS IN ANY IN OTHER AREAS
THAT THEY'VE TARGETED BUT OUR
DISTRICTS OF RESOUNDINGLY
SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AYE WE DO SUPPORT.
INCREASING THE LCF AFTER
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS I
REGARDING THAT WE HAVE TAKEN A
SUPPORT POSITION ON AB TWENTY
NEED OEF SHOULD ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SU CHI'S. I.
SUPPORT AND LEADING NOT
CONVERSATION FOR AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT CONVERSATIONS THAT A
NUMBER OF SENATE DEMOCRATS HAVE
PUT FORWARD BECAUSE THAT
PROVIDES PRACTICAL FUNDS NOW I
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT WILL.
DOT IS ALSO IN CONTACTS WITH
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT INCREASING
SPECIAL LET FUNDING TO WE ALSO
SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
SIX BUT I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE DON'T SUPPORT THESE.
IF IT.
WE DON'T SUPPORT THE
CONVERSATIONS.
ABOUT JEOPARDIZING THE
RETIREMENT SECURITY OF OUR
MEMBERS THE LEGISLATURE TOOK A
VERY STRONG.
STANCE A NUMBER YEARS AGO WHEN
THEY MOVED A. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY
NINE WHICH PROVIDES RETIREMENT
SECURITY TORE EDUCATORS WHO ARE
SEVENTY TWO PERCENT WOMEN. SO WE
DO BELIEVE THAT HAVING
CONVERSATIONS THAT WOULD
UNDERMINE THE RETIREMENT
SECURITY OF OUR MEMBERS IS ALSO
AN ATTACK ON WOMEN WHO
DISPROPORTIONATELY DO NOT HAVE
RETIREE HEALTH IN WHO ALSO DO
NOT HAVE SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS. SO WE DON'T THINK THAT
IN ORDER TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION IT MEANS IT HAS TO
BE DONE ON THE BACKS OF THOSE
THAT ARE PRIMARILY SERVING OUR
STUDENTS. AND WE WE WOULD
SUPPORT MORE CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATION MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
I'M GOOD MORNING SUSAN MONIA ON
BEHALF OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEADERS MILITARY LEADERS AND
BUSINESS LEADERS WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT.
THE INCREASE OF THE BASS GRANT
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANT ALSO BE INCREASED.
IT'S YOU KNOW GREAT WHAT WE
WERE ABLE TO DO IN THE MIDDLE OF
A CRISIS.
BUT THAT'S WAS TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT FUNDING LEVELS WE ALL KNOW
THAT WE KNOW THAT REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS AN
ASPIRATIONAL GOAL IT'S AGO WE
HAVE TO MEET. AND.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY IT'S IT
IS ABOUT THE FUNDING BUT GREAT
THINGS ARE HAPPENING ON THE
INSTRUCTION SIDE AS WELL WITH
COMMON CORE IMPLEMENTATION WE'RE
REALLY SEEING A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS HAPPEN IN OUR SCHOOLS
WITH OUR TEACHERS AND
INSTRUCTION IN THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THEY'RE GETTING SO.
THE MONEY HAS MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE BUT THE TEACHERS ARE
ALSO MAKING A TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE AND.
I THINK WE NEED TO BE A MAYBE
FIND A WORD OTHER THAN
ASPIRATIONAL FOR WHERE WE'RE
TRYING TO GET.
WHAT WE WANT IS REALLY A HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION FOR EVERY
STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU?
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF STAFF JEFF AKA REPRESENTING
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS ON THE
TWENTY THREE SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENTS OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
BOB I THINK A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING TODAY IS POINTING TO THE
FACT THAT LCF F. WAS NEVER ABOUT
THE ADEQUACY OF FUNDING. IT WAS
ABOUT A DISTRIBUTION MODEL BASED
ON A FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE OF
EQUITY. WHICH WE CONTINUE TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. OUT WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF MERCY CHEESE
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT MAINTAINS
THAT STRUCTURE MOVING FORWARD.
OF WE THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE YET TO BE
HAD ABOUT THE DETAILS. OF HOW
THIS WORKS BUT T THE END OF THE
DAY.
THE THEME THAT YOU'RE HEARING
AND MUCH OF THE TESTIMONY IS
THAT THERE SIMPLY AREN'T ARE NOT
ENOUGH DOLLARS TO. ACHIEVE WHAT
WE WANT TO ACHIEVE AND STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT ALTHOUGH LIKE MR
HOLE SIZE ARE PERFORMING WE ARE
BEGINNING TO SEE. A LIST OF SIX
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SCHOOLS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
AND YOU CAN WATCH ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND MUCH LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE HERE WERE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. EFFORTS TO INCREASE
LCF I'VE TALKED TARGETS
INCLUDING AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT AS WELL SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
STEVE WARD LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S FOR CLOVIS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE SCHOOL
FUNDING BECAUSE A COALITION IN
OUR FORTY SEVEN DISTRICTS AND
SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS WE REPRESENT.
WE'VE WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR
FOR FULLY FUNDING THE LCF F. AND
WE ALSO FULLY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLYMAN NEAR SU CHI'S AB I
TWENTYEIGHT OO EIGHT.
WHICH WOULD CONTINUE TO GROW
OUR BASE GRANT AND ALLOW US TO
FIND THOSE NEW MANDATED COSTS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY
WHILE ALSO ALLOWING US TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF OUR BEST
FIRST INSTRUCTION.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ONGOING DOLLARS TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M
BRIAN REAVIS REPRESENTING THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST.
WERE SYMPATHETIC TO THE COST
PRESSURES AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH BY CONSIDERING
INCREASES TO THE BASE GRANT.
BUT ONE THING WE WOULD URGE
CAUTION ABOUT IS.
TRANSPARENCY.
OF IN OUR COMMUNITY AND POLICY
WORK I'LL SHARE OUR VIEWIS THAT
PEOPLE WANT TO SUPPORT LCF F..
BUT THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO SEE
PRETTY EASILY WHERE THE MONEY IS
GOING AND WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
HELPING THE TARGETED STUDENTS.
SO IN CONSIDERING INCREASING THE
BASE GRANT WERE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN ACCIDENTS ESPN
MISTER MERRETT SU CHI'S PROPOSAL
TO SEE IF WE CAN FIND A WAY TO
DO THAT WITH. WHILE ALSO
AVOIDING PUTTING US BACK INTO AN
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT THAT WAS VERY MURKY
BLEND DISTRICTS HAD TO CALCULATE
FOR THEMSELVES. HOW MUCH THEY
HAD TO SPEND AND DO A SERIES OF
CALCULATIONS IT WAS JUST VERY
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND AND SUPPORT? SO WE'RE
WORKING TOWARD THAT END WITH OUR
PARTNERS.
GERMAN MEMBERS DENNIS MYERS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION.
.
JUST WANT TO CAUTION YOU ABOUT
USING THE TERMS FULLY FUNDING
LCF F. I DON'T THINK YOU'RE EVER
REALLY GOING TO BE DONE
IMPLEMENTING ELSE FF SO. THE
NEXT STEPS ARE WHAT DO WE DO
ONCE WE REACH THE TARGETS AND SO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES THAT WE
KNOW THE SENATE DEMOCRATS BY NOT
GOING A LITTLE FURTHER AT THAT
WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT THAT
CONVERSATION.
SO YES SUPPORTING.
ADDITIONAL HIGHER TARGETS IS A
GOOD THING WE THINK IT HELPS US
ALL TO STAY FOCUSED ON THE GOAL
WHICH IS. FULL AND FAIR FUNDING
IN MOVING US BEYOND OTHER
COMMITMENTS THAT ONLY PROP
NINETY EIGHT CAN GIVE US AND
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE REALLY NEED
TO DO TO MOVE THE NEEDLE AND
ACHIEVEMENTS IN CALIFORNIA SO
YES WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE.
RECORDS PUNCHING AB TWENTY TO
WAIT WE WANT TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION THE WHAT WE DO TO
MOVE THE SYSTEM A LOT FURTHER
THAN THAT AND I'M JUST WE'VE
BEEN TARGETING SO FAR SOMETHING
CAN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON RAP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ON WHERE
PERCENT OF OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO.
FIND THE.
THE GAP NOW CFF A WE DO BELIEVE
THAT IT IS TIME FOR LCF ALPHA
TWO POINT NO.
WE THINK THAT OF FULLY FUNDING
THAT GAP.
ADDRESSES THE EQUITY ISSUE BUT
THERE IS CERTAINLY A NEED AS YOU
WELL KNOW AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
CONVERSATION AS YOU WELL KNOW
TO.
A RAISE THE BASE.
FUNDING IN A TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT LEVEL ON
BEING FORTY THIRD IN THE COUNTRY
IN TERMS OF JUST A PER PUPIL
FUNDING. IS UNACCEPTABLE AND WE
APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARISA
CHIEF FOR HIS AUTHORSHIP OF
TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT WE'VE
SIGNED ON AS A CO SPONSOR. I
THINK THIS WILL BE A LONG TERM
CONVERSATION.
I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE WHO
JUST SPOKE THAT WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT.
REVENUE AND AND HOW DO WE
REVISE THE WAY WE FUND PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
BUT WE DEFINITELY SUPPORT
INCREASING THE PACE GRANT THANK
YOU.
QUORUM KAI JACKSON WITH SENEGAL
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
CERTAINLY LIKE TO ALIGN
OURSELVES.
WITH THE COMMENTS OF OUR
COLLEAGUE AT CSPA AND SUPPORT. A
FULL AND FAIR FUNDING FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ELSE FF
AND SUPPORT OF TWENTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT. IN ADDITION THERE'S HOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER THE LC
FF IT'S WORKING INCENDIO UNIFY
WANTS TO REAFFIRM ITS COMMITMENT
TO ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY.
ARE WE LIKE TO JAZZ ARE ALSO
NOTE THAT I'M AS OF TODAY.
THE NATION'S REPORT CARD CAME
OUT AND SAY NEW UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT RANKED NUMBER ONE IN
ALL OF THE UNITED STATES. FOR
ACADEMIC GROWTH BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
PARTICULARLY IN THE FOURTH AND
EIGHTH GRADES AND WOULD LIKE TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT BE HAPPY
TALK TO MORE OFTEN. OFFLINE
ABOUT HOW THAT IS BEING.
UP SUPPORTEDTHROUGH THE LC FF
IN THE COMMITMENT OF OUR.
SO
WITH THAT I THINK YOU FOR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
ARE EXTREMELY ENCOURAGED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA AND FULLY FUND THAT. WE
ARE ALSO LOOKING AT AB TWENTY
IT'LL EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MERITS ITCHY AND ALSO WORKING
WITH THE SENATE ON THEIR
PROPOSAL. TO INCREASE THE BASE
GRANT WE I WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH BOTH RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND KERN COUNTIES
COMMENTS ABOUT THE GOOD THINGS
OF THAT ARE HAPPENING UNDER LC
FF. AS WELL AS MISTER KAI
JACKSON FROM SAN DIEGO WE ARE
ALSO WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
ALL OF OUR EIGHTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ASSIST THEM
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
NEEDING DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE. SO WE HAVE VERY
CLOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THOSE
COUNTIES OUT WITH THOSE
DISTRICTS WOULD AFFORD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND FURTHER ON
INCREASING. ARE BOTH OF THESE.
ITEMS INCLUDING THE THAT BASS
GRANT SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND MANY SILVA FROM
SAITEK OR A NETWORK OF DROPOUT
RECOVERY SCHOOLS WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT AWAY.
IN ADDITION WE'VE SPONSORED A.
BILL THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
HAS INTRODUCED THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE BASE GRANT FOR
SCHOOLS. PROVIDING.
OF RECOVERY TO DROPOUTS
TO THE SAME LEVEL AS COUNTY
OFFICES RECEIVE FOR EXPELLED
STUDENTS AND PROBATION INVOLVED
STUDENTS THAT THE UC DAVIS STUDY
THAT SHOWS THAT SIX TWO ONE THE
NINE TO ONE. A BENEFIT COST
RATIO BY RE ENGAGING MORE OF OUR
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND OUT OF
SCHOOL.
THANK THANK YOU.
IF YOU ARE COMES BUSINESS WHAT
PEOPLE KNOW THAT IT DID THIS IS
NOT THE BILL HEARING.
I KNOW THAT MISTER MARTZ WHICH
HE HAS A BILL TALKED WEBER AS A
BILL. THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE THE
IDEAS WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
CONCEPT IN THE LANDS OF THE
BUDGET. SO REFERENCING THE BILL
PROBABLY DOESN'T DO A LOT OF
EFFORT TO NOT THINK MISTER MARTZ
WHO SHE WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WILL BE HEARD IN POLICY
COMMUNITY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THIS IS A DIFFERENT.
PROCESS TODAY SO HE COULD FOCUS
ON THE CONTENT OF THE ISSUE AND
NOT.
REPEAT THE BILL NUMBER BE
HELPFUL THING I WILL DO MY BEST
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA
LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
CONCEPTUALLY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF INCREASING THE BASE GRANT OUT
WE NOTE WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO FULLY
FUND LCF HALF. CERTAINLY SUPPORT
SENATE DEMOCRATS PROPOSAL TO GO
BEYOND THAT A LITTLE BIT.
BUT WE WE'VE CERTAINLY NOT THAT
EVEN WITH LCF AWFULLY FIND IT.
CALIFORNIA BANKS I THINK IT IS
FORTY THIRD OUT IN PER PUPIL
FUNDING SO WE SUPPORT EFFORTS I
INCLUDING ON HIM BILLS AT TO INC
INCREASE AT THE BASE GRANT AND
TO INCREASE EDUCATION FUNDING.
WE ARE ALSO VERY ENCOURAGED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION. I
IN THE WORK THAT THEY DO WITH
AYE DISTRICTS AT TO DEVELOP
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN THINK YOU THINK YOU.
BILLY CO WITHOUT VOICE I'M
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE SUPPORT THE
IDEA OF INCREASING THE BASE THE
GOVERNOR ALSO HAS A PAGES LINK
THAT NOTION OF INCREASING THE
BASE TO TRANSPARENCY. AND
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY WE
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE WORK DONE ON THAT THAT
THIS THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
REALLY SHOULD TAKE LEADERSHIP IN
THAT RESPECT. OF FEDERAL LAW
ACTUALLY REQUIRES YOU TO HAVE IT
OUT IN FRONT OF YOU AND IT
ACTUALLY SAYS IT IN BLACK AND
WHITE VERY CLEARLY IN THE STATE
BOARD OF ED HAS MEETINGS
THURSDAY IN THIS IS NOT A
SUBJECT FOR WHICH. I THEY'RE
ASKING WEAVER THE FEDS THEY HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH THIS IT'S ALREADY
YEAR OVERDUE AND THE
CALIFORNIA'S TO EXERCISE
LEADERSHIP NOT JUST THE ENTITLED
ONE MONIES. BEING DISTRIBUTED
ALL THE WAY THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICTS BUT.
CERTAINLY THE BASE AND SOMEONE
AND CONCENTRATION MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S GETTING AND IN THAT
MOST NEEDED PLACES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS.
REPULSED PROPOSAL.
ESTIMATES IF YOU.
UP FIRST OF ALL.
SHARE I APPRECIATE YOUR.
A REMINDER THAT WE ARE FOCUSING
ON.
THIS SUBJECT MATTER AND NOT AND
IN THESE.
BILLS AND.
IDEA.
DID NOT ENCOURAGE ANYONE TO
SPECIFICALLY TALK ABOUT MY BILL
I WANT. YOU TO KNOW THAT.
.
SO OF A GOING BACK TO.
AND THE LA NO.
.
WHAT?
?
WHAT RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH YOU
HAVE?
IN ORDER TO BEST ADDRESS THE
DISTRICTS CONCERNS OF DRAWING
FIX BECAUSE.
I'D I I'M SORRY OF OF WHICH
SPECIFIC CONCERNS.
WE HEARD FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENTS THAT.
THE.
THE PENSION COSTS.
ARE THE BIGGEST DRIVERS.
YES YES SO.
.
YOU REFERENCED EARLIER OUR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
ANALYSIS AND I IN THAT ANALYSIS
WE HAVE A CHAPTER SPECIFICALLY
ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE. A IT IS
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT WE
HEAR ABOUT FROM THE FIELD.
THESE INCREASING PENSION
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THAT
ANALYSIS WE WE OFFER THREE
GENERAL.
.
OPTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER A OF WHICH THE FIRST
WOULD BE CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON
PROVIDING GENERAL PURPOSE
FUNDING. A AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE CONTINUING TO DEDICATE
MOST NEW PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING TO SOURCES LIKE
THE LC FF.  OR TO THESE ONE
TIME DISCRETIONARY GRANTS OF
FURTHER SUGGESTION WE WE MADE
WAS THAT. IN THE DIRECTION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE GIVES ALONG WITH
THE ONE TIME DISCRETIONARY
GRANTS.
THAT ARE OFFERED AND IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THERE IS ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION.
DEDICATED FOR THAT PURPOSE SO
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD
EXPLICITLY SICK.
SUGGEST OPTIONS FOR US
ALLEVIATING FUTURE PENSION COST
PRESSURES WE DO THINK THAT THAT
DIRECTION IS MEANINGFUL AND HOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE SPENDING
THOSE DOLLARS. AND THE LAST
OPTION THAT WE WE PRESENT.
WOULD BE.
A PAYMENT ON BEHALF OF
DISTRICTS OUT OF STATE FUNDS
THIS COULD BE EITHER PROPOSITION
OR NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDS.
WE THINK IF THE STATE WERE TO
DEDICATE.
AT LEAST SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
.
AND TO PREPAYING SOME DISTRICT
OBLIGATIONS FOR DISTRICTS AND
AND THEN CRAFTING SOME LANGUAGE
WHICH.
WOULD ASSOCIATE THE GAINS WITH
THOSE PREPAYMENTS WITH SOME
REDUCTION AND THE INCREASED
PENSION CONTRIBUTION RATES FOR
DISTRICTS THAT WOULD KICK CAN.
FOR INSTANCE AT THE NEXT
RECESSION OR AT ANY DIFFICULT
FISCAL TIMES IN THE FUTURE THAT
THAT COULD PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
RELIEF FOR DISTRICTS AT THE.
THANK YOU AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I.
CERTAINLY.
.
ADMIRE YEAR.
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE CAREFUL
STATEMENT TO NOT THEY COMMIT TO
ANY FUTURE BUDGETS.
.
TO.
ANY SPECIFIC.
.
FUNDING TARGETS.
BUT.
WE WE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR WE'RE
HEARING LOUD AND CLEAR.
NOT ONLY FROM.
DISTRICTS WITH HIGH A DUPLICATED
POPULATIONS AS WELL AS
RELATIVELY LOWER.
THAT.
THERE ARE GROWING FIXED COSTS
ARE NOT KEEPING PACE
DESPITE.
THE GOVERNOR.
YOU KNOW.
DELIVERING
SIXTY SIX PERCENT AND INCREASED.
EDUCATION FUNDING.
SINCE THE RECESSION.
SO WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES PLAN.
TO.
OUR WHAT DOES IT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PROPOSE.
TO ADDRESS THIS VERY REAL
REALITY THAT WE'RE HEARING.
FROM URBAN DISTRICTS SUBURBAN
DISTRICTS ROLE DISTRICTS.
ABOUT.
THE RAPIDLY RISING FIXED COSTS
THAT ARE NOT KEEPING PACE WITH
THESE GOOD BUDGET.
BUDGETS THAT THE THE GOVERNOR
HAS BEEN DELIVERING.
I THINK.
I WOULD NOTE TOM
THAT.
OBVIOUSLY THE IN THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
BUT AGAIN.
IT.
COUPLED WITH INCREASING COSTS
LIKE WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
I'M WE DID PUT IN AS AS THE.
.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OUT
MENTIONED SUGGESTING LANGUAGE IN
OUR TRAILER BILL IT WOULDN'T
ALREADY IN THERE.
SPECIFYING THAT OF THAT ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IT'S
GONNA GO OUT FOR DISCRETIONARY
ONETIME PURPOSES. OF SUGGESTING
IN AND PUTTING IT IN THEIR IN
LANGUAGE ACTUALLY TO SAY. THESE
YOU KNOW CAN BE USED FOR.
.
STEPPED BENEFIT COSTS.
AND PENSION COSTS THAT THAT'S
THAT'S AND ALLOW THE USE THAT AT
THE DISCRETION AGAIN IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WHERE THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT OF
OKAY HOW MUCH OF A ONE TIME
RESOURCE WE WANT TO COMMIT MAYBE
THAT ONGOING THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TO.
PLAN ACCORDINGLY.
ON THAT.
BUT I THINK.
I WOULD REITERATE WHAT I SAID
EARLIER THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE LC FF AS IT WAS
ORIGINALLY ENACTED IN ENVISIONED
THE DEAL THAT WAS STRUCK BETWEEN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE AND
THE LEGISLATURE. AND I THINK
WITHIN THAT.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST A FISCAL
PICTURE.
BUT IT SAY ALSO BUT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE AND AND
IT'S AN OUTCOME
SURE LIKE NOT SOME MEMBER CHAVEZ
SPOKE TO EARLIER WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO IMPROVE ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES NOT JUST MAKE SURE
PEOPLE GET. YOU KNOW WHAT
WHATEVER THE OTHER CASE MAY BE
AND I THINK IN LINE WITH THAT
WERE ALSO TRYING TO MAKE STRIDES
HAVE THE YOU KNOW THE.
THE DASHBOARD WE'RE TRYING TO.
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
MONITORING PROGRESS ON THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS WE CAN.
YOU KNOW WITH THE BUDGET
CROSSWALK DOCUMENT CONTINUE TO
GIVE.
LOCALS MORE.
POWER I GUESS YOU COULD SAY OR
MORE OF THE OF IT INSIGHT.
INTO THAT AND UNDERSTANDING
INTO WHAT'S GOING ON I THINK
I'LL SEE IF IF IT WENT A LONG
WAY IN ENABLING THEM TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT BUT WE'VE HAD THE
LAST TWO YEARS THAT YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO WORK OUT THE THE.
.
THE KINKS IF YOU WILL.
AND I THINK IN LINE WITH THAT
THAT'S WHERE I THINK LOCALS
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS REALLY
ARE IN THE BEST POSITION MORE SO
THAN US. TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION IF I CAN BE
TOTALLY HONEST WHERE THEY'RE
HAVING THE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THEIR A LOCAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THEIR STUDENTS THEIR PARENTS
THAT THEIR TEACHERS.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE
SOMETHING AGAIN THAT WEEK WE CAN
ONLY DO SO MUCH WE CAN ONLY
PROVIDE SO MANY RESOURCES WITHIN
A FINITE POT. CERTAINLY AGAIN
IT'S WITHIN THE PROJECT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ON ALLOCATE
THROUGH EXISTING RESOURCES YOU
KNOW TO
TO. TAKE IT FROM SOMEONE ELSE
PUT INTEL CFF AND THAT'S THE
DISCUSSION OBVIOUSLY WILL WILL
HAVE TO BE A PART OF.
BUT I THINK THAT WOULD BE MY
ANSWER THAT REALLY YOU KNOW WE
WE WE'VE VIEW THAT WERE TAKEN%
THE MOST PRUDENT APPROACH THAT
WE CAN.
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW THAT IS
LIKELY GOING TO BE THE FISCAL
OUTLOOK MOVING YEARS FORWARD YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME
A LOOMING RECESSION.
.
AND LOCALS REALLY ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE YOU KNOW OF MOST
PIVOTAL IN THAT SADDAM.
DISCUSSION
LOT LAST QUESTION.
YOU IT EXPRESSED YOUR RELUCTANCE
TO SUPPORT.
FINDING TARGETS GOING FORWARD.
AND YET.
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WHEN IT WAS PASSED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN THE A
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA WAS IN
FACT THE TOP THE FINDING
TARGETS.
THAT WE ESTABLISHED IS THAT
CORRECT.
YES OKAY AND SO AND AND AFFECT
THOSE FUNDING TARGETS WORK TO
GET.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BACK TO
THE.
SEVEN OH EIGHT FUNDING LEVEL
ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION.
I BELIEVE ORIGINALLY YES THAT
WAS THE.
YEAH.
SO THERE THERE'S CONCEPTUALLY
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
SENDING FINDING TARGETS.
RIGHT.
YEAH I THINK I WOULD AGREE
CONCEPTUALLY TECHNICALLY I'M IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT IT CAN
BE IN THE MINUTES CERTAINLY
THERE'S NOTHING INHERENTLY WRONG
THERE.
IT'S MORE OF THE FISCAL REALITY
AND KIND OF YOU KNOW POLITICAL
OUTSIDE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AYE AYE
YEAH I WANT TO SAY THAT TIGHT I
SUPPORT THE. CONCEPT PRESENTED
HERE.
WITH IS WHETHER WITHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
ACCOMPANYING IT'S.
I DO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THIS
HOUSE TO FIT IN WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT. COMPETING INTERESTS
CERTAINLY.
WE'RE LOOKING AT EASY E.
SPECIAL.
CT  AND SO WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT.
OTHER PRIORITIES BUT THAT THE
NOTION HERE.
I THINK AS YOU ALLUDE TO MISTER
MARTZ RICHIE IT IS A TARGET AND
IT'S A MARKER FOR CALIFORNIA AS
FAR AS WHERE WE WANT TO GOT I
THINK ONE OF THE.
SPEAKERS EARLIER TALKED ABOUT
WHAT ELSE IT HEALTHY FF FIRST
CAME OUT BEFORE I WAS HERE IT IS
YOUR FIRST TERM.
YOU KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THE
EQUITY ISSUE MAKING SURE WE
SCHOOL FUNDING IS EQUITABLE AND
OF COURSE THE LOCAL CONTROL
CONCEPT BUT IT DIDN'T ALWAYS
FOCUS ON THE ADEQUACY OF FUNDING
AS WE HEARD AT OUR FIRST HEARING
FROM.
SUPERINTENDENT TOILETS AND THEY
WERE INCREASED SCHOOL FUNDING.
.
BY RECORD AMOUNTS TO LAST FIVE
YEARS AND WE'RE STILL FORTY
SECONDS OR FORTY FIRST IN THE
NATION IN PER PUPIL FUNDING.
SO WE HAVE A LONG WAYS TO GO.
CERTAINLY MONEY ISN'T THE
ANSWER TO EVERYTHING WITHOUT THE
WORK ON STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AS
WELL BUT.
MORE RESOURCES ARE A KEY
ELEMENT ESPECIALLY WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE NEEDS AS OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS.
OUTLINED EARLIER BUT I THINK
THIS.
WILL ENABLE US TO TO PRIORITIZE
AND ALSO PUT A MARKER DOWN THE
ROAD SO WILL WE WILL EVALUATE
THIS IN THE IN THE TOTALITY.
OF OF THE ISSUE.
BEFORE THE AT.
THE FINALITY OF THE BUDGET AFTER
THE MAY REVISE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE I OPEN OF COURSE. ARE NEXT
TO A PROPOSAL WE WANT TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
FORMING STUDENT GROUP. THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AGAIN. A LA.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BERMAN OF
ED GIVE US THAT AN OVERVIEW OF
THE PROPOSAL ON OUT AND ALLOW
THE PUBLIC INCLUDING OUR
COLLEAGUE. AT DOCTOR WEBER TO
PRATT PRESENT TO US AS WELL.
YES PROPOSAL THAT IS MENTIONED
IN
THE AGENDA WOULD EXPAND THAT ON
DUPLICATED COUNT TO INCLUDE THE%
STERN SUBGROUP. WHO PERFORMED?
LOWEST ON STATEWIDE ASSESSMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA EXEMPTING THOSE
GROUPS THAT ALREADY BENEFIT FROM
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING EITHER IN
LC A FAST OR THROUGH OTHER STATE
AND FEDERAL PROGRAMS. ARE IN
STANDING OF THE LATEST DATA ON
SOON OUTCOMES IS THAT THE SUB
GROUP THAT WOULD BE ADDED TO THE
ON TO PLACATE ACCOUNT UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS.
THEY GIVE.
BUT AGAIN AT THIS POINT WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
HAVE NO OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
DUB THAT LEGISLATION AND REALLY
BUG THE CONCEPT I'M AND WE
REALLY HAVEN'T HAD. A CHANCE TO
TO DO THE FULL APPROPRIATE
ANALYSIS OF
PROPOSAL AS WELL TO BE ABLE TO
OPINE.
DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TRUCKS AND WE
TWO HAVE NOT TAKEN A PROPOSED
THAT POSITION ON THIS PROPOSAL
YET WE'RE STILL I AM. REVIEWING
IT IN IN DETAIL BUT I DO AGREE
WITH THE INTENT AND THE
MOTIVATION BEHIND IT WHICH IS
REALLY HOW DO WE. TARGET READS
IF IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS HAD WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TARGETING A
RESOURCES TO I'M OUR HIGHEST
NEED STUDENTS.
OKAY.
WELL NOW ALLOW. PUBLIC COMMENT
SO WE CAN HAVE A OF A LINE UP
AND WILL ALLOW COURSE OUR
COLLEAGUE DOT TO EVERYDAY COME
UP HERE AND JOIN US AT THE
TABLE.
THANK YOU.
MET MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO TACKLE A FLAW
THAT HAS BEEN DISCOVERED IN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
SINCE IT WAS INSTITUTED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND EFFORT TO
TARGET RESOURCES TO THE HIGHEST
NEED STUDENTS IN STATE. I THINK
THE THREE OF US WHO WERE HERE
WHEN WE AND FOUGHT FOR LC FF IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN.
AND MISTER MURATSUCHI AND
MISTER CHAVEZ AND I BOTH KNOW
THAT UP IT WAS A VALIANT EFFORT
TO START TALKING ABOUT HOW DO WE
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND ONE OF THOSE THINGS WE
THOUGHT WE HAD IDENTIFIED THE
CATEGORIES THAT WOULD INCLUDE
EVERYONE IN THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE L. CFF IS ALWAYS SEEN AS A
LIVING DOCUMENT A LIVING
PROCESS.
THAT WHEN WE.
THAT IT'S NOT SET IN STONE BUT
IT IS A BILL AND HAS THE ABILITY
TO BE FLEXIBLE TO HELP US TO
MEET THE GOALS WE SET FOR
OURSELVES.
AS WE DESCRIBED EARLIER THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FOR MY
CONSIST OF A BASE GRANT
CONCENTRATION GRANTS AND
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS.
A MY PROPOSAL WOULD INCREASE A
NEW SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT GOING
FORWARD FOR THE LOWEST
PERFORMING GROUP.
STUDENTS OUTSIDE OF THE STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND AND AND AT
THIS POINT THAT GROUP IS A
AFRICAN AMERICANS BUT WOULD
APPLY TO ANYONE ANY GROUP THAT'S
THE IF WE HAVE TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WE HAVE TO
IDENTIFY THE GROUP.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EXPECTED
SCORES CONFIRM A DISTURBING FACT
THAT HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED FOR
YEARS AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
IRRESPECTIVE OF INCOME ARE
PERFORMING BELOW THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE IN BOTH ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS AND MATH. ONLY THIRTY ONE
PERCENT OF THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS THEY ADMIT STANDARDS AND
ONLY NINETEEN PERCENT MET THE
MAMAK.
OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN STUDY
THAT THE MOST OF YOU PROBABLY
SAME DONE DONE BY UC BERKELEY ON
ON HOW THE CENTRALIZING SCHOOL
FINANCE MAY NARROW ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS. UNEVEN PROGRESS IN
CALIFORNIA AFTER FORTY ONE
BILLION BY BROUGH BY FULLER AND
LEAD.
FOUND THAT THE SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS RECEIVING
CONCENTRATION GRANTS DOING THE
INITIAL TWO YEARS OF LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA DIDN'T
GAUGING ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGE
THAT PARALLELS GAINS IN STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT. COMPARED WITH
SCHOOLS IN ALMOST IDENTICAL
DISTRICTS NOT RECEIVING
CONCENTRATION GRANTS
THESE BENEFITS WERE LARGELY
EXPERIENCE BY LATINO STUDENTS
AND NOT BY OTHER GROUPS AS
SIGNIFICANT LEVELS BUT THEY ALSO
NOTE THAT THERE THAT QUOTE THE
INABILITY TO DETECT GAINS FOR
BLACK STUDENTS IS WORTH SOME.
THESE EARLY FINDINGS SUGGEST%
THAT WHAT ELSE CFF SUPPLEMENTS
MAY BE IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR
LATINO STUDENTS AS INTENDED A
NOTABLE GAP REMAINS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN THE STATE
PUT IN SIXTY THOUSAND ARE
RECEIVING A SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
BECAUSE THEY ARE LOW INCOME. ELL
A HOMELESS OF FOSTER KIDS
HOWEVER THERE IS A SUBGROUP OF
ABOUT NINETY THOUSAND STUDENTS
WOULD NOT RECEIVING A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT. AND NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND SUPPORT
IN ORDER TO IMPROVE THE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE.
THIS IS THE ONLY GROUP OF
STUDENTS PERFORMING BELOW THE
STATE AVERAGE THAT ARE NOT
ALREADY RECEIVING SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANTS.
BASED ON TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FIGURES WE ESTIMATE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE EL IS NEEDED TO IN
RESOURCES FOR TARGETED STUDENTS
AND ASSISTANCE.
THE FIGURE INCLUDE BUT ARE BOTH
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION TO
AND FUNDING USING EXISTING LCF A
FORMULA.
WITH THREE HUNDRED EIGHT THREE
POINT EIGHT BILLION IN NEW.
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING THIS
YEAR NOW'S THE TIME TO FIX IS
EDUCATIONAL IN EQUITY IN FULFILL
THE PROMISE OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA TO TARGET
RESOURCES TO STUDENTS THAT ARE
MOST IN NEED. AS WITH OTHER LCF
A FUNDS DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHAT STATE WHAT
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND SERVICES
THEY WILL BE OFFERING HIGH NEED
STUDENTS IN OTHER. IN THEIR
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN THIS WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ASSURANCE
THAT THE NEW FUNDING WILL BE
TARGET FOR LOCALLY LOCALLY
DETERMINED PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
TO BEST MEET THE NEEDS OF THESE
PUPILS.
ALSO THE GOVERNOR'S OF BUDGET OF
TALKED ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
I THINK WE SAW THAT EL OF THE LA
HAS REJECTED THE
ACCOUNTABILITY. THAT IS PUT
FORTH BY THE GOVERNOR.
WILL ALSO A LOOKING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND BE WE HAVE
WE'RE PROPOSING SOME LANGUAGE
THAT WE WILL BE SEEING FAIRLY
SOON TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. MOST OF US WHO
WORKED ON THE LC FF IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN KNOW THAT WE WILL BE
SURE THAT THAT BE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY TO MAKE SURE
THOSE DOLLARS WENT WITH A
SUPPOSED TO GO. AND THAT WE CAN
TRACK IT AND BASICALLY SEE WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IN OUR SCHOOLS.
WE ARE NOW PROPOSING SOME
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES YOU SHOULD
REALLY BE RECEIVING FAIRLY SEWN
TO THIS COMMITTEE TO MEET THAT
NEED THE GOVERNOR'S FINALLY SAID
WE NEED ACCOUNTABILITY. A AS AS
AS HE'S GOING OUT THE DOOR HE
SAYINGS FILING WITH UNDER SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY.
HE HAD PROPOSED SOMETHING THAT
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT ADEQUATE THAT
MANY FOLKS PERSPECTIVE AND YOU
WE WILL BE SHARING WITH YOU A
AND AN ACCOUNTABILITY DOCUMENT.
THAT CAN BE USED IN THE BUDGET
THAT BEEN WOULD REQUIRE THOSE
DOLLARS TO BE TRACK.
I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BE HERE TO PRESENT AT CONCERNING
THIS PROPOSAL OF THIS PROPOSAL
IS ONE OF THE IS THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY OF THE. A CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
TERMS OF BUDGET ASK THIS YEAR IN
TERMS OF WITH CHANGING AND
EXPANDING LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT ARE.
YOU KNOW I THINK AROUND I THINK
SO LARA FLYNN QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT YOU HAVE TIME OH YEAH YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JEFF AKA
REPRESENTING RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
I WON'T BREAK THE RULES BY
MENTIONING A BILL NUMBER THAT WE
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER HAS DOCTOR WEBER
HAS IDENTIFIED AN ISSUE THAT IS
DEFINITELY. WORTHY OF FURTHER
CONVERSATION.
AS OUR COUNTY OFFICES WORKING
WITH OUR DISTRICTS TO DO A DEEP
DIVE INTO THEIR STUDENT
PERFORMANCE DATA. THEY ARE
FINDING THAT THERE ARE SOME
INSTANCES WHERE THE AREAS OF
GREATEST NEED FALL OUTSIDE OF
THE CATEGORIES THAT GENERALLY
GENERATE A SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE INCREASED
PROGRAMS
SO WE WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION WE DO BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT.
THE METHOD BY WHICH WE IDENTIFY
THOSE SUBGROUPS AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO MAINTAIN THE FLEXIBILITY
AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES. WHERE THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE AT EACH DISTRICT
WHICH MAY BE AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS BUT IT MAY VERY VERY
WELL BE ANOTHER GROUP OF
STUDENTS SUCH AS FOSTER YOUTH?
SO. WHERE THE CONVERSATION AND
WE THANK DOCTOR WEBER FOR
BRINGING THAT FORWARD CAN THINK
YOU?
TERRY MEMBERS BRAD STRONG
CHILDREN NOW.
SOME DISTRICTS LIKE OAKLAND OR
MAKING CONCERTED EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC ACTIONS
PROGRAMS NEEDS OF OUR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS. THE MY WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LANCET OUT
CAN AMERICAN EDUCATORS IN AND
OUT SO A BLACK EDUCATION NETWORK
HAS MADE IT CLEAR TO ME THAT
SUCH EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF OUR LOWEST
PERFORMING SUBGROUPS ARE FAR
FROM. OUR FOR OUR FOR A FAR THE
EXCEPTION NOT THE RULE THEM WE
WE SUPPORT THE ADDITION OF THE
LOWEST PERFORMING SUBGROUP I'M
TO ADDRESS THE DECADES OF
UNREALIZED. POTENTIAL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARGARET FORTUNE ON THE
C. E. O. FORTUNE SCHOOL WHICH IS
A NETWORK OF TUITION FREE PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS. LOCATED IN
SACRAMENTO AND SAN BERNADINO.
WE ARE REGIONAL INITIATIVES TO
CLOSE THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
ACHIEVEMENT GAP THAT WAS
APPROVED BY THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION.
BECAUSE OF THE PERSISTENT
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN ALL THIRTEEN
OF THE COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I'M RELATED TO AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS.
WHO LIKE GOD AT THE STATEWIDE
LEVEL AT THE LOWEST PERFORMING
SUBGROUP OUTSIDE OF STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS?
WE ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL.
I WANT TO MAKE A FEW.
HIGHLIGHTS TO THE PROPOSAL.
ONE OF THE CRITICS OF THIS
PROPOSAL HAS BEEN. THAT IT WOULD
CREATE A PERVERSE INCENTIVE.
IT TO A INTENTIONALLY HAVE
STUDENTS UNDERPERFORM IN ORDER
TO GET THE RESOURCES.
AM I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT
WE THAT I BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
NOT THE CASE.
OKAY THAT WERE THE CASE IN THAT
WOULD UNDERMINE THE REASON FOR
HAVING SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS FOR
ANY SUBGROUP OF STUDENTS.
AND JUST TO MAKE SURE THIS
PROPOSAL. UP WOULD HAVE THE
INITIAL SUBGROUP IT'S IDENTIFIED
FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FISCAL YEAR CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
FUNDING UNTIL THEIR PERFORMANCE.
MATCHES MATCHES THE PERFORMANCE
OF THE HIGHEST PERFORMING SUB
GROUP SO THERE IS A CONCERN
ABOUT.
AT HAVING A DISINCENTIVE TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
THIS BILL ACTUALLY PROVIDES AN
INCENTIVE TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS BILL IDENTIFIES
STUDENTS NOT BY THEIR SUBGROUP.
BUT BY THEIR ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE.
I THINK THAT.
.
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS HAVE
HAVE A CERTAIN DEGREE OF
INVISIBILITY.
WE'RE AT HAS BEEN HANDS OFF IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC POLICY
SPECIFICALLY FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS.
AND THE RESULT HAS BEEN THE
CALCIFIED.
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AT THE
BOTTOM FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS AND THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THAT AHEAD ON.
SO WE IN THURSDAY ASK WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL. I WANNA KNOW THE
FOURTEEN SCHOOL IS ONE OF TWELVE
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE THAT IS
MEANT IN THE THAT SERVES A
MAJORITY AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. THAT IS IN THE TOP
HALF OF ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE IN
THE STATE. AND THE TOP TEN
PERCENT WHEN COMPARED TO SIMILAR
SCHOOLS.
SO WE KNOW HOW TO DO THIS WORK
AND THEIR OTHER SCHOOLS AROUND
THE STATE TO NOTICE HOW TO DO
THIS WORK AND WE WOULD LIKE THIS
TO BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPREAD
THOSE PACKED PRACTICES.
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL THROUGH
THE AL CAPP PROCESS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
AND REMIND PEOPLE I ONE MINUTE
PLEASE I DID GIVE. A MISFORTUNE
WERE TIME KNOWING THAT SHE WAS
ONE OF THE ARCHITECTS OF THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE US TODAY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I AM MEMBERS
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. FIRST AND FOREMOST
WOULD LIKE TO THANK DOCTOR WEBER
FOR HER EFFORTS OVER THE YEARS A
TO IMPROVE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE L. LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE BEEN WATCHING. AND
ADMIRING AND.
IN THAT VEIN OUR BOARD AND
SUPERINTENDENT STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL WE KNOW THAT WHEN
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA FIRST CAME INTO BEING
ONE OF THE GOALS WAS TO LIFT ALL
BOATS. AND WE DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE ANY CHILDREN BEHIND AND WE
THINK THIS PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS OR ANY
STUDENTS APPLICABLE SUBSEQUENTLY
IDENTIFIED AS LOW PERFORMING. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL AND THE FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU THANK YOU.
THAT'S MYERS CALIFORNIA SQUARE
ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF
THE PROPOSAL.
JUSTIN THE PRIOR CONVERSATION
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT'S NEXT IN LCF
AFTER THIS IS ONE THING WE THINK
IS NEXUS IS ADDRESSING.
PARTICULAR GROUPS OF STUDENTS
THAT ARE MISSING OUT ON THE
BENEFIT OF THE TARGETING OF
EXTRA FUNDING AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS REALLY ALL ABOUT.
STUDENTS WHO ARE ARE NOT
ACHIEVING AT WHERE THEY SHOULD
BE AND HELPS US TO STEER. A
SEMESTER RESOURCES DOT TO THE
STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
START AS WE SAID YOU KNOW JUST
WITH THAT MS GIBBS IS LIFTING
ALL BOATS WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT.
IN WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT IT HOPE
THAT THAT WE CAN MOVE THIS ALONG
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIAN REVERSE
SOME BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION
TRUST WEST WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL WE THINK DOCTOR WEBER
HAS PERHAPS UNCOVERED. A BLIND
SPOT IN IT'LL CFF BY IDENTIFYING
A GROUP OF STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT
DOING WELL IN WOULD DO BETTER
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH AND
EVIDENCE IF WE ADDED THEM TO THE
CATEGORY. QUALIFYING FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING WE ALSO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS GROUP'S NEEDS AND
GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION. AND THE EL CAP
PROCESS
AND FINALLY PERHAPS HOUSE
IMPORTANT IS THIS INDIVIDUAL
PROPOSAL WE NEED TO ASK
OURSELVES WHY IS IT. THAT ONE
GROUP CONSISTENTLY COMES OUT ON
THE BOTTOM I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
GET BRIEFED ON THAT DATA PULLED
TOGETHER BY THE PROPONENTS.
IT'S VERY COMPELLING BUT PERHAPS
AS IMPORTANT AS THIS INDIVIDUAL
PROPOSAL WE NEED TO ASK
OURSELVES WHAT'S HAPPENING
SYSTEMICALLY TO AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M CALLING MILLER
WITH CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION AND CCS A STRONGLY
SUPPORTS TARGETING FUNDS TO THE
MOST HIGH NEED STUDENTS TO
IMPROVE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY FOR
ALL STUDENTS. A DOCTOR WORKERS
PROPOSAL ACTUALLY WOULD CORRECT
OF A CLEAR.
FLAW IN THE LC FF WHICH IS
INTENDED OF COURSE TO.
TO TARGET THE.
RESOURCES TO THE MOST HIGH NEED
STUDENTS AND THIS GROUP OF THE.
THE LOWEST PERFORMINGSEPARATE
PISTONS THERE'S ABSOLUTE GAP IN
THE DATA IS UNDISPUTED BALL THAT
THE STUDENTS ARE IN NEED OF
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORTS.
JEFF UP BASED FUNDING IS
INSUFFICIENT FOR ALL SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS.
BUT.
FULL FUNDING THIS YEAR WILL
WILL PROVIDE A PRETTY STRONG
INCREASE IN THE BASE FOR UP FOR
ALL.
AND WAS SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN PROP NINETY EIGHT OVERALL
THIS YEAR WEAKER AS THE
COMMITTEE TO ALSO PRIORITIZE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO TRULY MEET
THIS CALL OF EDUCATIONAL EQUITY.
ENVISIONED BY THE ALSO FF AND
CLOSES PERSISTENT YOU MAKE OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SEAN THE MORE
AND I'M WITH FORTUNE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION I STRONGLY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR WAIVERS
PROPOSAL TO CLOSE THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN ACHIEVEMENT GAP. ARM
WHICH IS THE LOVE OF THE LOWEST
PERFORMANCE THAT GROUPS OF
STUDENTS STUDENTS OUTSIDE OF
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS BY
ADDING THEM TO THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE MCANDREW
IT ON BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF DOCTOR WEBBER'S
PROPOSAL IN THIS CONVERSATION
YOU MAY NOTE THAT WE HAVE A
SPECIFIC.
OFFICE OF AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE
ACHIEVEMENT UP FIRST IN THE
NATION SO WE ARE VERY FOCUSED.
ON THAT THE STUDENT POPULATION
AND APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR THE STUDENTS TO.
SUPPORT THEIR SUCCESS AND THANK
YOU.
JENNIFER BAKER AT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A
WATCH ON THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
ARE TAKING PLACE WE BELIEVE THAT
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS. IMPORTANT
IS THE CONTEXT IN THE
METHODOLOGIES THAT WHERE YOU
SEEN WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD AND EXACTLY HOW
WE'RE GOING TO SPECIFY WHICH
WOULD FUNDING GOES TO WHICH
STUDENTS BECAUSE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CATEGORIES OF STUDENTS
INCLUDING SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS WERE WE ALSO HAVE
SYSTEMIC PROGRAMS. WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
DOING THIS TO THE EXCLUSION OF
OTHER STUDENTS SUCH AS NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS OR OTHERS THAT
ARE IN LOWER PERFORMING.
STUDENTS ANOTHER SUBGROUP SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE. ALL
STUDENTS ARE SUCCEEDING WHILE
WE'RE ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WERE
CAPTURING STUDENTS THAT NEED
MORE ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ET DELUDE SEE WITH THAT VOICE IT
I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED ABOUT THE
EARLIER COMMENT YOU JUST HEARD
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK. THE WAY
THIS IS PROPOSALS DRAFTED THAT
THERE WOULD BE A LOWER
PERFORMING SUB. WHOLE POINT IS
THIS IS A LOW WORST PERFORMING
SUBGROUP AND IT'S TIME TO QUIT
BEING DATED DENIERS AYE THE DATE
IN FRONT OF YOU. IT'S
DESPICABLE.
AND THERE'S IT'S TIME FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND WHETHER
IT'S THIS. GROUP AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL ARE DOWN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL EACH INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICT THEY'LL CAP SHOULD BE
INTENTIONALLY PROGRAMMING
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS. THESE KINDS
OF INEQUITIES IN EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION.
SHOOTING.
THE AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT NOT ALSO MAKING
EARLIER TO THE.
LCF F. DISCUSSION I DO
APPRECIATE DOT WEBER FOR
BRINGING THIS.
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FORWARD.
MYSELF MR SICHUAN THIS
COMMITTEE BACK WHEN ELSE IF FAST
AND AND OUR OUR CHAIRWOMAN IS IN
THE AUDIENCE TERM OF BENICIA.
AYE WHEN WE HAD OUR YOU KNOW
SHIRLEY VIGOROUS AND MISTER
CHAVEZ IS ON THE COMMITTEE BACK
THEN TO WE HAD A. YOU KNOW A LOT
OF LOT OF DEBATE LOT OF.
BACK AND FORTH BUT I THINK
EVERYBODY.
FULLY EMBRACE THE GOALS OF
BRINGING OUR HAVING A FOCUS ON.
GROUPS THAT HAD REALLY BEEN LEFT
BEHIND.
AND THAT THAT'S WHY BILLY
APPRECIATE.
DOCKWORKERS PROPOSAL I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT AS WE.
ARE LOOKING OUT THE FULL FUNDING
OF AL CFF
WHAT ELSE GOES ALONG WITH IT AND
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO LOOK
AT. WHETHER OR NOT AFTER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO REALLY ON TO MAKE THE KIND OF
PROGRESS IN THE VARIOUS AREAS.
THAT WE'D WE'D HOPED AND I
THINK IT'S ALSO EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT AT THE AT THIS
TIME AS WE IMPLEMENT A HEALTH
EFFECT THAT WE ALSO HAVE. FULL
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES I YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN PUSHING FOR
MORE ACCOUNTABILITY MORE
TRANSPARENCY ONLY ONLY TO BE
TOLD THAT WE HAVE TO WAIT. TELL
ALL CF GRAPH IS FULLY FUNDED
WILL THIS IS THE YEAR THAT FULLY
FUNDED IS BEING FULL FUNDING OF
AUSSIE THAT HAS BEEN PROPOSED.
SO WE ABSOLUTELY EXPECT THAT WE
WILL HAVE DIED NO FULL FUNDING
WITHOUT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES.
FULLY IN LINE WITH WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR OVER THIS
LAST A COUPLE YEARS.
SO THAT I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
AGAIN DOCTOR WEBER KEEPING HER
EYES ON THE PRIZE AND STAYING
VERY FOCUSED ON OUR CHILDREN AND
MAKING SURE. THAT.
IF THERE ARE KIDS THAT ARE
BEING THE PRINT THAT WE FIND
WAYS TO KIND OF BRING BRING THEM
UP.
THANK YOU.
SMART. HEATH RAISING YOUR HAND
NOW TRIAL YES YES OKAY AYE AYE
IT'S OF A QUESTION. I GUESS IS
FOR DOCTOR WEBER BUT.
HOW IS?
SUB GROUP DEFINED.
WELL I THINK.
I THINK WE'VE HAD SOME
FEDERALLY DEFINED SUBGROUPS
BASED ON ETHNICITY AT WHICH IN
OTHER WORDS WE'VE IDENTIFIED
ALREADY TALKED AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND. HISPANICS API YOU KNOW SO
THAT'S HOW WE COLLECT THAT DATA
WHEN WE DISAGGREGATED DATA WE
DISAGGREGATED BASED ON WHAT WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IDENTIFIES AS THAT THAT'S SUB
GROUPS THEMSELVES. ARE GENERALLY
I GUESS THEY LOOK AT CULTURAL
IDENTITY SO FORTH AND SO ON AS
THE AS THE DEFECATION A PICKUP
GROUPS.
SO DO THE.
THE END. UP THERE THE. CTA.
MENTIONED SPECIAL EDUCATION IS
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
INCLUDED AS A POTENTIAL
SUBGROUP.
I THINK WE'VE GOT A WE'VE
MENTIONED THE FACT THAT WE THIS
WOULD NOT SAID THIS WOULD IT WE
WERE LOOKING AT THE SUBGROUPS
TAKING OUT SPECIAL LITTLE IN
TERMS OF SUBGROUPS BECAUSE.
THEY'RE SPECIAL KINDS OF THINGS
WE DO IN SPECIAL ED THAT OF A
LITTLE DIFFERENT AND WHAT WE DO
IN REGULAR ED IN TERMS OF
FUNDING. AND THAT CLEARLY WE DO
NOT FUND SPECIAL THAT ENOUGH.
AND ALL AND MOST OF US
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR THAT AND
WE HAVE FEDERAL GUIDELINES AND
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS STATE
REQUIREMENTS REGARDING. THE
FUNDING OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
SO IS SUB GROUP DIDN'T MIND IN
ANY WAY OTHER THAN BY RACE OR
ETHNICITY.
AB WELL I AM SURE THAT MANY WAYS
THAT WE LOOK AT SUB GROUPS AND
IN THE END NOT IN TERMS TO LOOK
AT LOOK AT GENDER.
OF MALE FEMALE WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT DIFFERENT AREAS OF MOST
FOLKS WHEN THEY DISAGGREGATED
DATA DISAGGREGATED IN A NUMBER
OF WAYS TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
ISSUES WHEN WE LOOK AT US STEM
EDUCATION.
WE NOT ONLY DO IT BASED ON
GENDER BUT WE ALSO DO IT BASED
ON ETHNICITIES OF THAT OF THEIR
SOUL OUT WE LOOK TO SEE WITH
THEIR DISPARITIES AND SOMETIMES
IT MAKES SENSE THAT DOM. WE HAVE
A WHOLE OF A GENDER ISSUE THAT
WE PUT INTO THE CATEGORIES
SOMETIME TO THE AREA OF MATH AND
SCIENCE WE DO.
BUT OFTENTIMES WE DON'T DO THAT
BECAUSE WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DATA
IT THERE'S NOTHING TO SAY THAT
THIS IS A. THIS IS A SUB GROUP
IT NEEDS A FOCUS OF WHAT WE DID
WITH THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP WAS
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY RECEIVED
INFORMATION. A LOCALLY AND
STATEWIDE REGARDING WHAT THE
VARIOUS.
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS ARE IN OUR IT
CODE IDENTIFIES ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
AS WELL IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF
NOT GAPS BUT IDENTIFIES THE
CATEGORIES THAT OF THE YEAR.
THEY CAN BE ETHNIC GROUPS THAT
CAN BE SO SO ECONOMIC THEY CAN
BE ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS ALL
THOSE THINGS WE IDENTIFIED. A
MOST OF YOU KNOW WOOD BEGAN WITH
THOUGH THE LC OF PFAFF WE.
WE ENDED UP WITH THESE GROUPS
THAT WE THOUGHT WERE GOING TO BE
SIGNIFICANT GROUPS THAT SHOWED A
A DISPARITY IN TERMS OF
ACHIEVEMENT AND THEY GENERALLY
WORK ITS WILL FOSTER CARE. ARE
KIDS WHO ARE HOMELESS OF BECAUSE
OF THE SOCIO ECONOMIC SITUATIONS
WHICH THEY FOUND THEMSELVES BUT
WE ALSO LOOK AT THE VARIOUS
ETHNICITIES AS WELL WE ALSO LOOK
INTO ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
BECAUSE THAT WAS A PART OF IT.
YOU REMEMBER ORIGINALLY THIS LC
FF DID NOT TALK BUT ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
BUT TALK ABOUT ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY.
AND IF WE KEPT THAT LANGUAGE WE
PRIDE WOULD HAVE INCLUDED THIS
LOWEST ACHIEVING GROUP THAT DOES
NOT FALL INTO ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS BUT DOES FALL INTO THE
CATEGORY OF ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
I APPRECIATE ALL THAT BIG AGAIN
MY QUESTION WAS IS.
SO STUDENTS ENGLISH LEARNERS
PUPILS WITH DISABILITIES FOSTER
YOUTH AND HOMELESS YOU.
OKAY AND WE ALSO AS I SAID
SOMETIMES LOOK AT SUB GROUPS
BASED ON GENDER. MEN THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE ADDED ALSO SO
BOTH OF THE SUBGROUPS.
WELL THANK YOU I I HAVE A FEW A
QUESTIONS AS WELL AND AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE HERE BETWEEN POLICY AND
BUDGET AND SO IS THE BUDGET
THAT.
HAD ON AYE I THINK THIS IS A
WORTHY. UP PROPOSAL IT I THINK
AS YOU AS WAS ALLUDED TO DROP BY
YOU AND AND ART TO US SPEAKERS
THAT.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
.
WE WE MAY MISS WHEN ELSE IF THAT
WAS CREATED AND AND I THINK YOU
KNOW E NEED TO TAKE A LOOK BACK
AND SEE WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENING
OUT THERE SO I THINK. TO THE
EXTENT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING HERE IT'S THE
SOMETHING THAT I CERTAINLY. A
SUPPORT AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT THIS WHEN WHEN WE GO
AND FEEL THAT LOGISTICS A
LEGISLATION THAT AND THE OTHER
COMMITTEE OF COURSE BUT THAT'S
WHEN I BRING UP TO TWO ISSUES.
ONE AS FAR AS THE SUBGROUP. AND
I I THINK IF YOU IF YOU LOOK FOR
EXAMPLE AT THAT THAT.
THE HANDOUT I THINK THAT THE
LASSEN AND I'M.
THE LAST SPEAKER GIVE US WHEN WE
LOOK AT FOR EXAMPLE. THE THE
ASIAN SUBGROUPS SCORE VERY HIGH
BUT ASIAN A FEW DISAGGREGATED
ASIAN. LOT OF LOT LOT OF A.
VARIETY THERE AND SO I KNOW IN
MY FOR EXAMPLE.
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN SPECIMEN
FORMER CITY COUNCIL DISTRICT
THAT LARGE API POPULATION AND.
.
PRIMARILY SOUTHEAST ASIAN
VIETNAMESE MONG MANH LAOTIAN.
AND THAT THIS SUBGROUP VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THAT THAT ASIAN
SUB GROUP AS A WHOLE AND SO. HE
WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT
WE COULD THIS PROPOSAL LOOK AT.
THE SUBGROUP WITHIN THE
SUBGROUP ON US ON THE RIGHT
TERMINOLOGY THERE BUT BUT
POTENTIALLY DIS AGGREGATE SOME
OF THE AND THE ETHNIC CATEGORIES
IN IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I I
VENTURE TO SAY THAT MAYBE THERE
ARE SOME SCHOOLS THAT. THAT ARE
ARE VERY SIMILAR.
IN THAT. IT WAS YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT I WHEN I WAS
ON THE SCHOOL BOARD IN SAN DIEGO
THE WHICH HAS A LARGE API
COMMUNITY.
WE DID DISAGGREGATED DATA.
AND WE FOUND OF COURSE THAT ARE
AMONG.
AT THE HEAD LOW ACHIEVEMENT IN
SOME OF THE GROUPS THAT MAY BE
SMALL BUT THEY HAVE SPECIAL
NEEDS NOT YOU REMEMBER.
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS I THINK
THOUGH ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA HAS
BEEN TRYING TO DISAGGREGATED
DATA. TO THE OPPOSITION OF THE
API COMMUNITY THAT DID NOT WANT
THE DISAGGREGATED DATA. SOME OF
SOME OF THEM MAY BUT WAS REALLY
OF YOU KNOW AND I SPOKE IN FAVOR
OF IT BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE. THAT
ALL SOMETIMES GROUPS OF OF OF
OUR.
I CAN'T GUARDS CATEGORIZE VERY
LARGE AND AS A RESULT YOU MISS
SOME GROUPS OF OVERUSE AT ANNA
AND THIS WOULD NOT PREVENT THAT
FROM HAPPENING THIS WOULD NOT
PREVENT IT FROM. FROM BASICALLY
GETTING DOWN TO IF WE IF WE HAVE
DISCOVERED A GROUP THAT IS
REALLY PERSISTENTLY A LOW
ACHIEVING GROUP THAT WE HAVE
DIDN'T MEET BEEN THAT'S WHAT
ELSE HE UP UP WAS ABOUT TO GO
GET THOSE GROUPS BECAUSE.
CLEARLY ABA A WE WANT EVERY
STUDENT TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO LEARN AND IF THEY'RE IN A
SPECIALIZED VERY LOW SUB GROUP
THAT'S THERE THAT'S PERSISTENTLY
LOW WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHY WE
NEED TO PROVIDE THE RESOURCES TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN. WE'VE HAD THIS
CHALLENGE IN THIS CONVERSATION
AMONG WHAT WE CONSIDER AFRICAN
INDIGENOUS INDIVIDUALS AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS. AND
OFTENTIMES THE AFTER THAT
CATEGORY AFRICAN AMERICAN HIDES
A LOT OF FAILURE IN AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHO LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY VERSUS THOSE WHO COME
FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE.
AND IN SAN DIEGO WE HAVE A LARGE
OUT IMMIGRANT POPULATION OF
AFRICANS. AND WE HAD TO
DISAGGREGATED DATA IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
REALLY MEETING THE NEEDS OF ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS AND OFTENTIMES
THOSE STUDENTS WHO HAD BEEN
HERE.
ALL THEIR LIVES WHO BORNEO
AFRICAN AMERICANS WEIRD
ACHIEVING LOWER THAN STUDENTS
WHO HAD JUST ARRIVED HERE WHO
MAY HAVE BEEN GOT THE BENEFIT OF
HAVING SOME BILINGUAL EDUCATION
MONEY. AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
KINDS OF THINGS AND SO I I'VE
NEVER BEEN OPPOSED US
DISAGGREGATED DATA TO GET TO
WHERE. YOU'VE WE'VE DISCOVERED
THAT THERE IS A GROUP THAT'S
UNFAIRLY THAT WOULD NOT MEETING
THEIR NEEDS YES WE NEED TO DO
THAT WE NEED TO DECIDE WHAT THAT
THAT DATA. BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT IF WE GO DOWN THIS.
THIS PATH AND AND DO THAT'S
SOMETHING I WOULD LIKE TO STICK
CENTER IS IS TAKING A LOOK AT
HOW WE ADDRESS.
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE AND I JUST
WANT TO ASK FOR.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
OFFERED THE PART OF EDUCATION I
KNOW YOU YOU YOU YOU MAKE YOUR
STATEMENT EARLIER I DON'T
PRETEND TO PIN YOU DOWN THAT
BUT.
BUT IF THERE WAS A WILL FROM
THAT COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
.
TO DO THIS
DODD DO YOU THINK THAT IT'S ONE.
THAT IT'S UP THAT WE COULD THAT
THIS OR THAT WE COULD DO IT THAT
IS A PRACTICAL WAY TO DO IT AND
THAT THEY'RE WITH THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY WITHIN THE. LEGAL
STRUCTURE OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU
KNOW PEOPLE REYES PROP TWO
NIGTS A FOR THAT WHAT THE
PROPOSAL IS. WHAT WOULD THAT BE
LAWFUL?
I AM.
HONESTLY IT AT THIS POINT.
I I DON'T THINK THAT WE AS
FINANCE OF HAVE ENOUGH
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH.
DEPARTMENT AND TALK ABOUT THE
THAT PRACTICABILITY.
OF IT I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY
MULTIPLE WAYS THAT YOU CAN GO
ABOUT IT I MIGHT HAVE SEEN THE
BILL AS WRITTEN AND I THINK
THERE MAY BE SOME TECHNICAL
ISSUES THERE BUT AGAIN HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THAT
ANNOUNCES ENOUGH THE. DEPARTMENT
OF ED MAY BE ABLE TO A PINE WITH
SOME MORE DETAILS OKAY
DEPARTMENT OF THAT.
BUT YEAH I CAN TAKE IN A PINE
WAS SIMPLY HE TELLS BUT ABOUT IT
BUT I THINK WE AS WE'VE REVIEWED
IT WE DO HAVE SOME SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH THAT I
THINK IF THERE IS A WILL TO MOVE
FORWARD THEN WE WOULD BE HAPPY.
TO ENGAGE IN A CONVERSATION ON
HOW TO MAKE IT HOW TO HOW TO
MAKE IT WORK.
OKAY WELL I WOULD ASK YOU THE TO
TO WORK WITH OUR. OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE INTERESTED IN. PURSUING AS
WE GO FORTH THIS YEAR.
MR MARTZ WHICH IF I CAN ASK ONE.
LAST FOLLOW UP QUESTION SO.
IF THE DATA SHOW THAT.
THE MONK STUDENT POPULATION AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WAS THE LOWEST PERFORMING
SUBGROUP.
YOUR BILL WOULD APPLY IT WOULD
APPLY TO ANY THAT ANY ONE OF THE
LOWEST SUBGROUPS HISTORY.
YEAH IT IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T
THIS BILL BUSINESS CONCEPT
DOESN'T SAY AFRICAN AMERICANS IT
SAVES THE LOWEST. OF SUBGROUP
THAT SEVERE AND AN AT AND IF WE
ARE SUCCESSFUL. AND WE MOVE THAT
LAWYERS COME UP WHATEVER BECOMES
ADMITS LUIS GROUP MEETS THE
FOCUS AND ATTENTION YES.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN.
UP HOLES A NUMBER THREE IS THAT
PROPOSAL FOR ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT GRANTS.
ALAIA.
YEAH BRIAN ANDERSON WITH LA NO.
IT'S OF THIS PROPOSAL.
UNLIKE THE PREVIOUS TWO
PROPOSALS WHICH WERE
MODIFICATIONS TO THEIR LCF AFTER
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE.
PARALLEL TO THE L. CFF SOME ONE
TIME FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR
THOSE ACTIVITIES.
OF REGARDING COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
PLANNING FOR HOW SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION DOLLARS WOULD BE
SPENT.
THANK YOU.
JUST GO HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AGAIN WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT THIS
PROPOSAL IN SENIOR LANGUAGE
AROUND IT SO BE DIFFICULT FOR US
TO OPINE ON IT THIS TIME.
HOWEVER AND WE WOULD MENTION
THAT GENERALLY SPEAKING.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS
AND TO IMPROVE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT COMMUNICATION IS A
KEY PART OF LC FF.
HOWEVER WE'D LIKE TO SEE
IMPROVEMENT IN THOSE AREAS DONE
I THROUGH THE STATE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT AS OPPOSED TO A OF. THAT
ONE OFF PROGRAM THAT THAT'S NOT
INCORPORATE INTO THE SYSTEM.
OKAY THANK YOU.
PART OF EDUCATION DEBORAH BROWN
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TOXIN OR WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF OF THIS PROPOSAL I
THINK THAT AS WE LOOK AT. A
MULTIPLE MEASURES IS THURMOND
AND STRUGGLE COMMITTEE
ENGAGEMENT AND STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT WE DO SEE THIS IS AS
FUNDAMENTAL BUT TO THAT SYSTEM
SO WE ARE SUPPORTIVE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WELL I PUBLIC COMMENT NOW
THINKING PLEASE LINE UP IN THE.
IN THE MIDDLE.
I KNOW THIS WAS AN AYE IDEA THAT
WE HEARD FROM YOU. YEARS AGO
WELL.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT LEADERS AND
MILITARY LEADERS AND BUSINESS
LEADERS. THIS COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PROPOSAL PARTICULARLY
AROUND THE ISSUE OF SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS BEING DONE ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS. AND PARTICULARLY
FOR STUDENTS PARENTS AND
TEACHERS WE'VE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
AND THESE CLIMATE SURVEYS ARE
ACTUALLY  INCREDIBLY VALUABLE
TOOL AS WE LOOK AT.
THE EL CAP.
AND KNOWING WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS AND MOVING
THE NEEDLE AROUND SCHOOL CLIMATE
SO.
IT'S WONDERFUL TO PUT THE MONEY
THERE FOR ENGAGEMENT WE'D LOVE
TO SEE THAT ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE
WHICH IS THE SURVEY WHICH IS SO
ICH IN DATA AND IT HELPS TO SEE
RIGHT NOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN
SCHOOLS AND SO WE THINK THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT ELEMENT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO AGAIN FOR THOSE OF YOU
OUTSIDE WE ASK YOU TO KEEP IT TO
ONE MINUTE AND THEN FOCUS ON THE
OTHER THE PROPOSAL HERE AND AND
NOT NECESSARILY THE LEGISLATION
SO THAT'S THIS IS THE COMMITTEE
TALK ABOUT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHE A ROOM I
AM I REPRESENT PICO CALIFORNIA
OAKLAND OAKLAND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS I'M A MOTHER AND
SCHOOL SITE COUNCIL CHAIRPERSON%
FOR MY SON. LAST YEAR'S MIDDLE
SCHOOL OPEN SO MIDDLE SCHOOL I
AM IN MY SENSE FORMER ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL I THOUGHT TO MYSELF AND
OTHER FAMILIES.
WERE NOT SEEN OUR SERVED IN SO
WE CREATE A COALITION OF
STUDENTS PARENTS AND EDUCATORS.
THAT USE LCS F. FUNDS TO
IMPLEMENT SOME CHANGES THAT ARE
NOW THRIVING AT HIS FORMER
SCHOOL SO IN THAT WE FOUND POWER
IN A HIGH SENSE OF SAFETY AND
OUR COLLECTIVE VOICE. SARDI
RELATIONSHIPS WITH EACH OTHER
ALLOWED US TO CREATE OAKLAND SO
MIDDLE SCHOOL WHOSE CORE EMBODY
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
CULTURE HUMILITY AND IT BEST
SERVES ARE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS. SPECIAL STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS ARE NEWCOMERS
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND SO
DISTRICTS NEED FOR SUPPORT SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO CREATE
ENVIRONMENTS AND PROVIDE TOOLS.
FOR STUDENT PARENT EDUCATOR
COLLABORATION SO WE SUPPORT THE
CHAIRS LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
OF INVESTING MEANINGFUL
INVESTING IN OUR MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'M I'M TO
CARNEGIE ARM ALUMNUS FROM FROZEN
UNIFIES EDISON HIGH SCHOOL.
AND I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE OC OF OF DIFFERENT IN MEN
COALITION. AND CALIFORNIA'S FOR
JUSTICE WHO IS ALSO HERE SOON
ENOUGH SUPPORT.
IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE TO PAR
TIES AND STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
WHICH WE ALL KNOW.
.
IT'S GOING CLIMATE THE SAME WHEN
WE INVEST LIKE OTHER STATE
PRIORITIES.
AND LIKE IF WE WANT TO SEE
IMPROVEMENTS IN EQUITY YOU FOR
LIKE STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THE STUDENT LIKE BONE
PENICILLIN GROUPS LIFTED UP BY
ELSIE FF THIS EXPRESSION WE
THINK IT'S CRITICAL.
SO AYE FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS A STUDENT LEADER
IN FRESNO MA I'M INITIAL
CHALLENGE WOULD ENGAGING WITH
THE OCF IF IT WAS LIKE THE
LANGUAGE IN THE TECHNICALITIES
THAT IT HAD.
BECAUSE LIKE NONE OF IT REALLY
MASON SUFFERS FROM A STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE IT WAS AND IT WASN'T
A FAMILY AFFAIR SPAN.
WE HAVE TO GO TO LIKE OTHERS
LIKE. YOU ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
CALIFORNIANS FOR JUSTICE.
PHONE IN FRESNO UNIFIED.
.
ABBAS IS ELECTED COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN LIKE THE DISTRICTS IN
THE SCHOOLS AND PARENTS.
AND HOW THE DISTRICT.
TRIES TO INFO CEREALS FOR OTHER.
COACHES AND.
LIKE MONNING AND
SPANISH WEREN'T REALLY
TRANSLATED CORRECTLY YOUR
WEREN'T UNDERSTANDABLE BY THE
PARENTS.
SO IN ALL THAT TO SAY THAT WE
HEARD YOU SOME PART OR ITS ARTS
FUNDING AND THE OCF OF SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT BUDGET. TO BUILD
CAPACITY
FOR DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE MEANINGFUL STUDENT AND
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT AND POSITIVE
SCHOOL CLIMATE THANK YOU.
HOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CANDICE BINGE AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF PARTNERS FOR EACH AND
EVERY CHILD A PROJECT OF THE
OPPORTUNITY INSTITUTE? I'D LIKE
TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSED ONE TIME
FUNDING TO INCREASE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF STRENGTHENING
STRENGTHENING A MEANINGFUL
APPROACH TO ENGAGEMENT. BUT A
CENTRAL TO CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS
THIS REQUIRES COUNTY'S DISTRICTS
AND SCHOOLS TO CONSIDER FIVE
PILLARS OF ENGAGEMENT.
REPRESENTATION TRANSPARENCY
SUSTAINABILITY COLLABORATION AND
ALIGNMENT.
THESE ARE FURTHER DISCUSSED IN
OUR MATERIALS WHICH I WILL SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE
ELECTRONICALLY WITHOUT ADHERENCE
TO THESE FIVE PILLARS THE
PROCESS ITSELF CAN HINDER
DECISION MAKING AND ULTIMATELY.
OBSTRUCTED COMMUNITIES POTENTIAL
TO PROTECT VALUABLE AND
EFFECTIVE RESOURCES SERVING
ESPECIALLY ITS MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS.
IT IS FROM THIS UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE APPRECIATE THE TRULY
GROUNDBREAKING PROMISE
ESPECIALLY FOR ISSUES OF EQUITY
THAT THE L. CUT PROCESS CAN
PROVIDE A COMMUNITY. THE
COMMITTEES RECOGNITION OF THE
VALUE AND COST OF MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT WORK AS EXHIBITED BY
THIS PROPOSAL.
BY THIS PROPOSAL IS COMMENDABLE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SHARON MEMBERS PROUD STRONG WITH
CHILDREN NOW WE SUPPORT A
REQUEST FOR THE FUN AND FOR THAT
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT GRANTS. AND THE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS.
.
THE.
AT SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO THE EL CAP AND
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT PROCESS.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SENATOR
LIEU PASSED A C. R. EIGHTEEN
WHICH RESULT BY THE SENATE OF
THE COLOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE ASSEMBLY THERE
OF CONCURRING THAT IT IS THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
PURSUE EVERY MEANS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT. THE.
CAL SKILLS WHICH IS THAT HELP
HEALTHY KIDS SURVEY I'M REMAINS
VIABLE WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND FOR
SUPPORT DISTRICTS AND ASSESSING
THEIR NEEDS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ZIAD
I'M ALSO A PARENTS I'M FROM
MERCED BY WHAT YOU'RE
SACRAMENTO.
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS ONLY A
HUGE ADVOCATE FOR EDUCATION I'M
A REFUGEE FROM LAOS AGAIN THE
PREVIOUS SESSION TO TALK ABOUT.
LOWERS PERFORMANCE I AM THE.
PERSON.
AND OF ASSOCIATION ALSO LEFT ON
THE PIE FOR EVERYTHING. AND JUST
ONE LIFT UP THAT I WORK WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT CROSSES A CENTRAL
VALLEY. A TO MAKE SURE THE HOUSE
EFFECT IS THAT IT IS OPPORTUNE
FOR ASSOCIATION KIDS. AS WELL AS
OTHER KIDS AND I SUPPORT OF
THESE.
MORE FUNDING FOR SCHOOL CLIMATE.
TYPICALLY WOULD COMMUTING GATES
WHEN IF YOU LOOK AT SOME STAGE
OF YOUR TALK ABOUT OF CFF AL
CAPP NO BODY HAVE ANY CLUE ABOUT
IT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME OUR KIDS
ARE STRUGGLING IN SCHOOL. AND I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
SCHOOL DOES TERRIBLE JOB IS TO
HAVE BETTER COMMUNICATION WITH
PARENTS PARTICULARLY MONO LEGAL
PARENTS.
AND I KNOW THAT MY CITY IS
STRUGGLING IS TO REACH OUT TO
THE ASIAN COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY
MOMENT ALLOW COMMUNITY SO IN
SACRAMENTO HAVE LARGER
POPULATION AND THEY'RE ALSO
STRUGGLE THE SAME THING. SO FROM
THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE WANT TO
TO DO OF YOUR BEST TO REALLY
REINFORCE AND LOCAL DISTRICTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DO THEIR
THEIR JOB RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
I GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
PATRICK MORE TEAR WITH COUNSEL
FOR A STRONG AMERICA. AND WE
SUPPORT.
THE PROPOSAL FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT BLOCK GRANTS.
WE FIND THAT POSITIVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE IS CRITICAL TO THE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
AND DESPITE ONLY ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT OF DISTRICTS WERE
DESPITE THAT TWENTY PERCENT
DISTRICTS.
ARE DOING ANNUAL STUDENT
CLEMENTS SERVICE NOW. DESPITE
THE EXPECTATION OF ANNUAL
STUDENT SURVEYS NAILS IF OF
STATUTE.
FOR SEVEN HUNDRED PLUS
DISTRICTS.
WE FIND THAT LESS THAN A QUARTER
OF THE FIFTY LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHOSE ALL CAPS
REVIEWED ARE DOING SURVEYS OF
ALL THREE GROUPS STUDENTS
PARENTS AND STAFF. AND SO.
INTERN WE SUPPORT
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING WHISKEY AND WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES UMP THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY FOR.
LEADING ON THIS.
WE BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT THE.
ASSESSMENT OF SCHOOL CLIMATE.
.
FOR ALL STAKEHOLDERS STUDENTS
PARENTS TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS
AND STAFF IS KEY TO
UNDERSTANDING. AND THE ABILITY
THE CAPACITY FOR ENGAGEMENT
WHICH WE THINK IS THE
UNDERPINNING OF LOCAL CONTROL
LCF HALF.
WE ARE MODELING WHAT WE MEAN BY
INCLUSIVE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS BILL.
THIS LEGISLATION EXCUSE ME THIS
PROPOSAL AND.
.
WE WANT TO INCLUDE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS OUT IN THAT
CONVERSATION WHILE WE AGREE THAT
THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT IS THE
PERFECT OPPORTUNITY TO BE
LOOKING AT EXPANDING THIS
CAPACITY.
WE ALSO THINK THAT.
ELEAZAR COUNTIES ALL THE STAKE
HOLDERS THAT ARE WORKING ON THIS
THAT HAVE THIS OBLIGATION NOW
NEED TO BE SUPPORTED NOW THANK
YOU FOR THE INVESTMENT THANK
YOU.
HELLO I'M.
MIAMI SLIGHTLY BEST.
I LIVE IN THE COUNTY OVER SAN.
AND I HAVE TICKETS AND
LIVINGSTON HIGH SCHOOL. AND I'M
SO WORRIED ABOUT.
MY KIDS THE CURRENT ONE OF THEN
THERE HE'S SO BEHIND OF SCHOOL
AND I SUPPORT THAT CLAIM MEET
SCHOOL. BECAUSE ON.
I DON'T WANT TO HAPPEN TO THE
OTHER KIDS LIKE HAPPENED TO ME
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL I
DIDN'T GET A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR
THAT THE SCHOOL. SO I DIDN'T
FINISH MY IN HIGH SCHOOL SO I
HOPE MY IS MY SON HE'S AND NINTH
GRADE I HOPE YOU FINISH THE
SCHOOL AND.
THE.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US
INTO YOUR SPACE MY NAME IS
AUTUMN MARTINEZ I MUST TELL FOR
YOUTH CONNECTION.
I WORK FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OFFICE AND SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE
WE CONSISTS OF CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND I WORK
WITH YOUNG. STUDENTS IN THE
SCHOOLS ARE CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOU TO IDENTIFY THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED AND
REGARDS THE LC FF AND.
THE BUDGET AND IT'S SUCH A
POWERFUL MOVEMENT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND COLLABORATING WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH OF ME AND THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH TO SUPPORT ON ON
HAND SUPPORT THAT. REALLY AND
POWER THE YOU TO IDENTIFY WHAT
KIND OF SUPPORT IT IS THAT THEY
NEED ON SO THEY CAN ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES SO THIS PROPOSAL WE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORTER AND.
.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER BAKER CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS CENTER
CITY COUNCIL MEETING. THOUGHT
THIS PAST WEEKEND WE BROUGH
PRESHEAF THIS CONVERSATION
MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
YES MISTER JARVIS.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD AS YOU KNOW I HAVE A.
AN ISSUE LIKE THIS ALREADY
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT TALK
ABOUT PARENTAL AND FAMILY
INVOLVEMENT.
BUT THERE'S THIS IS A BUDGET
MEETINGS OF WHAT YOUR INTENTION
HOW MUCH ARE YOU LOOKING FOR.
DEPENDS ON HOW MUCH WE HAVE. OUT
AS FAR AS THE BALANCER AFTER THE
MAY REVISE WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
THAT SOME MONEY AT ONE TIME
SOMEONE GOING.
VIA AT THAT THE IDEA HERE IS
POTENTIALLY DO THAT ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OVER THREE YEARS THAT
WE GET HAVE.
DEPARTMENT OF OF THAT. DUE ON TO
TO TO GRANTS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO HELP AUGMENT ANDSTRENGTHEN
THEIR COMMUTING GAUGE MEANT IF
THEY ARE EXISTING IF THEY'RE NOT
TO EXISTENT TO TO REALLY. YOU
KNOW MAKE IT A REALITY.
SO WE'RE WE'RE OPEN TO THAT AND
I KNOW THEY ADVOCATES WOULD
LIKE.
.
ONE TIME BUT.
THINK WE HAVE YOU KNOW I'M
SORRY ANOTHER ADVOCATES WOULD
LIKE ONGOING.
BUT I KNOW WE HAVE ONGOING
NEEDS WITH. HEALTHY FF AND TT
ANY CA AND SO I I THINK IT IN
THIS IN THIS AYE REALM AYE THINK
THE AT THE APPROPRIATE SEPARATE
POLLS WILL BE FOREST'S IS
LOOKING AT. A ONE TIME.
APPROPRIATION OKAY GRIP AND
APARTMENT VAN HOW WHAT DO YOU
THINK AND IF WE WERE TO.
FUND THIS HOW MUCH WOULD IT TAKE
AS FAR AS A GRANT OR A ONE TIME
FUNDING.
HAVE YOU GUYS HAD A CHANCE LOOK
AT IT FOR HOW YOU DO IT. I THINK
I WOULD JUST ECHO WHAT MR
MCCARTY SAID AROUND TAKING A
LOOK AT WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE OBVIOUSLY THIS THIS
APPROACH COULD BE SCALABLE BASED
ON HOW MUCH RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE AND AS WE THINK ABOUT
IT. WILL LOOK AT IS TWO FOLD
WHICH IS THAT THE IDEALLY I'M
GOING TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
INTEREST IN ONE TIME GRANTS BUT
ALSO WHAT WE'RE ALSO LOOKING FOR
IS THE FUNDING FOR THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS SO WE THINK THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE TO
THAT. SO THAT WOULD BE FUNDING
FOR ANNUAL SURVEYS FOUR I'M.
FOOT FOR DISTRICTS TO
ADMINISTER THE SURVEY SO WE WE
WOULD TRY TO TRY TO AT LEAST
HAVE THAT AS PART OF AN ONGOING
AND THEN LOOKING AT THAT THE ONE
DEMOCRATS I KNOW THAT DOESN'T
ANSWER THE QUESTION BUT I THINK.
WE COULD LOOK AT THIS APPROACH
IS IS BEING YOU KNOW AS LITTLE
AS AVAILABLE IN AS MUCH AS AS IS
AVAILABLE.
WELL I THINK WHEN WE LAST WEEK
WE HAD OF FOR. ONE OF OUR BUDGET
MEANS WE'RE LOOKING AT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AT RISK IN THEIR SAN.
WHEN TO TAKE WAYS I TOOK WAS
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT.
DEVELOP WELL ON THEIR OWN CAP
GENERALLY DON'T HAVE
FUNDING ISSUES ABLE TO GO
FORWARD.
AND I THINK.
DE.
MY OWN LOOKING AMOUNT DISTRICTS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SAID AND
ENGAGE.
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES AND HAD
A VERY ROBUST OUT OF REACH.
BEEN HAVE IS THE PROBLEM THAT
SOME OF THE DIDN'T
AND SO I TH.
I KNOW THE SEAT SHE HAD THE A
PTA IS BIG ON THIS ISSUE AS FAR.
FAMILY INVOLVEMENT JUST.
BUT EXPAND THE NET.
BECAUSE I THINK.
IN EDUCATE MORE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION WITHIN
SOCIETY.
IT ONLY BE BETTER SERVED WHEN
MORE PEOPLE INVOLVED TO TAKE
OWNERSHIP TO EDUCATION.
AND SO I THINK THE EXPANSION.
OF THE.
NOT JUST PARENTAL INVOLVEMENT
BUT DHEA FAMILY INVOLVEMENT
COMMITTEE INVOLVEMENT WOULD BE
OF GREAT VALUE. SO I'M.
INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE TO LOOK
FORGET COME FORWARD IN.
.
PORTIS
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU WE WILL.
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN.
AS AS WELL.
I'M GOING TO ASK MR CHAVEZ TO UP
TO TO TAKE OUR FREE ISSUE THREE
THAT'S ATTACKED AFTER GO TO
ANOTHER.
COMMITTEE AND PRESENT.
A BILL
.
IF YOU.
ISSUE THREE WILL BE TO SAY THAT
CALPERS SYSTEM OUR FIRST
PRESIDENT. MISERABLY JUST FOR
HOME FOR AMBER ALEXANDER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
.
KICK IT OFF.
JUST GO HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE ADMINISTRATION
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE STATE
HEALTH PFF ACCOUNTABILITY IN
IMPROVEMENTS SYSTEM. THE SYSTEM
REPLACES THE STATE'S OLD TOP
DOWN AND COORDINATED APPROACH TO
SCHOOL IMPROVEMENT BUT THE
STRUCTURE THAT ENGAGES ALL LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE. EDUCATIONAL
ENTITIES AS WELL AS THEIR
STAKEHOLDERS IN UNPRECEDENTED
NETWORK OF COLLABORATION AND
INNOVATION IN INFORMATION
SHARING. TO IMPROVE ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES FOR ALL STUDENTS
INCREASE OF FOCUSED AROUND
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT AS
OPPOSED TO STATIC GOALS.
AS HELIO MENTIONED ARE ACTUALLY
ANSWER THE OTHER HASN'T SPOKEN
YET AS THE LA. ACT.
WILL MENTION OF THE SYSTEM WAS
CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND WE SEE GREAT PROMISE IN THE
WORK CURRENTLY BEING DONE BY
COMMUNITY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THE CALIFORNIA CLUB REFER
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE AND
ADVOCACY GROUPS AND ADJUSTING
DIVA PERSISTENT OBSTACLES TO
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
I KNOW THAT.
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THAT LEO
SPOKE ABOUT THE PERSISTENT
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND THAT WAS
SPECIFIC TO TEST SCORES HOWEVER
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO.
DESCRIBES SOME OF THE IMPROVING
THAT WE'VE ALREADY SEEN AS A
RESULT OF LCF FIVE.
AND THERE IS WE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THEIR SUMMER MUCH WORK TO
DO SPECIFICS ARE* HOURS
HOWEVER I'M EARLY DATA SUGGESTS
THAT THE MOVE TO LOCAL CONTROL
HAS CONTRIBUTED TO IMPROVEMENTS
STUDENT OUTCOMES. INCLUDING IN
GRADUATION RATES WOULD HAVE
INCREASED INCLUDING FOR.
VARIOUS SUBGROUPS.
ARE SPECIALLY FOR.
SOME GROUPS HAVE HAD
HISTORICALLY NOT HAD HIGH
GRADUATION RATES.
SUSPENSION RATES HAVE DECLINED
AND SIGNIFICANT MORE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES ARE
ELIGIBLE TO ATTEND UC AND CSU
AND THIS IS IN THAT IN EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE OR HAVING.
EXPERIENCING AND.
LOWERING AT ACE WE HAVE MORE
STUDENTS PREPARED EVEN WITH LAST
ATA SO IT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DEDICATED TO BUILDING OUT OUR
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT TO REFLECT THE
NEEDS AND THE EFFORT TO NEEDS OF
OUR EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS SO THAT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROVIDES SEVENTY POINT FIVE
MILLION AN ON GOING PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND. SUPPORT
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION IN
THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE IN
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT TO ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ESPECIALLY THOSE
IDENTIFIED BY MULTIPLE MEASURES
OF STUDENT PERFORMANCE AS BEING
IN NEED OF TARGETED ASSISTANCE
WHAT WE CALL DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE.
ADDITIONALLY THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO ENHANCE
THE USER FRIENDLINESS OF THE K.
TWELVE DASH BOARD OF STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
CODIFIES WORK DONE IMPLEMENT THE
STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS AND CLARIFIES
THE RULES OF DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. THE
COLLABORATIVE AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WITHIN
THE STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
SPECIFICALLY TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CODIFIES THE CASE
STATES KEY TWELVE DASH BOARD OF
STUDENT DATA IDENTIFIES COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION IS THE
PRIMARY SUPPORT PROVIDER FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IDENTIFIED AS BEING IN NEED A
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE TO
ACCEPT ASSISTANCE WITHIN THE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
CREATIVELY COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO HELP BUILD STATE
RIGHT CAPACITY RUN CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT. A DESCRIBES
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
COLLABORATIVE IN THE DEPARTMENT
TO WORK TO BUILD THIS CAPACITY
AS WELL.
PROVIDES AVENUES FOR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THE
COLLABORATIVE AND THE DEPARTMENT
TO ASSIST SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
NEED OF EXTRAORDINARY SUPPORT.
AND MAKES TECHNICAL MOMENTS TO
REMOVE THE OLD ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE INDEX ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM FROM STATE LAW.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW WILL
GO TO THE ALEJO AYE SARAH CORD
JAZZ.
RIGHT.
I APOLOGIZE MY COLLEAGUE AND
ALSO AND ONCE WE GOT BETTER
POCKET. I.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK RESEARCHER.
EVER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FOLLOWING UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
PRESENTATION I'M GOING TO FOCUS
MY REMARKS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL RELATED TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN AREAS ARE
SELFLESS.
IN THE SPIRIT OF CORONATION
ACROSS THE STATE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES TEN MILLION AN
ON GOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. TO INCORPORATE
SELF US INTO THE STATE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF SIX TO TEN SAU
BELIEVES WHO WORK WITH COUNTY
OFFICES O IMPROVE PEOPLE
OUTCOMES.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RECOGNIZES THAT SUPPERS HAVE
EXPERTISE IN THE DELIVERY AND
MANAGEMENT OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES BUT COULD FURTHER
ENHANCE THE SUPPORT PROVIDED BY
COUNTY OFFICES.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES
THAT BRINGS UP AS INTO THE STATE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT IS CRITICAL
GIVEN THAT NEARLY THREE QUARTERS
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED
FOR DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
NEED TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES SEVERAL CHANGES THROUGH
TRAILER BILL THAT ARE INTENDED
TO PROVIDE GREATER COORDINATION
BETWEEN SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES AND GENERAL EDUCATION
PLANNING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SPECIFICALLY NEW REQUIREMENTS
ARE ADDED FOR COUNTY AND
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS TO
CONSULT WITH THEIR SELF BUT TO
DETERMINE THAT ACTIONS EARNED
SERVICES INCLUDED WITHIN THEIR
ACCOUNT. ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THEIR STRATEGIES IN THE SOUTH A
LOCAL PLAN FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS.
IN ADDITION IN AN EFFORT TO TO.
FURTHER INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
AROUND THE SUPPLE PLAN THE
BUDGET PLAN AND THE SERVICES
PLAN. THE GOVERNOR DIRECTS THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP PLAN TEMPLATES AND TO
ALSO DEVELOP A SUMMARY DOCUMENT
THAT LINKS THE BUDGET PLAN TO
THE SERVICES AND ACTIVITIES AND
THE SUB CLAN.
BEGINNING ON JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ALSO REQUIRES THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION VOCAL PLANS BE UPDATED
EVERY THREE YEARS AND LINE WITH
A THREE YEAR OLD HAVE PLANNING
CYCLE.
AND FINALLY THE GOVERNOR
REQUIRES THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
POST THE LOCAL PLAN BUDGET PLAN
AND SERVICES PLAN ON THEIR
WEBSITE. AND ALSO THAT A
COMPLETE COPY OF THE PLAN HE
HELD ON FILE IN THE SOUTH OFFICE
IN IT THE PARTICIPATING ELEAZAR.
WE NEED TO BETTER INTEGRATE
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND GENERAL
EDUCATION IS A THEME THAT HAS
BEEN HIGHLIGHTED TIME AND TIME
AGAIN. MOST RECENTLY WITH HURT
REPORTS BY BOTH THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THE STATE WHITE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TASK FORCE.
BOTH CALLING FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A UNIFIED
SYSTEM WITH GENERAL AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS PART OF A SEAMLESS
SUPPORT SYSTEM.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS ARE ALL
FOCUSED AROUND THE GOAL OF
PROVIDING MORE LOCAL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ROUTE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PLANNING.
AND FURTHERING THESE EFFORTS TO
INTEGRATE SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
GENERAL EDUCATION INTO ONE
COHESIVE SYSTEM. AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW WITHOUT ANY
FURTHER YOUR LITTLE DRUM ROLL
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM SARAH
ORGASM IN THE LA SHOW AND GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE CENTER COURT
HAS OF THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ALL BE SPEAKING FROM THE
HANDOUT THAT THE SERGEANT JUST
DISTRIBUTED. SORE* TODAY TO
DISCUSS OUR ASSESSMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
SO PAGE ONE INTO OF THE HANDOUT
PROVIDES AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL A WE SEE THE
GOVERNOR STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT IS HAVING FOR COMPONENT
SO THE FIRST PROPOSAL IS
PROVIDING FIFTY FIVE MILLION FOR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
SUPPORT IDENTIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
THE SECOND WOULD BE PROVIDING
FOUR MILLION TO ESTABLISH THE
REGIONAL READABLE REGIONALLY TO
ROLL WERE SIX TO TEN COUNTIES
WOULD. BE SELECTED AS A
REGIONALLY TO ASSIST COUNTY
OFFICES TO PROVIDE BETTER
SUPPORT TO DISTRICTS.
AND ON PAGE TWO WE DESCRIBE THE
THIRD PROPOSAL WHICH IS
ESTABLISHING THE CELL PAROLE ON
THIS COMPONENT PROVIDES TEN
MILLION TO SELF ESTEEM FUNDS TO
HELP COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPPORT DISTRICT. AND THE FOURTH
PROVIDES ELEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION TO THE COLLABORATIVE TO
SUPPORT COUNTY OFFICES AND
DISTRICTS.
ON PAGE THREE AND FOUR OF THE
HAND UP PROVIDER ASSESSMENTS.
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE SYSTEM
MINIMIZES DISTRICT CHOICE
INSTEAD OF CAPTURING THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF LOCAL
CONTROL UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DISTRICTS MUST RECEIVE
SUPPORT FROM THEIR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION UNLESS THEY
USE FUNDING TO PURCHASE. TO
PURCHASE ALTERNATIVE SUPPORT OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THE LACK OF
CHOICE COULD REDUCE THE QUALITY
AND THE TIMELINESS.
OF SUPPORT THAT A DISTRICT
COULD SEE COULD RECEIVE SO WE
COULD SEE THIS PLAYING OUT IN A
FEW WAYS BUT ONE EXAMPLE IS THAT
I COUNTY OFFICE COULD LACK OF.
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT THE
IDENTIFIED DISTRICT AND IT WOULD
TAKE TIME TO BUILD THAT CAPACITY
WHILE THE COUNTY OFFICES
BUILDING THE CAPACITY.
THE.
IF THE COUNTY OFFICE ISN'T
PROVIDING THE DISTRICT AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF SUPPORT THE
STATE COULD OFFER.
AND IF THE STATE FINDS A COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IS NOT
PROVIDING DISTRICTS WITH QUALITY
OF SUPPORT THE BULK OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS NOT ON COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION BUT IT'S ON
DISTRICTS BECAUSE THE DISTRICT
WOULDN'T WOULD REMAIN
IDENTIFIED.
SO WE DO THINK COUNTY OFFICES
OUR POSITION TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR THE STATE TO LEVERAGE THEIR
EXPERTISE IN REVIEWING BUDGET
AND EL COPS ON THE COUNTY
OFFICES ARE WELL FUNDED TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT WHAT WE S.
R. OFFICE ESTIMATES THE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION FIVE. AND
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING THAT THEY
COULD USE A SUPPORT DISTRICTS.
A WE CONTINUE OUR ASSESSMENTON
PAGE FOUR.
BUT WITH REGARDS TO THE
REGIONALLY PROPOSAL OUR CONCERN
IS THAT BOTH SILVA AND COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION REGIONAL
LEAD A ROLES APPEAR DUPLICATIVE
TO BOTH. THE NEWLY ESTABLISHED
ROLE ON IN THE WITHIN THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM AN ALREADY
EXISTING ROLE THE FOR EXAMPLE
ELEVEN COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION ALREADY RECEIVE
FUNDING TO SERVE AS REGIONAL
NEEDS.
THERE'S ALSO A LACK OF CLARITY
SURROUNDING THE REGIONAL NEEDS
TO FOR EXAMPLE COUNTY REGIONALES
ARE INTENDED TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY OF COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. PART OF THE RULES
ALSO TO POST ALSO TO SUPPORT
DISTRICTS DIRECTLY AND IT'S
UNCLEAR AT WHAT POINT A REGIONAL
LEGAL SUPPORT DISTRICTS AND HOW
DECISIONS TO SUPPORT THE
DISTRICT WILL BE MADE.
THE LACK OF CLARITY ALSO RAISES
CONCERNS FOR THE SELF BELIEVES.
DESPITE THE PROPOSAL INTENDING
TO ADD SELFLESS TO THE
CONVERSATION OF IMPROVING
DISTRICTS THE LACK OF CLARITY
SURROUNDING THE ROLE COULD
RESULT IN COUNTIES DEFERRING
DISTRICT SUPPORT TO CELL PHONES.
DISCONNECTING SPECIAL EDUCATION
PERFORMANCE ISSUES FROM OTHER
SHOULD OF PERFORMANCE ISSUES.
ON ANOTHER NOTE SELF AS OUR
EXPERTS AT PROVIDING SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES BUT THE
ISSUES THE DASHBOARD HIGHLIGHTS
OUR GENERAL EDUCATION ISSUES
SUCH AS TEST SCORES AND
SUSPENSION RATES. WE WOULD
CONSIDER THE PERFORMANCE ISSUES
AT THE DASHBOARD HIGHLIGHTS A
GENERAL EDUCATION ISSUES THAT
ARE DICTATED BY THE SAME
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT
APPLY TO ALL STUDENT
POPULATIONS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE WITH STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IS LARGELY
DETERMINED BY GENERAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS WHO HAVE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IN THE CLASSROOM.
ALL THIS IS A IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT
TO US WHY WE WOULD HAVE A
SEPARATE ENTITY INTERVENING FOR
ISSUE SPECIFIC TO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES OTHER RELY ON A
DIFFERENT SOURCE OF EXPERTISE
FOR THOSE. SAME ISSUES WHEN THEY
OCCUR WITH OTHER STUDENT
POPULATIONS.
ON PAGE FIVE AND SIX WE DISCUSS
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO.
AS I SAID BEFORE COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION ARE WELL POSITIONED
TO ASSISTANCE TRICKS AND WE
THINK COUNTIES COULD CONDUCT A
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS OF
IDENTIFYING DISTRICTS.
THIS IS WHERE COUNTIES WOULD
WORK WITH DISTRICTS AND UNCOVER
THE ROOT CAUSES FOR FOR THEIR
PERFORMANCE ISSUES. WHICH WOULD
M. ACTUALLY BE SIMILAR TO WHAT
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY
UNDERTAKING SO COUNTIES COULD IN
FACT SUPPORT DISTRICT BEYOND A
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS AND HELP
DISTRICTS. IMPROVING HELP
DISTRICT IMPLEMENTS SOLUTIONS
HOWEVER COUNTY OFFICES HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
DISTRICT AND WE RECOMMEND
AUGMENTING THEIR FUNDING FOR
THIS PURPOSE.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND REJECTING BOTH
THE REGIONALLY PROPOSALS BECAUSE
CREATING THESE THESE ROLES LEAD
TO UNNECESSARY DUPLICATION.
AHMED ALSO THE SELF RULE COULD
SILO SUPPORT INSTEAD OF
FOSTERING CONVERSATIONS IS
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS.
ON PAGE SIX WE DISCUSS OUR
ALTERNATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. AND WE SEEING
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF LCF OFF
WITHOUT CREATING ADDITIONAL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
WE RECOMMEND USING THE
COOPERATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE WHICH IS THE NEW
ENTITY THAT WAS FORMED GENERALLY
TO ASSIST DISTRICTS.
AS AN ENTITY THAT OPERATES
SIMILAR TO FIX MATCHES THE
STATE'S FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
ENTITY. AND WE RECOGNIZE THIS
WOULD BE A CHANGE FROM BOTH
CURRENT LAW AND WHAT THE STATE
AND WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES.
SO FOR FIGURE OUT ONCE A
DISTRICT HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT
THEY NEED FISCAL ASSESSMENT OF
FISCAL ASSISTANCE FIGMENT
DEVELOPS A TEAM THAT CAN SUPPORT
DISTRICTS.
IN VERY SPECIFIC AREAS SO WE
THINK WE CAN BUILD OFF THE
SUCCESS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN FACT
MATT SUPPORTING DISTRICTS AND
MODEL THE COLLABORATIVE TO
OPERATE SIMILARLY.
SO THE FIRST STEP OF OUR
ALTERNATIVE IS THAT ANA IDENTIFY
DISTRICT WOULD WORK WITH
COUNTIES TO UNCOVER THE ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS OF THEIR
PERFORMANCE ISSUES AS DISCUSSED
EARLIER. SO ONCE THE COUNTY
COMPLETED THE ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS ADDITION WITH AND WORK
WITH THE COLLABORATIVE TO
IDENTIFY AN EXPERT OR TEAM OF
EXPERTS THAT THE DISTRICT COULD
WORK WITH THAT IT WOULD ADDRESS
THE ROOT PERFORMANCE ISSUES.
THE EXPERTS COULD BE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION DISTRICTS
OTHER PROVIDERS OF EDUCATION
EDUCATION CONSULTANTS THE IDEA
IS THAT THE COLLABORATIVE WOULD
HAVE EXPERTS UNDER CONTRACT SO
THAT WHEN YOU DID EXPERTS WILL
BE AVAILABLE FOR THE DISTRICT
THAT NEED SUPPORT.
THE RECOMMENDED SYSTEM WOULD
PROVIDE DISTRICTS WITH GREATER
CHOICE IN SELECTING EXPERTS DOES
NOT REQUIRE DISTRICTS COULD WORK
WITH THE COLLABORATIVE TO CHOOSE
CONTRACTED EXPERTS ARE BEST
SUITED TO HELP ADDRESS THE KEY
PERFORMANCE ISSUES.
AND DISTRICTS I'M ALREADY HAVE A
STRONG INCENTIVE TO CHIU SUPPORT
PROVIDERS WIRELESS WISELY I'M
UNDER STATE LAW THE ULTIMATE
ACCOUNTABILITY RESIDES WITH
DISTRICTS BECAUSE THEY'VE REAP
FACE REPERCUSSIONS IF.
THE FAILED TO IMPROVE ABOVE
DISTRICTS FAIL TO IMPROVE THE
GET INTO INTENSIVE INTERVENTION
AFTER SEVERAL YEARS OF POOR
DISTRICT PERFORMANCE WHERE THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION PARA CHOIR. BUDGET
REVISION THAT AL CAPP PROVISIONS
AS WELL AS STAY IN RESCIND
ABOARD DECISIONS.
SO WITH ALL THAT SAID WE PREVENT
THIS OPTION TO DISPLAY BUT
THERE'S MORE THAN ONE MODEL FOR
THROUGH THE LEGSLATURE TO
CONSIDER TO ACHIEVE THE DESIRED
OUTCOME OF SUPPORTING DISTRICTS.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
BUT HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
WOW WE GOT A CONFLICT THAT'S
COOL.
LET US NOW WELL HERE FOR THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION DAVID
SAP AND YOU'RE GONNA.
CLARIFY THE. THE CONFLICT HERE
RIGHT.
BUT I'LL BE THE TIEBREAKER
GASOLINE MORNING DAVID SAT STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND I LIKE TO
ADDRESS THREE POINTS ON FIRST.
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS BEEN PRETTY
CONSISTENT ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF.
KNOWING WHAT TO EXPECT OVER
TIME CONTINUITY. I LARGELY AGREE
WITH THE STAFF ANALYSIS IN THIS
HOMES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL REFLECTS THE WORK OF
THE STATE BOARD HAS DONE. TO
IMPLEMENT ALL CFF
BUT WE ARE RELIANT TO SOME
EXTENT ON RELATIONSHIPS NORMS
AND THEY INSERTED BASIC
OPERATING PRINT PRINCIPLES. THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED JOINTLY WITH THE
AGENCIES AND STAKEHOLDERS IN
IMPLEMENTING LCF OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES IMPORTANT
CLARITY AROUND ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THEN EXPECTATIONS THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL PROVIDE THAT
CONTINUITY FOR EDUCATORS AND
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH FURTHER IMPLEMENTATION OF
LCF OUT. IN A WAY THAT IS QUITE
DIFFERENT FROM OUR PAST SCHOOL
IMPROVEMENT AFTER.
AND THAT'S MY SECOND POINT WHICH
IS WHY WE SHOULD WANT TO ENSURE
CONTINUITY.
A COMMON FEATURE OF OUR PAST
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SCHOOL
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS WHETHER
STATE OR FEDERAL A LAW DROVE
THEM WITH IF THEY WERE COMMANDED
CONTROL APPROACHES.
THAT RELIED ON A MIX OF
SANCTIONS AND PUNISHMENT AND
TIME LIMITED FUNDING.
VARIOUS RESEARCH EVALUATIONS OF
THOSE PROGRAMS CONSISTENTLY
FOUND THEY TO NOT LEAD TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES AND
HAPPY TO GO TO MORE DETAIL ON
THE WISE IF YOU'RE INTERESTED
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS. THAT THE
PERFORMANCE GAPS THAT WE ARE ALL
GREATLY FOCUSED ON TODAY
PERSISTENT IN SOME WAYS
INCREASED UNDER THOSE EFFORTS ON
PASSED.
SO THEY DIDN'T REALLY WORK TO
ACHIEVE THE GOAL THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY APPROACH.
THAT PRIOR SYSTEMS WERE ALSO A
THE PERSISTENCE APPROACH TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SUPPORT WERE
ALSO DISJOINTED IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE UNDER TITLE ONE WE
CREATED WHICH IS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS A FEDERAL PROGRAM. ONE
REGIONAL SYSTEM OF SUPPORT YET
UNDER TITLE THREE WHICH IS
ANOTHER FEDERAL PROGRAM FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS THERE IS A
TOTALLY SEPARATE REGIONAL SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT. AND THEY'D WANT
COORDINATED IN THERE'S NO
COMMUNICATION AMONG THEM SO JUST
TO POINT OUT ABOUT THE CONCERN
ABOUT CREATING REDUNDANT
DUPLICATIVE SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT.
I ACTUALLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S
TRUE I BELIEVE THIS IS TRYING TO
REPLACE WHAT WERE DISJOINTED
SYSTEMS WITH A SINGLE INTEGRATED
SYSTEM THAT WILL BETTER SUPPORT
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS AND
ULTIMATELY STUDENTS.
WHY DOES IT MATTER TO HAVE A
COORDINATED SYSTEM
STEPHEN CAN BE AN ENGLISH
LEARNER OF FOSTER YOUTH AND OLD
LOW INCOME STUDENT?
BUT SHE'S NOT A SET OF LABELS
SHE'S A STUDENT WITH PARTICULAR
LEARNING NEEDS YET THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT THAT WE CREATED FOR
SCHOOLS WAS BASED ON LABELS AND
CATEGORIES.
AND THE BURDEN WAS ON DISTRICTS
TO RECONCILE AND RATIONALIZES
THE SPORTS THAT WERE AVAILABLE
TO DESIGN PROGRAMS THAT MET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS RATHER
THAN LABELS.
WE'VE LEARNED FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CURRENT APPROACH IS GOING TO
THAT IT WOULD MAKE A BETTER.
MAKE MAKE A BETTER WAY OF DOING
IT MAINLY WHAT WE'RE DAYS WERE
ASKING EDUCATORS AND
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO PHONE THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY FACE AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR IMPLEMENTING
SOLUTIONS TO IT BASED ON THE
DATA THAT THEY'RE SAYING ON
MULTIPLE MEASURES OF STUDENT
PERFORMANCE. INERT STATE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT IS GOING TO BE
OFFERED IN A COORDINATED MANNER
WHERE INSTEAD OF PUTTING THE
BURDEN ON DISTRICTS.
TO NAVIGATE AND FIND WHAT WORKS
FOR THEM THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY
ON THE STATE AGENCIES TO WORK
TOGETHER AND HELP DISTRICTS
CONNECT TO THE RESOURCES BUT
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS BASED ON THEIR DATA.
SO WITHOUT MINIMIZING THE WORK
THAT THE HEAD IS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY THERE ARE SOME PROMISING
SIGNS OF SUCCESS AND IT WON
SEVERAL PUBLIC COMMENTERS
REFERENCE THEIR LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTE SAY WHICH I WON'T
BELABOR. BUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS THAT DISTRICTS
THAT RECEIVE THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS UNDER LC FF ARE SHOWING
FASTER GAINS ON SOME OF THE
INDICATORS ON STUDENT ASSESSMENT
PARTICULARLY AROUND MATH. IN
ADDITION TO GATHER DATA POINTS
THAT IS HOMES HIGHLIGHTED
EARLIER.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY FINAL
POINT WHICH IS THIS ALL SOUNDS
NICE BUT WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE I
THINK WE'RE TALKING AT A VERY
HIGH LEVEL ABOUT POLICY WITH
THAT WE SOMETIMES LOSE TRACK OF
THE FACT THAT THIS IS OCCURRING
RIGHT NOW. DISTRICTS AND
COUNTIES ARE WORKING TOGETHER AS
WE SPEAK LOOKING AT THE DATA
THAT THEY GOT ON THE DASHBOARD
IT FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESPOND AND
BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS.
SO THIS GIVEN EXAMPLE THE
EXAMPLE I'M GONNA GIVE ACTUALLY
COMES FROM ONE OF THE LEARNING
NETWORKS THAT MISTER DANIELS
WILL TALK ABOUT IT AND IN A
MOMENT THAT THE CC  IS
PROVIDING. BUT THE APPROACH THAT
THEY'RE USING IS VERY SIMILAR TO
HELP COUNTIES OF WORKING WITH
DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED FOR
ASSISTANCE ON THE DASHBOARD.
IN THIS EXAMPLE DISTRICT STAFF
HAD COMPLETED A REVIEW OF DATA
AND IDENTIFIED UNDERLYING CAUSES
FOR SOME REALLY TROUBLING
SUSPENSION DATA. AND WHAT THEY
IDENTIFIED WERE GENERATIONAL
POVERTY FAMILY STRUCTURES IN THE
HOME AND LANGUAGE BARRIERS.
WHEN THEY CAME BACK THE NEXT
SESSION THE COUNTY OFFICE
FACILITATOR ASK THEM TO LOOK AT
WHAT THEY'VE IDENTIFIED IN
REFLECT ON WHETHER THEY COULD
CONTROL WHAT THEY HAD
IDENTIFIED.
THEY ENGAGE IN A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION WITH ACTUALLY
FOCUSED ON THINGS LIKE SCHOOL
DISCIPLINE POLICIES MINDSET
APPROACHING EXPECTATIONS OF
STUDENTS. AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT CAME TO A VERY DIFFERENT
SET OF UNDERLYING CAUSES THAT
THEY ACTUALLY COULD DO SOMETHING
ABOUT TO ADDRESS.
THAT'S A VERY DIFFERENT TYPE OF
CONVERSATION THEN WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF SOMEONE SHOULD UP WITH
A CLIPBOARD OR PRESCRIBE SAID
IF.
FIXES FROM SACRAMENTO BASED ON
DATA THAT WAS SHOWN.
SIMILAR CONVERSATIONS WHICH
REALLY FOCUSED ON MIND SET AND
CULTURE ARE TAKING PLACE RIGHT
NOW ACROSS THE STATE THIS IS
REALLY WHAT THIS NEW SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT IS FOCUSED ON IS
CHANGING THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AND LOOKING OF THE CULTURE OF
WHAT WE CAN PROVIDE TO OUR
STUDENTS AND IN FOCUSED ON THEIR
KNEES PARTICULARLY.
SO AFFORD TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS VERY MUCH DAVID.
THAT'S ARE GONNA THE LA SHOW FOR
ME BETWEEN THIS
LOOKS I'D MISS BROWN DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ALL THESE YEARS.
YEAH I THINK THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH RUN AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM PARK SINCE I'M
GONNA BUILD UPON WHAT'S UP
WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN BEEN TALKED
ABOUT WHICH IS TO TALK ABOUT
THREE ADDITIONAL THINGS WHICH
IS.
THE WORK THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
THAT DOING RELATED TO THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT THAT
THAT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT. GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE ON WHERE WE'RE AT
WITH THE ROLLOUT OF THAT THAT
DASHBOARD AND THEN AT JUST A
REALLY BRIEF UPDATE ON WHERE
WE'RE AT WITH THE AS A STATE
PLAN SAYS WE THINK ABOUT THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT. AND
ALTERNATE TO BE REPETITIVE ON
THIS ONE OF WHICH IS THE IT CAN
GET ITS ITS RECOGNIZING A
PARTNERSHIP AND EXPERTISE AND
IT.
A SUPPORT THAT DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF THE STATE CAN PROVIDE SO I I
THINK ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT WERE PLEASE BE PART
OF THAT AND SO THE GOAL. IS THAT
ALL OF A LEVELS TO ASSIST
ELEAZAR AND THEIR SCHOOLS TO
MEET THE NEED OF AB EACH STUDENT
SERVED WITH THE FOCUS ON
BUILDING CAPACITY TO TO
SUSTAINED IMPROVEMENT AND
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS INEQUITIES.
IN STUDENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
OUTCOMES AND IN ORDER TO
COORDINATE SUPPORT AT ALL LEVELS
THE AGENCIES CHARGED WITH
PROVIDING SUPPORT UNDER LCF
HAVE.
EXPANDED THEIR INITIAL CROSS
AGENCY GROUP TO INCLUDE
STAKEHOLDER PERSPECTIVES AND
PRACTITIONERS FROM THE FIELD
THIS LARGER TEAM IS A SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT PLANNING GROUP AND IS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS. COMMON
CONCERNS AND INTERESTS FROM THE
FIELD REGARDING SUPPORT FAMILIES
AND SCHOOLS SO SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS OF SUPPORT INCLUDE
INITIAL PATHWAYS TO SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE. AND SHOW OUT
RETALIATES AND REVIEW OF DATA SO
ADDRESS IT ADDRESSING STRINGS
AND UNDERLYING CAUSES FOR
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND ALSO
PROVIDING SUPPORT TALLIES IN
THEIR SCHOOLS TO IMPROVE STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
THAT'S THE.
AND SAID THAT THIS APPROACH HAS
I AM AT AT THE THREE OF THE KEY
CHIPS REFLECT THE INTENT THE
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE.
ADDED TO BE TAILORED TO LOCALLY
IDENTIFIED NEEDS RATHER THAN
IMPOSE ON A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
SOLUTION TO THAT'S I THINK WHAT
MR AT SAP TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE
BIT SO. IT'S SUPPORTING
PROVIDERS WORKING ALONGSIDE A
LIAISON THEIR SCHOOLS TO
IDENTIFY KEY CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES. USING A
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH AT TAYLOR TO
LOCALLY IDENTIFIED NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS AND ENGAGING WITH
LOCAL EDUCATORS AND COMMUNITIES
AS PART OF THAT DECISION MAKING.
WITH A DECEMBER RELEASE OF THE
DASHBOARD COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION HAVE BEGUN WORKING
WITHOUT LIAISE IDENTIFIED. OF
FOUR DIFFERENT SHE DID
ASSISTANCE OF THAT THAT LEVEL TO
ASSISTANCE.
AND THEIR WORK WHICH ALIGNS
WITH THE LC OF THAT STATUTE
INCLUDES INITIAL PERSONAL
CONTACT BETWEEN EACH COUNTY AND
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT AND THIS
A CONTACTED OCCUR BEFORE THE
RELEASE OF THE DASHBOARD. AND
THE WORK WILL CONTINUE WITH DATA
ANALYSIS AND UNDERSTANDING
UNDERLYING CAUSES WHICH WILL
INFORM ELEAZAR I'M. EL CAP AND
IT WOULD JUST ALSO NOTE THAT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS VESTED IN
THIS APPROACH AND WE HAVE
INTERNALLY.
ENGAGED IN EFFORTS TO BETTER
ALIGN THE WORK THAT WE DO AND
THINK IN A MORE COLLABORATIVE
WAY AND SO WE'VE DONE THIS
THROUGH ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT. WHICH
ACROSS DIVISION I'M EFFORT
LINKING STAFF WERE PROVIDING
SUPPORTS A DIFF DISTRICTS WITH
STAFF WERE A STANDARDS AND
CONTENT AT EXPERTS.
AND THAT FOCUSING ON SUPPORTING
A LIAISON THEIR WORK AND WE'RE
USING THE DASHBOARD TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS AND SAYS WE LOOK
AT THAT THAT DASHBOARD. THE AD
DEVELOPMENT OF THE DASH WHAT HAS
BEEN AN INTENSIVE EFFORT THAT
HAS BEEN UNDERWAY SINCE THE
STATE BOARD ADOPTED THE INITIAL
PHASE OF THE EVALUATION REPORT
BACK IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
AND WE CONTINUE TO INCORPORATE
INTENSIVE FEEDBACK FROM ANYWHERE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT SESSIONS AND
WORK GROUPS TO INFORM THE STATE
AND LOCAL INDICATORS.
IN AND THEN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THE FOR THE FALL TWO
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
DASHBOARD INCLUDES SEVERAL NEW
FEATURES TO IMPROVE THE
FUNCTIONALITY AN ARRAY OF NEW
RESOURCES TO INCREASE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT. AND UNDERSTANDING IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO USER
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE.
THAT INITIAL RELEASE OF A FIELD
TEST SORT OF IN THE SPRING
TWENTY SIXTEEN WE.
IMPROVED UPON THAT THAT
DASHBOARD INTO SOME OF THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE NEW DETAILED
REPORTS AND SO IN THREE PRIORITY
AREAS ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
SCHOOL CONDITIONS ON CLIMATE AND
ACADEMIC ENGAGEMENT. AND EACH
REPORT DISPLAYS THREE YEARS OF
DATA IS AVAILABLE FOR EACH
INDICATOR A STUDENT GROUP DATA
REPORTED FOR THE ACADEMIC
INDICATOR THE ACADEMIC INDICATOR
NOW REPORTS. DATA FOR ENGLISH
ONLY STUDENTS.
LISTING ALL SCHOOLS IN THE
DISTRICT SO WITH THIS FEATURE
VIEWERS CAN ACCESS ALL THE
INFORMATION ON ALL AYE SCHOOLS
IN A DISTRICT BY JUST PULLING UP
THE DISTRICTS M. AS THAT
DASHBOARD.
UPDATED VIDEO TUTORIALS AT THE
DASHBOARD HOMEPAGE CONTAINS A
VIDEO TO TRIAL THAT HIGHLIGHTS
THE FEATURES OF THE DASH BOARD
AGAIN TRYING TO MAKE IT. MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND THEN PDF
CAPABILITIES THAT WOULD ALLOW
YOU TO. ADD CREDIT PDF TO PRINT
IT
OTHER FUNCTIONALLY WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR EDUCATORS WHO HAVE
REQUESTED NUMEROUS TIMES TO
SHARE REPORTS WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
AN ANSWER CRITICAL INFORMATION
INTO THEIR AL CAPP.
I AM I WOULD SAY WE THINK WE
HAVE THE RIGHT DATEABLE WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK TO IMPROVE
THE ACCESSIBILITY AND
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE DASHBOARD
SO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
UNDER WAY. ARE INCLUDING ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE OF AN APPLE
OF AN APP FOR PHONE TWO THAT I'D
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BUDGET INCLUDED. FUNDING FOR
THAT DEVELOPMENT AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT BEING AVAILABLE
IN THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR WERE
AWESOME WELL SO WOULD LOOK TO
IMPROVE THE DASHBOARD HOMEPAGE
OF THE THAT GOVERNOR'S CRIME
BUDGET PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED.
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO UPDATE THE
DASHBOARD INTERFACE INTO THAT
WOULD HELP AGAIN WITH
ACCESSIBILITY. UP MAKING FURTHER
REVISIONS TO DASH BOARD REPORT
SO DISPLAYING THEIR PORTS WITHIN
THE DASHBOARD TO MAKE THEM LEX
TECHNICAL LESS TEXT HEAVY EXCUSE
ME AND MORE INTUITIVE FOR ALL
USERS. AND ALSO DOING SPANISH
TRANSLATIONS
AND. THAT AGAIN WORK WERE
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE AND ABOUT
THAT ABOUT THE DASHBOARD WE WE
DO RECOGNIZE THAT MORE
IMPROVEMENTS ARM OUR. NEED TO BE
MADE AND WE DO THINK THAT.
THAT IT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
PARENTS AND COMMUNITIES ARE
ALSO.
SOMETHING THAT THEY ALSO
SUPPORT THE USE SINCE IF WE LOOK
AT A SURVEY CONDUCTED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS. A RUSTY SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION A PILE AND PACE.
ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF
CALIFORNIANS SURVEYED TO SIXTY
ONE PERCENT AGREED THAT THE
INFORMATION ON THE DASHBOARD IS
AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO COMMUNICATE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS. AND MORE
THAN HALF AGREED THAT THE
DASHBOARD IS EASY TO USE.
AND CAPTURE SUPPORT MEASURES AND
DISTRICT SCHOOL OF DISTRICT AND
SCHOOL QUALITY SO OVERALL WORK
WERE POSITIVE ABOUT THAT THAT
ROLE AND LOOK FOR TO CONTINUED
IMPROVEMENTS ON THAT. AND THEN
THE LAST THING JUST TO NOTE
AROUND WHERE RAT WITH THE STATUS
OF THE AS STATE PLAN IT'S A
WE'VE PROVIDED UPDATES. TO THE
COMMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
VARIOUS FORMS IS THAT THAT.
CALIFORNIA STATE PLAN FOR A
FEDERAL FUNDING HAS BEEN UNDER
WAY TO THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION ADOPTED. THE STATE
PLAN BACK IN I'M SEPTEMBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT WAS
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. WE
RECEIVED INITIAL FEEDBACK AT THE
END OF THE YEAR SO LATE IN
DECEMBER MADE AT REVISIONS WERE
MADE TO THE PLAN THE BOARD
ADOPTED THOSE REVISIONS IN
JANUARY. AND THEN FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION RESULTED
IN FURTHER.
AT CHANGES IN MARCH AND AS WE
THINK WAS NOTED EARLIER SOME OF
THOSE CHANGES WORK WEREN'T QUITE
READY FOR I'M A CONSIDERATION BY
THE BOOK BY THE BOARD AT THE
MARCH MEETING INCLUDING AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENGAGE IN CONSIDER THOSE. AND SO
THERE'S A SPECIAL MEETING I'M
HAPPENING ON THURSDAY WERE
ULTIMATELY THAT I AM AT.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WE HOPE
THAT THE BOARD WILL ADOPT THE
PLAN THE CAN BE SUBMITTED AND WE
THINK THROUGH CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT
THAT WOULD BE IN A PROVABLE PLAN
AND THAT'S SORT OF WHAT COMPETE.
COMPLETE THE LAST PIECE OF.
AT THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM AND IT
WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS
SO MY CHARACTER READ BETWEEN THE
LINES HERE.
EVEN A LOT OF GOOD STUFF BEEN
VERY BUSY DON'T NEED ANYMORE AND
NEW IDEAS.
THEY GET RIGHT.
I WOULD SAY I I THINK WERE
OPENED IT TO HAVE MORE IDEAS
THAT AS LONG AS IT'S NOT
CHANGING THAT THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE THAT WERE UNDER WAY
WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN IMPROVE IT MAKE THE
INFORMATION THE POLITICIAN NOT
YOU.
OKAY MISTER DANIEL FOR.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
THEY ALL LEFT AND A AND STAFF.
JOSH DANIELS.
DIRECTOR OF TRAINING THAT WHICH
FOR THE. I CC  THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR INVITING US BACK TO
SPEAK I LIKE TO START BY JUST
EXPRESSING OUR APPRECIATION PER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. PROVIDE
OF IN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE CC EVE AS ONGOING
FUNDING. I THINK SETTING
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CONTINUE
THE WORK WE'VE BEEN DOING WHICH
IS WHY I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ALL.
I WAS HERE ABOUT A YEAR AGO TO
LET YOU KNOW WHAT THINGS WERE
GOING ON AT THAT TIME. BUT THAT
TIME WE WERE PRETTY NEW. I WAS
THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN SCHOOL
YEAR IT WAS REALLY THE FIRST
YEAR THAT WE HAVE BEEN AYE DOING
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING.
BUT NOW THEY'VE HAD A YOUR HONOR
OUR BELTS I WANT TO JUST TOUCH
ON A COUPLE OF THE KEY. AREAS.
PARTICULARLY AROUND OUR
COLLABORATION INNOVATION WITH
ELEAZAR AND AROUND OUR BOSS WHAT
INVOLVEMENT IN THE STATE WHAT
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES IN THE OPPOSITE OF
QUESTIONS HAPPY TO GO INTO. MORE
DETAIL.
WITH RESPECT TO COLLABORATION
INNOVATION WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THREE ELEAZAR ACROSS THE
STATE.
TO FOCUS ON HOW TO COMMUNICATE
BUDGET ISSUES INFORMATION.
LIKELY OUT FOR THE BUDGET
TRANSPARENCY
I WE'VE OFFERED IT DIDN'T DO ARE
DOING AND ENTER A PROCESS WHERE
EACH DISTRICT IS WORKING ON WAY
TO COMMUNICATE INFORMATION USING
TECHNOLOGY. HOT TESTING ON THE
FIELD AND THEN SORT OF GOING
BACK AND TESTING OUT AGAIN.
AND THEN WHATEVER WE LEARNED
FROM THAT PROCESS WOULD THEN BE
SHARED TO A BROADER AUDIENCE.
WE ALSO CONTINUE OUR ONE ON ONE
WORK OF MULTI YEAR WORK.
WITH ELEAZAR ACROSS THE STATE
ARE CURRENTLY THAT EIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ONE.
CAN OFFICE EDUCATION.
.
TOUCH TODAY AND YESTERDAY THAT
YOU HAD ONE OF OUR SORT OF EVERY
OTHER MONTH SUMMITS WHERE WE
BRING ALL OF THE. AT LEAST
TOGETHER.
AND TALK ABOUT THE WORK THAT'S
GOING ON SO THAT THEY CAN
COLLABORATE AND LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER.
I'M AND THEN WE ARE ALSO DOING
UPON REQUEST FROM.
VIC ELEAZAR CHARTER SCHOOLS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ONE ON ONE TOPICS.
PORT
SO A STAFF MEMBER RECENTLY WAS
IN A KNOT IN THE NORTH STATE.
WORKING WITH OP PRINCIPLES TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE DASHBOARD
NOW WORKING ON THE MARK WITH
ADDED EVALUATION.
WITH RESPECT TO THE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM SUPPORT MORE GENERALLY.
UNDER THE LEGISLATION THAT
PROVIDED FUNDING TO THE C. C. E.
IN A ONE TIME BASIS WE WILL BE
CONDUCTING ARE CONDUCTING. A
STATEWIDE SURVEY.
AS WAS MENTIONED BY MR SAP
EARLIER WE HAVE UP WHAT WE CALL
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORKS
THESE ARE FIFTY SIX NETWORKS.
ARE PRIMARILY RUN BY COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION BUT NOT
EXCLUSIVELY. THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY OVER THREE
JUNE FIFTY ELOISE PARTICIPATING.
AYE AND OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY INDIVIDUAL PARTICIPANTS
FROM THOSE EARLY DAYS BABY
REGULARLY AND THE. AUTHOR OF
THREE OF ACTION IS BY WORKING
TOGETHER LEARNING FROM EACH
OTHER.
ON A REGULAR BASIS THEY ARE
BUILDING CAPACITY AND IMPROVING
HOW THEY SERVE STUDENTS.
AND THEN LASTLY UP ON THE STATE
WHAT'S OF SUPPORT WE OFFER UP
FOR TOPIC SPECIFIC TRAINING
MODULES. FOR THIS YEAR.
ONE OF THEM IS ON JUST REGULAR
UPDATES OF THE ELK HAPPEN THE
DASHBOARD WITH A FOCUS ON A
FAMILIES.
SECOND IS MY FAVORITE NEW
ACRONYM
DICE UP DE AYE AYE S. U. P.
WHICH STANDS FOR. DEMONSTRATION
OF INCREASED OR IMPROVE SERVICES
FOR ON DUPLICATED PUPILS.
WHICH IS THE TITLE OF THE LAST
SECTION OF THE EL CAP.
YEAH I DO BETTER.
I WILL ACTUALLY THAT ONE HAS
HAS BEEN PRETTY PROFOUND IN OUR
WORK IN THAT HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT LATER NOT BECAUSE OF THE
ACRONYM THOUGH.
BECAUSE OF THE WORK.
WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON DATA
AND EVALUATION.
PARTICULAR WITH RESPECT TO
SMALL ELEAZAR HOW TO
UNDERSTANDING UTILIZE
INFORMATION IN THE DASHBOARD TO
DRIVE DISTRICT DECISION MAKING.
AND THEN LASTLY.
THIS WEEK
WE RELEASED OUR FIRST PODCAST
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FIELD TRIP.
AND IT IS A CONVERSATION WITH
THE MOTHER LODE .
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT
AND STAFF FROM THE EL DORADO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
MOTHER LODE WAS IDENTIFIED AS
ONE OF THE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY AT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEEDING. A
DEFECTIVE ASSISTANCE
AND IT'S ABOUT THEIR WORK WITH
THE COUNTY OFFICE AND THE
STRUGGLES AND SUCCESSES THAT
APPROACH
BUT THEY'VE TAKEN TOGETHER SO
IT'S ABOUT TWENTY MINUTES LONG.
AND I KNOW YOU'RE VERY BUSY BUT
IF YOU HAD THE OPPORTUNITY.
SUGGEST YOU CHECK IT OUT IT IS
OP OUT FEATURED PROMINENTLY. ON
OUR WEBSITE.
AND WITH THAT I WILL TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU THANK YOU.
TWENTY MINUTE PODCAST YEAH
LET'S.
SIDE LOOK FOR THAT I USUALLY AT
NIGHT IF I GO TO SLEEP RIGHT.
NOW THAT IT MIGHT KEEP YOU UP
SIR YEAH EXCITING STUFF.
WILL ANYTHING FROM THE SCIENCE
FAIR GO TO THE BEACH PUBLIC.
ANYBODY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
COMMENT ABOUT THAT.
THIS
I DON'T.
YOU WERE STILL HERE TO ENGAGE.
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JEFF AKA REPRESENTING
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS. ADJUST TO A COUPLE
OF QUICK POINTS NUMBER ONE HAS
THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
THAT'S REFLECTED IN HIS JANUARY
BUDGET.
DID BUILDING ON A POINT THAT MS
HOMES AND MR SAP MADE.
THIS IS LOOKING A LOT
DIFFERENTLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAN IT USED TO.
A THE DAYS WHEN THE COUNTY
OFFICE WOULD GO INTO A DISTRICT
WITH A BINDER FULL OF SOLUTIONS.
THAT WERE NOT RESEARCH DRIVEN
AND WE HAD NO WAY OF KNOWING
WHETHER THEY WERE GOING TO WORK
OR NOT.
NOW THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS
TAKING PLACE THAT ARE GOING INTO
THOSE ROOT CAUSES.
AND DETERMINING STRATEGIES THAT
WORK AND IT MAY LOOK DIFFERENT
IN EACH DISTRICT
AND THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
AND THEN LASTLY WITH RESPECT TO
A FISCAL CAPACITY.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY IS BLESSED TO
BE ONE OF THE HIGHEST FUNDED
COUNTIES BECAUSE OF WHERE WE
WERE. ABOUT AT THE ADOPTION OF
pTHE POINT OF HAVING TO TRIAGE
THE SUPPORT THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO DISTRICTS.
A SO THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT EXTRA FUNDING THAT'S
REFLECTED IN THE PROPOSAL IS
ESSENTIAL. AND PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE COUNTIES THAT ARE NOT IN
THE SAME POSITION THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR TRYING
TO KEEP IT TO ONE MINUTE AS WE
GET THROUGH THIS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MONEY GRIMACE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER.
OUT WE HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS SURROUNDING A CUT A
PROPOSED THREE MILLION DOLLAR
CUT IN TITLE THREE FUNDS TO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
THESE DOLLARS HAVE BEEN GOING TO
THE COUNTIES FOR YEARS TO PAY
FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
ME.
OFTEN THESE ARE THE ONLY STAFF
AT THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WITH E. L. EXPERTISE.
AND WE ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
CONCERNS THAT WITHOUT THE STAFF
WHO HAD HIS EXPERTISE FOR MANY
YEARS THERE WON'T BE THE
SUPPORTS.
THEY ARE TO CENTER THERE WON'T
BE THE STAFF THERE TO SUPPORT
DISTRICTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING.
JUST FOR A POINT OF REFERENCE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THERE'S ONE
HE'LL EXPERT HOUSE DID YOU
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WHO
SERVING SEVEN DIFFERENT COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SUSAN BORNEO WITH
COUNSEL FOR A STRONG AMERICA
FIGHT CRIME INVEST IN KIDS.
WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO SEE
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT THAT ARE
BEING CALLED OUT AND SUPPORTED
OUR FINANCIAL ALONG WITH THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AS
THE VERY FIRST LINE OF SUPPORT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO CALL IT AGAIN.
SCHOOL CLAIM IT AS AN ISSUE THAT
WE BELIEVE THE PUBLIC PUTS A
VERY HIGH PRIORITY ON.
AND WE FEEL THAT IT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE TO.
FOLLOWING ON THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS TO HAVE EXPERTS WITHIN
A COUNTY NOT JUST FOR THAT ONE
COUNTY THAT THEY CAN BE CALLED
UPON. UP BY OTHER COUNTIES IN
THE SURROUNDING REGION AS WELL
AND THAT INVESTING MONEY IN
DEVELOPING PARTICULAR EXPERTISE
AROUND SOME OF THE. AREAS.
LIKE SCHOOL CLIMATE.
THIS MONEY WILL GO FARTHER IN
THE SUPPORT WILL GO FURTHER.
FOR ALL OF THE SCHOOLS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CZERWINSKI AND
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES ON WE
AGREE VERY STRONGLY WITH THE
THEORY OF CHANGE BEHIND ALL CFF
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT THAT.
WAS LAID OUT VERY ELOQUENTLY BY
MR STRAP IN MS HOMES TODAY.
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO FUND A THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT WORK BUT IN OUR VIEW IT
IS NOT ENOUGH.
AND IT IS WHAT IS BEHIND THE A
PROPOSAL THREE IN THE PRIOR
AGENDA ITEM THAT YOU JUST HEARD.
REGARDING INCREASING THE
CAPACITY STATEWIDE FOR
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT AND
ASSESSMENT OF SCHOOL CLIMATE.
ALL THE EFFORTS THAT YOU HEARD
ABOUT WE AGREE WITH WE THINK
THEY'RE RIGHT.
BUT THEY DON'T GO DEEPLY ENOUGH
AND THEY'RE NOT ENOUGH TO
REALLY.
AREN'T TAKEN ROOT AT THE LEVEL
WHERE IT'S NEEDED SO THAT LOCAL
CONTROL CAN TRULY BE LOCAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS VERY MUCH.
YES SIR PROUD STRONG CHILDREN
NOW ECHO SOME OF THE THE COMMENT
YOU JUST HEARD ALSO.
CHILDREN NOW IS.
IN TERMS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
FUNDS THAT ALLOCATED TO THE
OFFICES OF EDUCATION FOR THE
DIFFERENTIATED WORK. I'M AS WELL
AS THE FUNDS ALLOCATED TO THE CC
IN THE SOUTH BUT I'M
REGIONAL EFFORTS. AND TO
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE SEE ONE
AND WE THINK THAT THE LEVEL ONE
SUPPORTS OF THE OVER ARCHING
JUST THE LEVEL.
OVERALL ONE.
TAT LEVEL ONE SUPPORT. AND THAT
BE AVAILABLE TO ALL SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS IT.
ARE CURRENTLY IN A LACKING IN
AND COULD
COULD BE RIGHT MORE ROBUST.
FINALLY WE BELIEVE THAT THE.
ARE WE THAT WE ADVOCATE FOR THE
LEAD COE STRUCTURE.
MENTIONED.
PREVIOUSLY AND ALSO IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
VERY MUCH SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER STEVE
HENDERSON NOW REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS.
I JUST LIKE TO.
REFERENCE MY COMMENTS TO THE
MONEY THAT'S IN THE BUDGET FOR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO HELP
DISTRICTS WITH THE.
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND COUNTY
OFFICES PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
FACILITATING THE REDUCE REVIEW
OF DATA AND ALSO THE ANALYSIS.
ACTING COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THE DATA AND SO THEY
CAN PRODUCE THEIR OWN PLAN FOR A
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE COUNTY OFFICES
WORK TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY
RESOURCES AND BEST PRACTICES. TO
ADDRESS UNDERLYING STUDENT POOR
PERFORMANCE WE ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THAT AUGMENTATION
THEY VERY MUCH SIR.
MICHAEL HALL CESAR AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS WE
JUST WANT TO. COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE SPECIFICALLY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STATE
BOARD IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
FOR NOT ONLY THE FUNDING THAT
ARE PROVIDED FORCES
MS OF SUPPORT BUT ALSO THE
CLARIFICATIONS IN THE TRAILER
BILL. THAT WE THINK REALLY ARE
GOING TO MAKE THE SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT ON THE INSTRUCTIONAL
SIDE NOW STARTING WITH
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
WHAT A LOT MORE LIKE THE
COLLABORATION THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN COUNTY OFFICES. AND
THICK MAT ON THE FISCALLY BE
TWELVE HUNDRED SIDE.
WE THINK THE SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT
EFFORT REALLY PROVIDES FOR THIS
KIND OF CONTINUITY.
IN THE WORKING TOGETHER THAT
THAT THAT WE NEED.
CLEARLY THE TRAILER BILL
IDENTIFIES SOME VERY IMPORTANT
NEW RESPONSIBILITIES IN TIER ONE
WORK FOR COUNTY OFFICES.
I IT REQUIRES ALL COUNTY OFFICES
TO PROVIDE. A GREAT DEAL OF
ASSISTANCE TO EVERY DISTRICT IN
THEIR COUNTY PARTICULARLY
DISTRICTS THAT ARE IN NEED OF
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE AND WE
WELCOME.
WE WELCOME THAT CLARIFICATION SO
WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
THINKING
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS SIR.
I DO.
NOW GET ALL THAT DONE.
MISS BROWN.
CHIU BUT YOUR BACK AND WE WERE
DOING THIS.
THE HAVE.
WHO IS THE PRIMARY AUDIENCE OF
THE DASHBOARD?
WE ARE WE HAD A BIG DISCUSSION
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO DEVELOP
THE STASH WHERE WE HAD A LADY IN
HERE FROM DAVIS WHO. HAD ALL THE
DATA POINTS DO MEMBER WHO THE.
PRIMARY AUDIENCE IS AND WE
REMEMBER THAT. WHY DID WE DO THE
DASHBOARD WHO IS THE PRIMARY
AUDIENCE I THINK HE'S GOING TO
GRAB THAT ONE POINT?
OKAY.
DAVID'S SAVER.
SHE MAY HAVE TO SAVE ME.
SO I I.
I I THINK THAT THAT'S.
THAT'S IN ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
IS THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE MULTIPLE
AUDIENCES FOR YOU KNOW YOU'VE
EDUCATORS WHO WANT.
DEEPER DATA AND HOW TO ANALYZE
IT AND OF COURSE THERE'S PARENTS
IN THE PUBLIC THIS IS PART OF A
THAT YOU KNOW COUNT ABILITY ANY
LOCAL ENGAGEMENT THAT THAT
THEY'RE DIFFERENT AUDIENCES.
AND I THINK THAT WHEN THE THINGS
THAT THE REDESIGN THAT MISS
BROWN ALLUDED TO THAT IS ALREADY
UNDER WAY WANTED THING THAT
INCLUDES IS A MUCH CLEAR
STATEMENT OF WHAT IS THE PURPOSE
OF THE DASHBOARD. AND IS TRYING
TO CLARIFY THE PRIMARY AUDIENCE
IS THE PUBLIC PARENTS AND IN THE
BROADER THE BROADER PUBLIC THEIR
ADDITIONAL RICH DATA RESOURCES
THAT EXISTS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
MAINTAINS. THERE'S DATAQUEST
THERE'S THE ASSESSMENT WEBSITE
THE CAST THAT WEBSITE THAT SHOWS
THE RESULTS THE DEPARTMENT IS
ACTUALLY CREATED SPECIAL
REPORTS.
FOR SOME OF THE INDICATORS ON
THE DASHBOARD THAT INCLUDED A
MORE RICH BREAKDOWN OF THE DATA.
SAID THINKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN
YOU USE THE DASHBOARD AND POINT
PEOPLE TO THOSE OF RICHER
DATASET FOR EDUCATORS OTHERS WHO
DON'T WANT TO DIG DEEPER AND. IN
PARENTS AND THE PUBLIC WHO
ULTIMATELY SOME OF THEM DO WANT
TO DIG DEEPER BUT NOT ALL OF
INDIA AND THINKING ABOUT THE
AUDIENCE A LITTLE MORE CAREFULLY
AND GET THE GOVERNOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL MONEY. THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO.
THERE'S AN EXPERIENCE ON HOW TO
DO IT AND THINK ABOUT HOW YOU
CAN PRESENT INFORMATION IN A WAY
THAT'S MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
INTUITIVE TO THE GENERAL
AUDIENCE WHILE STILL MAKING IT
MEANINGFUL IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO
CLICK IT LEVELS DOWN TO GET TO
THAT DETAIL IF YOU WANT IT. SAY
I I THINK THAT YOUR QUESTION IS
THE RIGHT ONE.
I THINK THERE IS A STRUGGLE WITH
WHICH THE RIGHT AUDIENCE WAS AND
I THINK WE'RE REALLY FOCUSING
THE PRIMARY AUDIENCE SHOULD BE
PARENTS. AND THE PUBLIC IN THAT
WE CAN USE OTHER DATA RESOURCES
TO MEET THE NEED OF EDUCATORS
FOR RICHARD DATASETS EXACTLY
RIGHT HE WAS FOR THE PARENT
BECAUSE. MEMBER HOW WE STARTED
THIS TIME.
CAPITAL YOU HAVE A MEMBERS
BETTER SIX YEARS.
WHEN WE STARTED THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING.
USE ARE GOING TO GO DOWN THAT WE
SAID WELL THAT'S GOING TO BE
LOCAL. THEN WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
PEOPLE ENGAGED SO WE DEVELOPED
THE EL CAP.
AND THEY SAID SO WE'RE GOING TO
BE PUT THE MONEY IN THERE HOW DO
WE KNOW IT'S ACTUALLY ME WORK
AND I MEMBER HAVE BEEN HEARING.
SOME LADY CAME FROM DAVIS WAS
SAYING  YOU NEED ALL
DIFFERENT.
POINTS AND I REMEMBERED AT TONY
SAID YOU KNOW YOU'RE SITTING
HERE.
TELL US WHAT YOU LOOK AT.
BUT I THINK THE AVERAGE PARENT
IS ACTUALLY AT WORK TONIGHT HERE
AT A HEARING IN SACRAMENTO.
AND WHAT THEY WANT TO KNOW IS
BEING LOOKED UP QUICKLY AND
THAT'S IT.
BACK THEN WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
WERE DASHED WHAT IS ACTUALLY MY
TERM I SAID BACK IN THE IN THE
MILITARY WORLD WE USE A
DASHBOARD LOOK AT COLORS WE CAN.
LOOK AT AND SAY THERE'S A
PROBLEM HERE IS NOT A PROBLEM
HERE
BUT THEN YOU CAN THAT CAN DO IT
AND GO.
ALL THE DETAILS YOU WANT TO AND
JUST HAVE FUN FOREVER.
OR YOUR PARENTS TO LOOK AT IS IS
OKAY MY KIDS ARE DOING WELL.
AND SO THAT'S JOB THAT'S HOW WE
STARTED THIS SO THAT'S WHY WE.
TRYING BACK TO THE QUESTION
WHERE DID IT.
TERM DASHBOARD GAME IT WAS
GLOBAL PRO FUNDING LUCK AT.
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE DASHBOARD
IT WAS DESIGNED PRIMARY FOR THE
PARENTS TO GET HIM ENGAGED.
THESE THAT'S WHY WE CALL THE
HISTORY OF IT.
THE.
MISS CORTEZ YOU'RE IN YOUR
ANALYSIS OF THIS.
WHEN YOUR RECOMMENDATION.
THE.
THERE'S A TERM I LEARNED A LONG
TIME AGO AN ORGANIZATION
DYNAMICS THAT YOU CAN'T.
MAKE SOMEBODY RESPONSIBLE FOR
SOME LESSER ACCOUNTABLE FOR.
THEY GOT TO BE ABLE AFFECTED BY
THE EYES DOES HAPPEN. AND WHEN I
WAS LISTENING TO THE
PRESENTATION.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ALL THESE DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONSI ASKED MY STAFF
TO DO AN ORG CHART FOR ME ON HOW
THIS WORKED.
AND IT WAS REALLY LIKE AN
OCTOPUS. ALWAYS THINGS GOING
AROUND.
.
SO I DON'T REALLY BUY INTO THAT.
I THINK I AGREE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION PHILIP FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
RULES ARE GENERALLY.
.
YOU CAN HAVE A CENTRALIZED
GOALS.
AND.
VISION AND THAT'S WHAT WE DO UP
HERE.
BUT YOU NEED DECENTRALIZED
EXECUTION TO GET IT DONE
BECAUSE.
FRESNO IS DIFFERENT OF SAN
DIEGO'S DIFFERENT AN ALLY AND WE
ARE PROFESSIONALS AT ALL THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT.
OUR TRAINED TO DO THIS AND IF
THEY NEED ASSISTANCE IN THE
COUNTY THAT GETS IN BOEING START
THOUGH ON A BUNCH OF FINGERS IN
THEM PIE.
THE NO ONE'S RESPONSE WHERE WE
SUCK ENOUGH MONEY IN THE END THE
DAY WE GOT.
NOTHING.
SO I FROM MY POSITION. I LIKE
THE LA OWES RECOMMENDATION AND.
HOPE YOU GO LOOK AT IT THAT
WHICH YOU WANT TO WE CAN NOW
TALK ABOUT IT LATER.
AS ANYTHING ELSE.
REALLY LOVE THIS AND YOU CAN'T
TELL I GET A KICK OUT OF THIS
ONE THIS IS
IT WAS IN THE GROUP HAVE WATCH
IT COME THROUGH FOR ALL THESE
YEARS.
WE'RE DONE.
I DO HAVE A LOT OF.
HOWEVER.
YEAH.
OKAY
AND I CAN'T HELP.
NO